good morning it being 9 A.M we are going
to go ahead and start our committee
hearings for the day and I would ask
representative Marston to lead us in the
Pledge of Allegiance
allegiance to the flag of the United
States of America and to the Republic
for which
one nation under God indivisible with
liberty and justice for all
and I am going to go ahead and open the
hearing on HP 1414 I don't have a gavel
so I'm going to bang this thing
and at this time I would recognize
the bill
oh
purpose today so if you get
she needs to be what
um
oh really
one minute
over here
just stand by we're having a logistical
Barrel
foreign
query from the Bill's sponsor
uh good morning uh thank you chairman
and members of the committee for the
record my name is Joshua query and I
represent Hillsboro district 16 which is
Manchester's Ward 9.
I'm here today to introduce House Bill
1414 which requires the state police to
submit an annual report on traffic
violations
the bill aims to collect data including
where the violations occurred type of
violation whether it was primary or
secondary offense
if the citation was paid on time or at
all
and where where applicable how many
warnings were issued
currently there is no place or way to
find out this information
the goal of this bill is to help inform
future legislators in creating new
traffic laws and or help to inform
decisions when readdressing current
traffic and road safety concerns
furthermore for the last three years I
have served on the public works and
highways committee right across the hall
where we work closely with the
Department of
transportation and Department of Safety
where statistics like these can often
help us make educated decisions on where
to invest improvements to Granite State
roadways having access to this data will
allow us and future legislators the
ability to make informed decisions on
how to assist our state troopers and
making the roadways of New Hampshire
much safer
uh
I'm going to be real brief so thank you
for your time and happy to take any and
all questions that you have
are there any questions
representative Rhodes
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question you had mentioned
that
this
that this report that the that the
police officer was supposed to gather
whether or not the penalty was paid and
if on time
is is there somebody in in an
administrative that that would do that
or is the police officer expected to
call around to these municipalities to
find out or to call the court to find
out this is actually paid
uh thank you for the question
um when I talked with this uh State
Police office earlier this year
um they informed me that they do have
this information for individual uh
violations so I don't expect it to be
the individual Troopers that would be
collecting this but it would be more of
an administrative office that would be
collecting this information
yep
representative testerman
wonders of
how we'll improve our highways and our
byways and stuff like that
I'm trying to understand how
number of
citations that are paid are not paid
how the gender or race of the person
would affect that can you explain how
how you would use that to decide where
to pave or where to where to put
yeah uh thank you for that question
um
those were additional things that uh
after working with co-sponsors and the
office of legislative services that we
felt would eventually might be requested
and so we included it early on that way
it didn't have to be amended in future
future years my goal is to get the types
of of violations mainly speed or safety
violations so I can make those in
informed decisions like I was saying in
across the hall
follow
can you take
can you take a
situation and explain to me
how a citation would be used in in our
roadway design or whatever I mean I'm
trying to understand
you know maybe because there's too many
of them or whatever but could you could
you explain to me how you would intend
to use these
yeah um so working with the Department
of Transportation different roadways do
have the ability to handle different
speeds
and flow of traffic
um so knowing that a lot of people are
speeding
um or that there are severe road safety
issues with them speeding will allow us
to plan better for our highways so that
if someone does speed in an area that
they won't cause a catastrophic accident
any further questions
seeing um thank you for your testimony
thank you
at this time the chair recognizes
um I'm not I believe it's a trooper
Victor Mozzy
thank you chairman and members of the
committee
um for this opportunity to speak to you
this morning my name is Victor Muzzy I
am a lieutenant with the New Hampshire
State Police currently in charge of
record Information Services
which encompasses a few areas of the
State Police
and I'm also the project manager
consequently enough for our new records
management system that we just went live
with in June
and
I guess the state police's position on
this this bill as proposed with the
language contained therein while we
would support the idea of an annual
report I think the the way the language
is written is what we would oppose
for the following reasons at the moment
given our practice and our standards
relative to traffic citations
uh while we have the ability to collect
things like race
uh in particular that's not a
requirement at the moment it's not a
required field in our in our system nor
is it a required field for either the
court or the DMV to adequately
um
process if you will the traffic citation
furthermore the race portion of the
language that's contained in the bill is
concerning because uh scheduling of that
through the DM
V or through the process of of receiving
a license
so that would be left to speculation I
suppose on the part of our Troopers when
it came to determining race if in fact
we were required to collect that
information pursuant to the language and
the bill here so I would offer that if
the bill is passes that there would have
to be an additional mandate if you will
to collect that information at the time
of credentialing
um so that it's consistent and accurate
otherwise we're going to rely on guesses
or speculation or other information that
is not going to add to the reliability
of the statistics relative to that
particular
data point
at the moment we don't record uh primary
or secondary offense other than by RSA
but certainly we would have the ability
to do that given the con the uh the
confines of the new records management
system certainly the street municipality
uh the age
the number of citations
I'm sorry the number of warnings those
are all things that we could we could
report out now and we do by way of our
annual report it doesn't break down
certainly the roadways that these
offenses have occurred on nor the
individual offenses but that's something
that we could certainly add
our issue with the number of citations
paid on time the number of citations
paid late and the number of citations
where payment was not collected is
that's not a function of the State
Police that's a function of the Division
of Motor Vehicles I don't have any
first-hand knowledge on how they collect
that or how they track that I would
suspect that they do however that's
that's not a function of the State
Police so that would be a problem for us
the way the bill is written in order to
report out on that as far as a state
police responsibility so that's that's
of concern I think also
um
I lost my train of thought
so again while we're in support of the
idea of this information to assist with
making the roadways safer where these
violations are occurring to help do our
DOT determine uh where there may be
problem areas I think some of the
demographics as they're stated in the
language will be difficult and I don't
think that those demographics will
necessarily be accurate which I think is
a problem if that's in fact what we're
looking for and I believe it is
based upon credentialing drivers and how
we would capture that information
and I'm happy to take any and all
questions
thank you for your testimony Trooper
representative Newman has a question
thank you for taking my question
um
about a month ago
three members of this committee took a
had a briefing over at the Department of
Motor Vehicles yes sir and we had a very
long discussion about race and the
difficulty of being able to
gather it on site but I I may have might
not understand stood something
but I always give I took away from that
meeting an impression that specifically
race because that's the one that is the
is the guessing and all the whole thing
there currently is as I understand it
drop down menus
and they have selections and some of
them are other and they even had one for
ethnicity
um so
my question is it sounded to me as
though you collect some data on race
and enter it somewhere for some reason
would the state police have an objection
to including whatever data you now
currently add to it and perhaps what
happens in the future
where it's as simple as it appears to be
now
to including that data
in a report if this bill were to pass
that required some kind of report
I I don't think the state police would
be opposed and if I may elaborate a
little bit
um as you recall I I was at that at that
meeting with you folks and
um and I didn't speak to it at the
moment only because we're talking
traffic citations so what I will clarify
is that yes in the in the process uh and
as as you folks probably are all fully
aware on the on the face of any traffic
ticket there is a box to cut to gather
race uh there is also that same box
within our electronic process to gather
that however it's not required the
options currently in that in the course
of of crafting a traffic ticket our
American Indian Asian black unknown or
white I would say that we do have a
percentage of Troopers that likely fill
that out if they can make a reasonable
determination
however I'm sure there are just as many
if not more in there it's left blank so
as to not
gather information that may not be
accurate
where we are required to gather race as
a part of a neighbors reporting which is
our higher
reporting Authority when it comes to
crime data and arrests
is just that when we arrest someone we
are required to gather their race
that
data point is gathered by way of asking
the person what their race and ethnicity
is so while the traffic ticket doesn't
have the ability to capture ethnicity
it does have the ability to capture race
however in the course of arresting
someone in gathering that information
pursuant to the arrest we can and are
required to capture both race and
ethnicity
if that makes sense thank you for your
question
follow-up
would that then be an additional burden
or could you with the systems you have
now could you
report that information in this
for traffic tickets
I would have to work with Defender to
craft a report
that would report out exactly as as
you've got here that doesn't exist at
the moment that doesn't mean we can't do
that I don't know what the associated
cost may be to generate that report on a
regular recurring basis but what I can
say is we do capture or have the ability
to capture that information and I
suspect could produce a report should
the bill
passion and I understand that and I
wouldn't be
my own thing I would not be looking for
you doing additional stuff that was was
like that because you just have the data
and if you can report it out then you
could include it in something like that
if you found it correct and if I
understand you correctly we could
potentially report out on whatever data
we've collected as long as what you're
saying is it's not required
then
we will report out on whatever we have
gathered I guess to answer that fully
representative Platt yes you use the
terms race and ethnicity yes could you
distinguish between the police so I
understand
race as I understand it
um is more broadly defined where
ethnicity is more narrowly defined with
respect to
someone's
um
nationality or what you know origin I
guess race is more Broad
ethnicity is more narrowly defined
within that race as I understand it
um thank you I'm going to go ahead and
ask a question myself
um
to what you said originally would it not
be easier if the DMV just included this
on the driver's license I mean your
answer to the question regarding race
and ethnicity seems to um
demonstrate that it's it's a guessing
game
it certainly would be easier I don't
know what the process would be or what
would be required of
what the DMV would require to credential
that from our perspective it certainly
would be we certainly don't aren't set
out to offend people or assume things
it's a little uncomfortable frankly to
have to ask people especially on a
traffic stop that happens
thousands of times per day what their
race might be an arrest is a little
different
so it certainly would be easier for us
if that were built into the process by
way of credentialing yes
thank you represent representative
Rhodes
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question we did have a similar
bill that we heard
um in the
in the first half of our term that had a
lot to do with this would you would you
say that when you have to guess a
person's age gender race or
ethnicity would be
considered under the definition of
profiling
I suppose to an extent I don't know if
profiling to me has a negative
connotation I suppose so
I
I guess it probably could lead to that
and I think if nothing else it could be
offensive to somebody who then gets a
copy of my traffic ticket where I've
I've indicated on there something that
isn't accurate
um that's I guess personally my fear
with with that
a data point is that I've tried to make
an educated guess and and failed and I'm
you know I may be offensive to somebody
so I guess
having
what is currently the an unofficial
process to gather that I would say could
be considered profiling
um
for lack of a better term when it comes
to our current process of gathering that
sure
representative Martian
yes sir
age
I think the annual report that we
generate is not required and maybe I'm
wrong I I don't know whether it is or it
isn't I think out of good practice we
generate both a calendar year report and
an annual report which contains
um
data relative to how many traffic stops
we conducted how many warnings we issued
how many summonses we issued I think
this bill lends further depth to the
statistics as I understand it we don't
report out on individual rsas or
roadways to the extent that the bill is
is looking to do this would certainly be
more comprehensive and likely more
valuable
I think as a matter of
um not common practice but when there is
a concern or an issue or some reason
for us to take a look at statistics on a
given roadway we do that on a one-off
basis now if something pops up it is a
problem so while it may seem redundant I
think the intent of the bill here is
really looking for more depth and
clarity as to
you know it wasn't that we issued a
hundred thousand citations throughout
the state but where did we issue those
what road was it on was it a speed is
this road and I think to the to the
uh credit of of the sponsors you know I
if that's the if that's the the intent
of the bill I think it this
annual report would lend more clarity
and help on that than what we currently
report on
follow-up
yes sir
got them
thank you
um so in regards to profiling
um do you
normally when you're putting out like a
search warrant do you say like six five
white male
for a search warrant for a person yeah
not as a matter of general practice if
we know the individual that we're
looking to search we're usually trying
to identify them by name date of birth
driver's license number Social Security
number
those data points don't typically come
into play on a search warrant okay
thank you
um do you use that type of information
sometimes to look for somebody
uh yep okay yep all right a wanted
person or something yes
thank you
thank you for answering questions
um so if I get back to what you said
earlier you do not collect
information on the number of citations
paid citations uh not collected
is that true
and are you also indicated you don't
report the location of the citation no
no we we we don't report out on it we
gather that at the moment and and so as
far as the location of the citation yes
that is gathered that is captured in our
records management system it's not
something that we currently report out
on but I I don't see why we couldn't at
some point should we be required to
relative to payment of citations how
many are paid late how many aren't paid
that's a function of the Division of
Motor Vehicles not the division of State
Police I can't speak intelligently to
that I suspect they capture that they
must in fact because if you don't pay a
traffic summons that typically goes into
default and whatnot and gets sent to the
court so while the state police doesn't
do that I think the state of New
Hampshire by way of DMV probably does
in a matter of safety uh is there
another report that's issued as far as
accidents are happening and where and
location
Etc
not necessarily that's public facing and
not for any good reason I think that
information is probably shared with New
Hampshire highway safety Federal Highway
Safety and D.O.T
um
I don't know specifically what that
report may or may not look like but to
my knowledge we don't generally speaking
have any public display of that but
again I don't see why we couldn't do
that but I do know we share that with
our internal and external business
partners as a matter of safety and as a
matter of
requirement really with the federal
government to to report out on where
these things are occurring which I
suspect they take into account when it
comes to roadway design and speed limits
and as does the state DOT I suspect
thank you very much
um
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking the question sir how uh following
up on my colleague's question about uh
somebody's race being identified if
they're wanted or if there's a press
release out to the media how does the uh
do State Police identify someone's race
in that circumstance if they've never
had any interaction with them or had any
self-identification by the suspect I
think that race would likely be
identified typically very broadly
speaking and it would probably only
Encompass the folks that are
extreme and I think sometimes that
description can include a mix of wraith
race and ethnicity
um I think sometimes descriptions can be
black white Hispanic Hispanic is not a
race it's an ethnicity so I think those
types of things are what we would
typically either gather from people that
are reporting the event and describing
the individual that's missing or wanted
in that manner or
by other official means such as
photographs that we may have and things
that the common person may be able to
describe somebody given their appearance
if that makes sense
thank you and along those same lines
could you use that same standard you
just described and could the troopers on
the road were encountering individuals
and subjects throughout their day could
they use that same standard
um to gather the data as contemplated by
this bill
probably I don't know what the accuracy
of that would be if and maybe maybe the
intent is not accuracy it's just
capturing it I don't know but
I think the trouble is is is now
you know where it's an optional field
for us so far as traffic citations go I
think if it's immediately apparent
and the trooper is so inclined they
include that if it's not immediately
apparent
and it you know wouldn't be in the
future I think what you're going to get
is unknown
um in that in that drop down so
we could use the same standard to answer
your question yes I just fearful of what
the reliability or the usefulness of
that data would end up being
representative true
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question sir
um
individuals were interested in looking
at that where would they find those
I don't know the answer to that
I don't know the answer to that whether
that's something that we post on our
website whether that's something that we
print and is publicly available through
the Commissioner's Office it is prepared
for the commissioner of safety through
his office so I don't I don't know
whether we physically print that and
distribute that whether we post that on
our website in some capacity
what the extent of our distribution of
that is
thank you
um I recognize myself for another
question one of my colleagues just asked
you with regard to a wanted person you
know you may put out over the air be on
the lookout for uh you know a six foot
two white male or black male
is that not
um often the result of a victim or
witness that gave you that description
it can be yes
thank you
that's the question of the share
when we were in our briefing we had a
thing about the drop down menus or what
was actually get a copy of of that the
drop down menus so that you could see I
think other was one of them
so I don't think they guess I mean they
ask and they get an answer and a lot of
times they don't know if it's true or
not so I think it would it would be a
beneficial to the committee just to know
what's on the drop down menus they have
now to understand what data they collect
and how and why they collect it
that sounds like a reasonable request
would you be able to provide us with a
screenshot yes sir I appreciate it thank
you and
again I
race and ethnicity I presume is what the
committee would be looking for those
those two drop downs and what the
variables are the only other thing I can
add to that real quick is that the FBI
has got from what I understand and I
haven't had the time to research this
there's there's two different race lists
and and I don't mean to muddy the water
I just put that out there as there is a
a federal standard I suppose as to what
the race list is and what the ethnicity
ethnicity list is but I will certainly
provide to the committee what we have
currently in that list and I if need be
I can determine the origin or the
guidelines by which that lift list was
crafted if need be yeah whatever you
could provide from both in-house or the
FBI records we would appreciate our
consideration thank you any further
questions
there being none thank you very much I I
called you Trooper it looks like you're
a lieutenant I apologize
very good I appreciate it thank you
members of the committee for your time
is there anyone else wishing to testify
on this bill
there being none I'm gonna close the
hearing on HB 1414.
yes sir
we have about a 13 14 minutes before our
next hearing so we'll stand in recess
okay everybody it being uh 9 45. I'm
going to go ahead and open the hearing
on HP 1475.
who's the sponsor
you
representative trottier is recognized
good morning
just a second if I could
um to all the committee members as well
please make sure that you get the mic on
when you talk and get it close enough to
your mouth that it picks up for us thank
you go ahead
good morning Mr chair and members of the
criminal justice and Safety Committee my
name is Douglas trottier I am a
representative out of District Six
Belknap County serving the town of
Belmont
I come before you today with more of a
housekeeping matter
um this is going to be in relations to
the powers of the New Hampshire Liquor
enforcement investigators
they currently
um get their powers under 179.59
however I feel when back in the 90s when
these legislative body
um passed this they made an error
they gave the Commissioners or the
commission the power to hire or appoint
investigators and give them the power of
any sheriff in any County
whereby a sheriff is a constitutional
officer along with a superior court
officer
and the sheriffs are appointed where
liquor investigators are not and at that
time when they gave that they did not
change the they did not ratify the
Constitution to add liquor investigators
as a constitutional officer which I
don't think was their intent so my
proposal is I think I passed around an
amendment all I'm trying to do is change
the wording
from all the powers of the sheriff in
any County
and replace it with the investigator
she'll have powers State wider or powers
or jurisdiction throughout the state
and pretty much
that's what I'm looking to do
thank you um a quick read of the
amendment it says that you intend to
give them Statewide power over all laws
um is it your intent to make them
similar to a trooper the ability to
force all criminal laws no but based
basically but sometimes they do go into
establishments
whereby a cry might happen in their
presence and this will allow them to
have power to take action well without
being questioned if they're authorized
to do so
thank you
questions for the witness
representative Gathering
So currently if they run into a
situation what they have to call the
police department
no technically they uh
under this statue they still have the
powers to enforce all laws
but my concern is where it says they
they powers of a sheriff whereby a
sheriff can do civil process being a
superior court officer they do have the
right to do bails on certain warrants
where they're Superior Courts
um
but at this point they still liquor
investigators do have the power to take
action on criminal offenses
I am just looking to clarify that so
there's no question down the road by an
attorney in the court of law
representative Platt
I recognize that you're not changing
wording other than is indicated so
you're going from from uh from
sheriff in any County to uh Statewide
jurisdiction but they can support that
concerns me is what you didn't change
when it says all laws
because it's not addressing just liquor
laws it's all loss and is it is that a
concern
no
um because if something if we say they
can only enforce liquor laws and all of
a sudden they're in an establishment and
they come across a domestic or an
assault
um they cannot take any action or say if
they are driving
um down the road and they see a
um
incident happen you know
a robbery you
know if we say they can only enforce
liquor laws they would be able to take
no action
representative Bolton
thank you for taking my question are
there any differences in training
between
um for example a Manchester Police
Department Officer and an officer from
The Liquor Commission particularly as it
relates to like
um
I know that you know in just the last
couple of years there's been increases
in types of training there's been
additions to the sort of training that
police tend to go through to get them up
to date on certain
you know Community concerns
we become a certified
investigator a fire marshal so that pot
there is no different training but where
they specialize in liquor and you know
title um
at uh correction 13.
um they do have their own in-house
training and they specialize in that
area but I believe the chief is here and
might be testifying today so he could
explain a little more about their
training follow
thank you for taking my follow-up
question
um so is it possible that there's
training that a normal City police
officer might receive that might better
qualify them to deal with a domestic
incident for example
um versus the training that uh long that
a a police officer from The Liquor
Commission might receive uh hold on a
second um let's leave that for the chief
he'll be he knows exactly what training
they have
any further questions oh did you have a
question waves off any further questions
for this witness representative Newman
I just have a just process question
about the amendment so the original Law
you amended a bunch of stuff in there
and now this amendment just just forget
about that and now this is the amendment
with the original Law in this one change
to it is that correct correct thank you
representative
is
um
it appears that the amendment makes uh
law enforcement by liquor uh
uh or whatever enforcers more
more law enforcement rather than taking
care of uh liquor violations with
if you actually run into occasion where
you are helping other law enforcement
is that not what the case is no that's
not the intent the main focus will be
under the liquor law you know title 13.
um
and what they specialize in but for an
example
say if all of a sudden there's a police
officer on the side of the road that
involves saying a motor vehicle stop and
a liquor investigator is coming along
and that officer is being assaulted
this will give them the power to stop
and help because they will have the
right to
take action under criminal law it's not
their primary function but this will
allow them to take action without delay
dozen of the original Bill take care of
that situation
it does like I said my main concern is
where it says they shall have all the
powers of a sheriff in any County which
is unconstitutional
yes but you're the amendment that you're
proposing gives much broader power to
the liquor enforcement people than your
original bill
I'm not saying it's going to I mean
originally when I put in there that they
should focus on that
I did a little re more research and that
would restrict them my original bill
would restrict them from taking actions
so if all of a sudden they were out and
about and they came across an assault a
robbery
even a homicide
they could not take action without
the authority of the local
law enforcement agency which that delay
could be the difference between life and
death
thank you
representative again three
approaches us and we decide to put in a
bill so I'm just wondering it was
brought to my attention you know
being retired law enforcement and I am
still a part-time deputy and this was
brought to my attention and it was a
concern when I read the statute
and knowing that a sheriff and the
deputies uh our sheriff is a
constitutional officer which is
um stated in our New Hampshire
Constitution under 2 article 71.
so when this was brought to my attention
I did some research and was concerned
about it I have spoken with the Attorney
General's office about this and I also
spoke with representative Lynn who's a
former Chief Justice of the Supreme
Court and
he thought that the body back in the 90s
did era
okay
representative Bolden
oh it works now thank you these are
pretty smart mics
um thanks for taking another question
um on on that
um wavelength uh was there like an
incident that occurred where someone was
unable to take action which inspired
this legislation or um
something similar uh not that I'm aware
of
but I saw that it could be a problem
um down the road if an attorney gets
hold this hold hold of this or they want
to challenge this this might be a
challenge in the court so I figured that
I would try to stop it before we got to
that point so we have to pay
um spend taxpayers money to defend it
there we know further questions the
witness is excused and I would call
um
from the New Hampshire Liquor Commission
I cannot pronounce the last name because
I can't read it as Meg you go ahead and
just say it
I'm not going to butcher it
I always say if they hack up my name
they'll know who I am
uh
first of all uh thank you Mr chairman
honorable committee members I
it's
uh my name is Mark armaganian I am the
chief of uh the division of enforcement
and Licensing for uh New Hampshire
Liquor Commission and if I look familiar
to some of you uh 25 years previous to
this appointment I was our 28 years I
should say I was a bureau Commander with
the state police
as as representative trottier has stated
this is a housekeeping issue
um oh I'm sorry and with me today is uh
Lieutenant Danielle Elston who's the
commander of our field operations could
you make sure she fills out a pink card
before she leaves please thank you
sorry about that
um this this was brought to our
attention uh as a housekeeping issue not
to reiterate what representative
trottier had stated that was exactly
what he had stated to me
um representative trottier myself back
in the early 90s worked together so
there was a good pre-established
relationship to have a very candid
conversation and exactly what he spoke
to all of you about he spoke to me about
um this issue this this circumstance or
or well it's called an issue has never
been brought up since 1990 but it was an
issue of housekeeping
um it does not change our jurisdiction
um our jurisdiction stays the same
um for some of the reasons and more so
than uh What uh representative trottier
had stated to all of you there are
circumstances and incidents throughout
several jurisdictions in the state that
uh have become life safety issues that
um given our jurisdiction uh we would
not be able to act upon given that we
would not be able to act upon especially
when they come to alcohol related
incidents uh State V welding 1984 would
actually create liability for the State
uh because police officers are
given the duty to actually take action
take minors into custody and release
them to their parents so uh case out of
Kingston of course
very well known through the law
enforcement Community
actually is what governs our actions
when it comes to that
um so again uh when it was brought to
our attention like uh
representative trottier had stated
um there are policies and procedures
that are solidified book markers if you
will that are solidified in title 13 but
there are times like I say life safety
times that we are traveling from point A
to point B and have come across things
and we mentioned the city of Manchester
absolutely uh one of our best Partners
um and uh I will tell you that we are
very close with uh Chief aldenberg
um and and one of the things he's been
very vocal about and I'm sorry that I
probably shouldn't testify on his behalf
but he's been very vocal about us doing
our jobs and they do their jobs and and
he appreciates Us in the city of
Manchester and some of the other larger
jurisdictions throughout the state
yeah
other than that I would be reiterating
everything that was previously stated
representative calling you recognized
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
chief for taking the question can you
please for my own knowledge and
background and forgive the committee if
if this is widely known but can you
describe what the role of your law
enforcement officers are and
circumstances in which
um they might encounter uh criminal
activity that is beyond their scope and
then what would be the response of that
officer absolutely thank you for the
question representative uh first and
foremost it was brought up earlier
training
um all of our sworn investigators go
through the New Hampshire Police Academy
they are full-time sworn police officers
we do have a part-time contingent that
our police officers also that have
either gone through part-time training
or their full-time police officers who
have now gone to a part-time status
um
when it comes to circumstances uh to I
think the most prevalent one uh happened
probably within the last couple years we
had an investigator that actually was at
a traffic light coming back to our
headquarters on store Street here in
Concord
um at the lights right be on South Main
Street right before uh getting to Dunkin
Donuts for a landmark if you will
um the car in front of him was not
moving
and the cycle of Lights had gone through
um the uh investigator at that point
initiated a stop
um realized that the person was not
responding made contact with the
operator the car who was slumped over
the wheel and actually overdosing
um so that felt totally into a life
safety situation Concord Police
Department was called to assist to to
transfer any criminal activity that was
found out of that vehicle that's by
policy
in in uh like representative trottier
had had brought up traveling from point
A to point B
um we come across a a traffic accident
in inclement weather
um we would actually stop we have a duty
Life Safety duty to stop
um and and notify State Police if we're
on the highway or that jurisdiction that
we're on to transfer
um our our whatever it might be our
probable cause because as a as a
civilian witness if you will
there's no you're a witness there's no
transfer of probable cause but police
officers in this state can transfer
probable cause to each other for
purposes of Warrant or or arrest so if
there was something that we came across
and we had to transfer that authority to
a traditional law enforcement entity we
could do that
representative Conley you recognize for
a follow-up thank you and thank you for
that uh detailed answer so in short
though and I appreciate the
representative describe this in his
intro is that you're not out there
responding to calls over the radio
you're it's things you come across that
you would then respond to and then await
uh the local jurisdiction is that
correct correct we we don't want to
serve civil paperwork there is a
Sheriff's Department in each of the 10
counties of this great state that that
cover that
um the powers to be back in 1990 thought
it was a easier way there was no
pushback from from the sheriff's
Association at the time
um there still isn't other than a
housekeeping issue and it doesn't change
the way we do business this bill does
not change the way we do business I
can't state that enough
oh if if I may
um I'm sorry to interrupt you
representative we on anything that is
considered outside of title 13 Life
Safety wise we have to in the in the
interest of transparency we quarterly
report to Commerce
um in in written form and that is found
on our website too in the interest of
this Administration we put together a
brand new Administration when I came
over from State Police
um the face of the Command Staff has
totally changed a hundred percent uh
with that face changing there's a
transparency that came along with it and
as in I think uh so and I apologize I
didn't I don't remember who brought it
up uh the liac commission that was just
formed by the governor
um we're the first state agency that
actually got to the Finish Line because
we do business that way so all the all
the recommendations of Lee act are
actually completed and we're the first
ones to complete that and on top of we
are the only ones that will within the
next two months be clear accredited
representative Roy you're recognized for
a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so currently this is
going to be a couple part question
currently you have powers of arrest
with regard to liquor violations
this would give you powers of arrest
with regard to all crimes where do you
transport arrestees to do you have a
holding facility of your own do you take
them to the local jurisdictions how does
that work no we do take them to either
local jurisdictions or to the House of
Corrections
um I would say a majority of our our
infractions are handled administratively
um we have
produced a
um a
softly
um what's the best way to say it
um procedure of accountability
and it starts with our education program
um and works up from there so those
instances of of full custodial arrest
are are there they do happen 100 but
they they don't happen as often as they
would in some of our traditional police
departments
thank you
representative bordner
I had the original bill
I saw that it was limiting the
enforcement
abilities for Liquor Commission
officers
it limited the powers of law liquor Law
Officers yes
and and the amendment which
uh does all it does is limit it cannot
sir officers cannot serve papers and do
sure
I'd I'd like to limit because a it gives
you the pro your Law Enforcement
Officers the uh priority of enforcing
liquor laws and I'm sure that they have
plenty to do there absolutely
the amendment
gives them broader and law enforcement
powers and in fact they can
enforce traffic laws if I'm if I'm not
mistaken and I've heard rumors about
long liquor Enforcement Officers
representative board name is there a
question
yes
uh
participating high-speed chases
is this really what we want to do or do
we want to go back to the bill as as
presented I think to answer this
correctly first of all thank you for
your question representative
um I'm here in this building to also
dispel any misrepresentations or
false information that has been put out
there to many committees there are no
Pursuits going on
there are none under this Administration
or previous Administrations
um there is policy intact that actually
prohibits us from pursuing vehicles and
I want to make that very clear there is
there is management oversight in the
highest regard to make sure that the
rules that that are presented to gel car
and are set forth for us that solidify
the laws of this state are are intact it
does not broaden our it's the same
jurisdiction as what we have right now
it does not broaden that view at all it
keeps it intact and to be quite honest
about it when we first looked at that
original version of the bill uh
representative trottier and I hadn't
spoken to each other and he did not
realize the book markers if you will the
book markers that have been in place
to make sure that there were only life
safety issues we do not want to run
radar on 93 North
um I've commanded the people that do
that
would State Police it's a different
Mission altogether
um our mission is title 13 and to keep
the communities and the industry safe
and and let's not forget the youth the
vulnerable age group in this state safe
from misuse of alcohol
thank you thank you
representative Newman
I'd like to go back
representative Newman please speak into
the microphone
and to the members in the on the
committee if you're not speaking uh
please turn off your microphone because
that
might the audio will come out through
the speaker on the microphones
okay
so my my question is you mentioned a
constitutional officer
and then so it's in conflict with what
other type of Officer yeah just just to
clarify I I did not bring that up uh
that is what was brought up by
representative trottier
um I quite honestly do not have an issue
with our jurisdiction
um I do believe that it is housekeeping
and and I accept that and and that's as
written on this amendment that is the
only reason why we're supporting this
it's not to restrict our ability from
what we have right now because
um as you will see and they they can
testify from themselves the uh the
sheriff's
uh Association the Chiefs Association
the patrolmen's association all of our
advocacy groups are all in support of us
having us not limiting our the way we do
business on a daily basis
thank you for the answer
represent Newman you recognize for a
follow-up
I was just trying to get the name of the
the distinction that was made by someone
else that testified sorry say something
about
so there was previous testimony
that mentioned a series of
law enforcement type investigators
that have that kind of pro do all are
there other types of law enforcement
investigators
other than liquor enforcement that have
these types of
powers absolutely that great question
representative so uh there are off the
top of my head on on the state level
there are
five six other regulatory agencies or
entities let's call them because we know
what agencies are concerned in state
business
um ourselves fish and game uh Troop G
over at uh State Police
Marine Patrol Fire Marshal's office
we need our jurisdiction to navigate to
be quite honest about it you can't
navigate through the these industries
separate Industries without it's by room
by policy that we put book markers on it
we make sure that our people don't do
jobs that quite honestly are assigned or
or point at other agencies traditional
agencies
if I can defer to Lieutenant Alston to
add to this
title 13 investigations that we
encounter
come with an administrative and a
criminal component and many of them are
multi-jurisdictional for example a
fatality the fatality might have
occurred in one jurisdiction while the
individual might have been drinking at
life's establishments in multiple
jurisdictions throughout that night so
the reason one of the reasons that we
need the broad law enforcement power is
there are sometimes simultaneous
administrative and criminal
investigations that can occur within
title 13 that range through multiple
jurisdictions referencing one incident
so this allows us to navigate that
without having to disrupt the local
municipalities to to be involved in each
level of that investigation
and if I'm sorry Mr chair
just just to add to that and back in
2014 there is case law at the Supreme
Court level that actually solidifies our
jurisdiction uh to maneuver and and also
states that without that jurisdiction
quote it would impede the investigators
from doing their daily duties
yeah
and I can give the reference if you
would like that thank you thank you
representative Rhodes
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question what I'm hearing you
say is this is not broadening
your jurisdiction what this is saying is
if you are present in a situation and
something bad is happening it would give
you the ability to take action
but also simultaneously call the local
jurisdiction and say this is what is
happening and this is what I'm doing get
somebody over here
that's it thank you 100 that's it
thank you for your question
representative
representative testerman thank you
that question
I want to understand
as as it's amended
uh is going to give you some amount of
authority
if this bill
did not happen would it affect how you
do business day to day no not at all
representative true
thank you Mr chair and thank you chief
I'm a ghanian
excellent thank you
um
as the law
reads now
correct
when the commission
appoints a liquor investigator
whether he's
full-time or part-time
do they all immediately assume
the police powers of the state policeman
um they so we have different missions so
so I and the only reason I want to
clarify that is
they are keeping our highways and byways
safe under 106 b
um which is their jurisdiction statue so
do we do we all have the same
jurisdiction in its broadest sense yes
but Rule and policy
draw that back to to the book markers
that we created and and those book
markers are this agency this division of
the Liquor Commission will not go
outside to title 13 unless it's a life
safety issue
representative true you recognize for a
follow-up
thank you Mr chairman thank you so again
I won't do that I did it once you did it
great
um
so when a
an investigator or a part-time
investigator
becomes uh is appointed by the
commission
when do they go through the complete
State Police
training academy and that that includes
part-time I assume they all must
complete that before
they become
an appointed liquor investigator so we
we swear first of all uh the state
police doesn't own the police academy
the academy it has its own Council
um uh just to clarify that
um under director skippa uh who's who's
there uh uh it their uh commander and
and I I will say uh happily an academy
classmate of mine so there's a great
relationship there
um our investigators get sworn in uh
when they get sworn in then we we own
them as employees
um it's at that point that they go
immediately to the police academy
whether in a part-time or full-time
status
um I will nobody goes on the street
without the academy
and we also have an in-house Academy
um
16 weeks I'm sorry uh 16 weeks now that
we teach specifically title 13 and the
liquor laws of the state and and go over
scenario based situations
um and those I'm sorry to have my back
to you over there
um I those situations are have been
shown and proven to be the foundation of
of practically teaching Law Enforcement
Officers because as we know situations
are so fluid and they are totally fluid
in the establishments that we regulate
um where we have had
um just uh the representative left
um uh in the jurisdiction of Manchester
um we we have had a investigator walk in
to do a regulatory inspection and the
first question of his mouth was
how's business doing he walked into an
armed robbery
and and uh was able to take action
um was was recognized by the Manchester
Police Department
um and and there are so many uh the 234
jurisdictions throughout the state I we
don't have a bad uh relationship with
any one of those jurisdictions
um and I know some of them are yours
um I always leave my uh phone number
with everybody uh uh Monday through uh
Sunday all hours of the day or night
there are a lot of and and if I can uh
there are a lot of there is a lot of
misinformation
um that that has been brought up uh like
the representative had had brought up I
I want to dispel that and and the only
way to do that is for all of you and
those that are listening to us right now
to call me uh I will dispel that
immediately uh because we have a good
product that we have put together in the
last four and a half years and it is at
the highest levels
representative Greene
thank you and thank you for taking my
question uh what type of vehicles do you
use are they marked or unmarked and how
are they equipped
they are they are
um equipped with
um Emergency Equipment that would
actually be
um uh
uh place in them to stop a vehicle
um you have to also recognize that there
are circumstances such as uh miners
transporting alcohol and and uh
possession of alcohol that we we
actually have to and are charged with
the duties of taking action upon those
people
um they don't happen that often but they
do
they are in uh police uh vehicles
um I will tell you that after doing an
assessment when I first came in that
I can get a vehicle such as that cheaper
than a civilian vehicle and it'll last
me longer so in the interest of being
fiscally responsible
um I it's a better vehicle it lasts
longer
uh more more like six to seven years
green recognized for a follow-up
this should pass would you need addition
we're not changing business at all
thank you thank you
representative Roy
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um
I think in the general there's a there's
a a perception of you know operating
during the daytime coming around with a
clipboard checking stuff
is your job in fact it's sometimes
dangerous do you sometimes go into bars
late at night in situations that are you
know not not just your average uh liquor
store yeah thank you sir appreciate the
question yes um we do work in the
evenings our job is to regulate the
industry when is most of this industry
Oakland late night we are out Thursday
Friday Saturday nights we are inside
these license establishments we are
meeting with these business overs do we
do checks during the day absolutely we
go in we check we make sure your license
is posted that you have the the proper
signage for the IDS but there are times
at night where we're in these licensed
establishments and I can tell you within
the last four years and just for
reference I've been with liquor
enforcement for 13 years
we have been called on by the local
agencies to go check the bars at night
they have called and said hey we have a
report of a minor inside this license
establishment can you help us with this
hey we have a report that there's
um you know there's illegal activity
occurring inside this license
establishment can you help it help us
with this we've also had local
jurisdictions say hey this place is out
of control they're serving you
responsibly they're serving to minors
can you help us with this and that does
involve us going into these licensed
establishments and well you know for
clarification purposes one example I'd
also like to give is we're talking about
you know some of these extreme examples
but even our interactions with patrons
tend to to go sideways very quick
we part of our purpose is looking for
over served individuals these are
individuals who are intoxicated and who
don't always respond the way we would
like them to respond so a simple
um incident of asking an intoxicated
individual to leave a licensed
establishment can go sideways very quick
they become combative they become
belligerent they become disorderly and
the delay to have to call the local
police department especially in a time
where many of these agencies are running
well below staff as it is to have them
come and handle that when we have the
ability to do that immediately
immediately safely Rectify that
situation
um this is this is the reason for those
Powers but ever those incidents of us
being inside these late nights they are
dangerous we've had investigators who
have been down the road from a shooting
that has occurred inside a licensed
establishment we've had recently had
shootings inside license establishments
that it's very likely we could be inside
so these the reason for this this the
jurisdiction that we have have is so
that we can deal with those immediately
because they do tend to turn into
bigger instances
thank you
and if I may representative
um uh one of the things that has become
very prevalent uh since and and we have
changed a lot of business and it would
be a laundry list to tell you exactly
what we have changed but
um there there was a standard of of
investigating to our administrative
abilities
um and and not so much Beyond A
Reasonable Doubt where we would end up
in Criminal Court
um those instances where since I was
running an investigative Bureau for the
State Police uh which was homicide major
crime narcotics and intelligence uh one
thing we found very quickly was that the
traditional police departments were
conceding to our our jurisdiction uh for
fatal motor vehicle accidents that
pointed to our uh Authority in title 13.
so you have probably seen on the news
um there have been some very tragic in
incidents and and I talked to those
parents I I will say at least two three
times a week
um and and assuring them that we will uh
really fortify that these these negative
incidents don't happen again but
sometimes we don't have control over
them we're not investigating the fatal
accident
that's State Police or the jurisdiction
that they're in we're navigating through
our industry which traditional law
enforcement has has not opted totally
out of but but recognizes that this and
that this industry has gotten so
specialized that it needs a specialized
law enforcement agency to have oversight
um so
um uh three or three different
jurisdictions throughout the state
geographically way apart from each other
uh at both borders we have been able to
navigate through and and they are the
the most egregious events that have
occurred in those that you've seen on
the news and those cases are still open
right now we're handling them and and we
handled them appropriately
thank you
representative Klein Knight
thank you chairman and thank you for
taking my question apologies if this was
already answered as I came in late
um these enforcement officers
uh would they only be getting involved
if there was
um some sort of life safety risk as it
says
in line 17
. representative Klein Knight there is a
an amendment that
although it's not been an introduced or
adopted we've been for most part
discussing the amendment
well I'm just explaining okay
I I want to know
um
basically what is the jurisdiction on
getting involved before then and the
ability to put people in sober tanks
before things escalate
so the the
line that you're referring to is
um
in the previous
the previous Bill the amendment that has
been submitted doesn't change our
jurisdiction at all however I can can
clarify that a little bit so
um much of our purpose inside these
licensed establishments is to enforce
title 13 in an administrative capacity
but there are times when we're
investigating those administrative
violations that that criminal offenses
occur and a small one might be
um where they're looking for minors to
see if the bar is serving minors and we
find a minor in possession of alcohol
we would need the ability to
appropriately deal with that minor so
that they are really safely and in many
of these jurisdictions there might not
be any law enforcement agencies on or in
the other opposition and if you're in
Manchester or Nashua they're dealing
with a incredible a number of calls
we're calling them to just simply take
custody of the minor to release Superman
isn't isn't feasible at that time so the
the jurisdiction that we have is again
within the course it gives us Statewide
jurisdiction because there are licenses
throughout the state and we need to
regulate those licensees but there are
instances when we're in the process of
dealing with our administrative
capacity that criminal instances occur
in our presence
um another example again on a small
level would be similar to what I gave
before is we're there we find an
intoxicated Patron we work with the
establishment to shut that Patron off
and get them home safely but sometimes
they don't always leave cooperatively so
if the establishment is asking them to
leave and they start becoming disorderly
or disruptive then we have the law
enforcement authority to appropriately
deal with that individual as we need we
do have the ability for protective
custody which I think is what you're
you're speaking of where if an
individual is incapacitated we would
have the ability to to take them into
custody ensure that they are are then
dealt with safely release them to a
sober party or bring them to a sober
facility or to to we that comes within
the authority and we have encountered
that at licensed establishments before
we have encountered incapacitated
patrons that need immediate assistance
thank you and if I can just add to that
um and this happened just recently and
you'd sit back and say how dumb uh we
went to do a final inspection on one of
our prospective license establishments
and when the investigator walked in
there were two miners at the bar uh
extremely intoxicated
um but but even better than that
um because we're talking about a lot of
negative here this is probably one of
the first times that industry has
supported this agency as a whole and and
I will say that restaurants and lodging
wholesalers
Grocers Association and and also our
manufacturers have like the way business
is being done because their success a
successful business we regulate to the
point of industry and Community safety
keeping our kids safe our vulnerable age
kids safe
if a business is successful we are
successful if our people write no
administrative fines or take criminal
action that means our our platform for
education is working
so so I hope I'm I'm making all of you
comfortable knowing that there there are
management controls that are here that
are keeping this this agency this
division between the book markers
thank you both for your testimony thank
you Mr chair
and if you don't mind
do uh
I I believe you both need to fill out a
ping card
all right Chief can you can you please
spell your name for the clerk
just just for the clerk for the record
can you please spell your name
it's bad enough we can't pronounce we
can't spell audio
on that
this time we will now close the public
hearing on House Bill
1475.
at this time we'll now open the public
hearing on House Bill
just watch the wires
it might be easier to pass around
there's a lot of wires here and
I hate to
eat this
and uh at this time the chair recognized
representative Tony labranche
because I want to go after everybody
representative the floor is yours
thank you Mr chair and uh thank you uh
house criminal justice and Public Safety
Committee for having me today
uh my name is representative Tony
lebranch and I represent the town of
Amherst I'm here today to introduce
House Bill 1031 which would prohibit
police departments from encrypting their
Communications unless under exceptional
situations
this actually was the case up until
recently Nash was the only city to my
knowledge but has decided to permanently
encrypt their police frequencies doing
so only a few years ago
almost every single community in the
state does not encrypt their frequencies
unless something extraordinary does
occur
that was the practice for decades and
this bill seeks to bring us back to that
this bill seeks to balance the interests
of Public Safety in the interest of the
public and government transparency and I
believe this bill does that
this bill is bipartisan and was already
common practice up until recently
and with that I asked the committee to
pass this bill with an aut path
recommendation but I did add something
at the end that I did find a technical
error in this bill and I would be
putting forth an amendment because it
does not State who gets to decide when
to increase the encrypt the police
frequency so I would like to uh
I wanted to hear what the committee uh
had to say about that before I sent in
an amendment thank you and I'll take any
questions
foreign
you haven't introduced the amendment yet
but uh who should decide who encrypts
the records and when
uh it was
um my intention to uh make it the chief
of police or his designee uh and then
make it so that there is a time limit on
how long they can encrypt their
frequencies before having to go to a
judge to uh encrypt their frequency for
any longer my intention with an
amendment would be probably uh anywhere
from
48 hours to a week that they could
increase this frequency because we don't
know how long these situations might
last and then we would have to go to a
judge to uh see if we need to continue
encrypting police frequencies
representative testerman
thank you thank you for taking my
question uh
originally at one time I guess you say
all of the frequencies were were open
and I know that to be true uh and now
that they can't
uh so people can't listen on a scanner
what harm is whether they're encrypted
or not encrypted to the public
if they were to be open for uh and the
question is
if we
if we allowed them to be incredible all
encrypted
are partially encrypted or none I mean
what harm if they're all encrypted
I believe that would be uh in violation
of the people's rights to know what
their government is doing I believe it's
a matter of public transparency on the
actions their governments are doing
especially when it comes to uh law
enforcement because uh they they do
serve the public and I believe it's the
Public's right to know what uh what they
are doing
representative Roy
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um we've heard and seen uh recently in
the last few years incidents of law
enforcement members being ambushed and
killed and part of that would be knowing
where they are and where they're going
do you not feel that it's in the best
interest in the safety of officers not
to have their exact locations always
known by the public
I believe those would be a extraordinary
circumstances
um and I I would look into a way to
amend that
representative the chair May inquire of
a question is there any particular
incident that occurred in the state of
New Hampshire that inspired this
legislation or at least
raise this issue uh mostly discussions
with constituents
thank you
representative Klein Knight
um thank you Rob
what have your constant
ly
fairness a question like that anyone
this is a public hearing any one member
of the public is allowed to testify to
allow to answer speak on behalf of that
many individuals I don't think is an
appropriate question can I clarify I'm
going to rule that question out of order
you may ask a different question I'd
like to know a relative argument that
has been a general consensus
and as you can speak into as few words
as possible as to what you're hearing
from your constituents
what I'm hearing from my constituents is
that they have been able to listen to
police frequencies uh since forever uh
and that this uh one Community uh Nashua
is the only one to my knowledge that has
decided to permanently encrypt their
frequencies so that these individuals
can no longer listen to those
Communications I know a good few of my
constituents listen to the Amherst
Police Department uh police
Communications and there's no ill intent
there it's just good to know what is
happening around town
yeah
thank you for your testimony
Shannon recognizes representative
leightner
my apologies representative
so the record I'm a representative Stacy
Marie Lawton
um I filed this legislation and I want
to thank Tony for helping to introduce
it
um and this
is not a piece of legislation to
um to come down on any sort of law
enforcement
it is more to do with either
transparency or
um it does these though controversially
they some people might feel that they
should not be they should be encrypted
others you know this also helps folks
that are like myself who cover community
events I do a fair amount of reporting
not today but um we do a lot of stuff in
Nashville and
um using the uh the scanner frequencies
helped us to
um do our jobs a little better and
um and I have received bipartisan
support on this legislation and
um
you know as far as
you know what's going on as far as you
know why we wanted to file this and why
I wanted to file it like I said there's
nothing specifically against Nashville
Police Department we actually respect my
local police department a great deal and
all police departments across the state
the idea for this was basically for the
people's right to know what's going on
in their police departments and also in
different instances
these communications help people do
their jobs whether it's hotel security
members of the press so they know what's
going on in the community it actually
impedes uh the job of some reporters in
the city of Nashua and this is something
that has been done in other communities
outside of New Hampshire but Nashua
currently is the only community in the
state that has encrypted its frequencies
and
the legislation does state that uh
it would own the
we would encrypt frequencies when it
comes to highly sensitive situations
such as you know if there's uh an active
shooter situation something that's you
know that needs to be confidential but
these will be just basic
um uh Communications you know and if
I don't think it really I've I've heard
that it might
um
uh
it might cause a safety risk for police
officers in the state
it really hasn't
um I I've noticed in other places it
might but New Hampshire that hasn't
really been an issue and Nashua didn't
really have a reason to encrypt they
just did so and so
um I I filed this because I feel as
though um it's it's our right to know
the citizens have a right to know and
um and it also like I said it it
prohibits people from being able to do
their job
and this is what only pertained to
General
um Communications you know highly
sensitive stuff like I said would be
would have to remain encrypted because
you know there's certain information the
public doesn't need to know but just
general
Communications that um
that that they do every day and uh and
we're not looking to impede on officer
safety
um officer safety is very important but
that's pretty much all I have to say and
I wanted to thank again uh
representative labrench for helping me
introduce this legislation
representative Bradley
so
in Manchester I can only speak for
Manchester we have very clear
communication
um we don't we have encrypted
um frequencies but yet we are we have um
like Facebook Twitter and all that stuff
that actually lets us know what's
happening so that's very clear
um is that something that you think
could be in place just because could you
just repeat your question yeah do you
think that that could be in place of
encrypted frequencies instead just
communication
you mean to use like social media
um I feel like that would be a good
option if there was somebody dedicated
to updating that information
um not always is there someone readily
available to do that
thank you
the chairman choir
suppose this this
Bill became law and
if you look at the lines three through
seven of the bill
what would what do you believe the
consequence should be if an officer
didn't comply with that paragraph it
seems to me that whatever would have
would that it was a contest if you can
test that issue or not it would have
already happened I guess so what
what happens if that's not followed by
law enforcement
um well I mean to say like if an officer
encrypted and they weren't supposed to
encrypt under like if this became law it
didn't meet the definition
um I guess it would probably I wouldn't
think there should be any sort of
penalties I mean maybe if they did it
and they weren't sure of
if they were allowed to or if it
qualified for encryption
um maybe just a supervisor talking to
them but I don't think an officer should
be
um you know reprimanded for you know for
this I mean sometimes things are done in
Era
um but uh I don't I don't think there
should be anything negative that should
happen to the officer
thank you
representative Conley
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking the question have you asked your
home department and your Chief to
explain their thought process for why
they made this change I have
and um under the previous chief who's no
longer the chief as of this past Sunday
he never returned my phone calls and
after also trying to reach out to other
people in the department I've I've
received no word
thank you
thank you representative for your
testimony
at this time the chair recognizes Joseph
hobeki
Mr chair members of the committee my
name is Joseph hobecki
h-o-e-b-e-k-e for the record I'm the
chief of police in Hollis New Hampshire
and I also serve as the current
president of the New Hampshire
Association of chiefs of police
in no deference to representative Lawton
I respectfully asked this committee to
find this bill and expedient to
legislate
um I have a few points
um I find this fill this bill filled
with uh ambig ambiguity uh it's quite
ambiguous
um it's confusing
um in reality
um what we need to do as agencies is
protect real-time information
and with technology and social media
there is this constant flow of
information to sources like the media
that informs them of events as they're
happening look in the newspaper turn on
the news and you'll see that media
sources have very real access real-time
access to information as it's occurring
encryption provides Public Safety with a
mechanism to protect certain information
and some of which is defined in the
legislation and and some of which is not
um when we look at specific instances
maybe in New Hampshire this is not a
problem yet it might be it wasn't a
problem in Boston until the Boston
Marathon bombings when they were
conveying information about potential
suspects over unencrypted channels and
that information was then being
redistributed by members of the public
and it turns out that those persons
weren't Suspects
um so there's a very real danger there
um from my knowledge there's at least
um two or three other agencies in the
state that use encrypted Networks
representative Bradley mentioned
Manchester they also use encryption on
their radio system I know Nashua Nashua
has used it for two years Manchester
Manchester has used it for four years
and in the interest of disseminating
information into timely manner I know
for example Nashua what they will do is
they will communicate information on
their website about specific calls even
though Communications are encrypted on a
website that's available between 20 and
30 minutes after the call occurs
so that the argument that people don't
have access that there's a lack of
transparency I don't believe is an
accurate representation of what is
actually occurring I would also mention
that to encrypt the radio system is
quite expensive
um and so what do we do if this bill
passes are we to say that these agencies
now have to unencrypt their radios which
requires money to do that it there's a
cost that would require all these radios
to be reprogrammed which in fact is is a
you know comes down to funding and
really is an unfunded mandate on these
jurisdictions to to then unencrypt their
Radio Systems that have been in place uh
for a number of years
additionally I think we need to be very
careful about eroding local control so
as a chief I don't operate in an agency
with encrypted channels if I had the
money I would probably do that at least
have one encrypted channel for sensitive
information as it stands now I would
have to switch to a uh like a federal
Homeland Security channel to have
interoperability
um but I think that as a chief of police
that decision should be my choice along
with the governing body who are my
bosses as you know so with that I ask
you to find this bill and expedient to
legislate and I'll answer any questions
that you may have
representative Rhodes
and Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question thank you we heard testimony
that
encryption
hindered the media from being able to do
their job
it is my understanding or is it true
that you know if if local media
were to call a police station and ask
questions
that information is available right so
it really would have nothing to do with
whether or not the information
if you're if you were had encrypted
information going over the radio
that's correct and and again I think the
intent of encryption
in a world where technology is so
readily available I mean you can
download an app on your smart device
that allows you to scan unencrypted
channels there was a problem with people
showing up to calls before police
arrived on scene and I'm not saying that
happens in every jurisdiction but
certainly that was a consideration in
terms of radio encryption additionally
we have to look at it's not just law
enforcement that has information that
might necessarily require protection
think about fire service right do they
not have information that they could
communicate to their dispatch centers
that might be protected Say by HIPAA so
I think those are additional
considerations but I do believe that
the public has access to this
information the media has access to this
information to me this is a non-issue
and and I don't think we need to do this
I just don't see the intent and the
purpose of the legislation
thank you
representative Borden you're recognized
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question thank you I'm a
little concerned if if the police
encrypt their Communications how do they
coordinate with Eminence and fire
departments
well typically with encrypted
um radio communications the jurisdiction
as a whole
um would would also have the capability
for interoperability with encrypted
channels save if a police department in
Hollis decides to have an encrypted
radio system we would be ensure that
um fire and EMS and even DPW would have
the capability to interoper for
interoperability with our agencies in
addition to that when we're talking
about outside jurisdictions there are
means in in ways to do that through
different radio channels that are common
use not encrypted like the vtac channels
the v-law channels as well as through
dispatch centers to communicate
information as well
thank you thank you representative
representative Newman you're recognized
thank you thank you for taking my
question
um and Hollis are your Communications
encrypted and if not how do you handle
situations where you need to encrypt
information
uh thank you for the question
representative so we are not and it's
certainly it's costly to do it we've
talked about it it's just the funding
source
to find the appropriate funding to do it
in a responsible manner how we would do
that in terms of sensitive information
is
we would do our best obviously not to
communicate that information over the
Airways we could try and use other means
such as mobile data Terminals and cars
um we we urge the officers not to use
their personal cell phone devices just
because they are discoverable in many
cases and you know we don't want that
information there you them using their
personal cell phone devices to
communicate police related matters
slippery slope
um so we try our best to handle that
appropriately uh and to protect privacy
and tactics and such but the reality is
is in these rapidly evolving situations
we may not necessarily have that option
there might be specific information that
needs to be communicated the officer
might not be near their car they may not
have the ability to communicate in some
alternative uh medium and so they have
to put it out over the radio
follow-up question
thank you
not understanding how many channels you
have access to and things like that the
technical capabilities that you have
would would with that the kind of
capabilities that you may have or other
police departments may have could you
have one frequency that was not
encrypted for your general calls and
then when you needed in to encrypt
something
could you then go to your encrypted
Channel if you had one
yes short answer yes so in our previous
lifetime at my previous Department we
had that so we had an encrypted Channel
but again it is cost prohibitive it's
very expensive
um and then it's not just the cost to
have a encrypted Channel
um
frequency it's the cost uh program all
the radio it's portable radios dispatch
radios mobile radios which are in the
Cruisers
foreign
representative Bert you were recognized
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
your testimony
um I heard a word that made my ears fly
up about
um
uh HIPAA
some situations are in HIPAA could you
explain
who is responsible
for keeping HIPAA information private
and who is not responsible in a public
setting
well I think we all have a
responsibility to keep you know medical
information private I I used it in
context of the fire service in speaking
with some folks about encryption
I know that's a very real concern for
the fire uh in EMS side of of the house
and
um
and they're very concerned about having
to put information out via the radio if
they may not have access to one of those
alternative mediums like I spoke to so
that was one of the things that I spoke
I when I had a conversation with kind of
a technical expert in this area which
clearly I am not um he mentioned that
that there was concerns for hipper
particularly from the Fire EMS side and
I hope I answered your question
representative all right thank you thank
you
representative Conley
thank you
representative true
thank you Mr chair and uh thank you
Chief Becky for taking my question
can you give me an idea how if a town or
city had encrypted and not encrypted
radios would it just be a like a two two
button issue over they change to a
different band
from my understanding the bands would
stay the same it's just an encrypted
Channel Through the programming of the
radio so it would depend on what radio
systems being used
I would imagine for a portable radio
from my experience when we operated with
an encrypted Channel it you basically
turned the dial to try and find the
encrypted Channel
mobile radios in the car same situation
just maybe a different button
uh Dispatch they would have to find the
appropriate frequency for encryption on
their radio system but typically when
you switch to an encrypted Channel
dispatch really doesn't need to do
anything from there into the house other
than listen to the transmission coming
to the station
thank you representative
thank you chief for your testimony thank
you
this time the chair recognizes
Captain Joseph Ebert
hi good morning members of the committee
chairman uh it's good to be back before
you in person my name is Joe Ebert it's
eb-e-r-t and I'm a captain with the
state police I oversee the Investigative
Services Bureau which is the detectives
within the agency
so I am here today to oppose this bill
uh I won't go over the points that Chief
obecki has brought up but I did want to
emphasize a few things I think there I
was hoping to thank the sponsor of the
bill because I do think that there was
an effort made to really take into
consideration the safety of law
enforcement here I I just in our opinion
it fell short
um there is a
there is the ability to switch
Communications to encrypt it as I think
was just the discussion that was being
had our concern with that is that
situations unfold so rapidly that it it
is difficult to either make an incumbent
upon the trooper or the officer or the
deputy who's in that uh rapidly
unfolding uh situation to switch over to
an encrypted Channel
or to ask somebody who's in dispatch who
may be receiving 911 phone calls about
it trying to dispatch emergency
Personnel other than law enforcement uh
to a scene and trying to hear the law
enforcement uh traffic it's it's a lot
to ask for that in that moment to say
okay where and I also want you to switch
to the encrypted Channel
the other concern that I have uh on
behalf of the division is that uh the uh
the notion that
um
all law enforcement agencies within the
the state would have to have an
encrypted channel is concerning only
because I'm not sure how that would be
applicable to our federal Partners many
of whom have encrypted uh frequencies
that they operate on so you know I I
think that uh uh the last point I want
to make is you
you can't always be sure uh one of the
prior speakers said well we we just want
to hear kind of the mundane things we
want to hear what's going on uh in the
day-to-day things we're not looking for
what is the significant action that's
taking place the problem is that you
don't always know what that significant
action is going to be something as
simple as being dispatched to uh
domestic disturbance call when you're
when you're signing off there that can
be an indicator to somebody on the
inside that you're there and and they
can take preparation and what to do uh
based on that so ideally uh to be able
to have the option to encrypt your
channel and have an encrypted
communication for safety purposes is
something that we would absolutely
support uh and and as a result of that
we would oppose this bill having said
all that I am more than willing to take
any questions at this time
representative Pratt
owner Federal agency comes into your
area and they're encrypted doesn't that
leave you at a disadvantage to try to
not be able to hear what they're doing
sure so uh yeah that's a 100 true that
um if there is an agency that you're
working with that has an encrypted
Channel it makes it difficult uh we have
a workaround for that to work off of
frequencies that are non-encrypted but
that's really not ideal uh ideally what
would uh what you would have and I think
Chief hobecki referred to this is uh you
would have everyone have the ability to
have the encrypted law enforcement
Communications unfortunately that's very
cost prohibitive but yes that's that's
absolutely something that um you know I
weighed out in terms of our support or
not support of this bill but it's to me
the uh the notion that you may have
interoperability or inner communication
that is somewhat hindered uh is
outweighed by the officer safety issue
involved with the bill what up
you're recognized for a follow-up okay
are you familiar with the 911 Commission
uh study of the 9-1-1 situation where
none of the organizations are able to
talk to each other and that's the reason
for the federal mandate to come up with
all the money for all the radios that
you all have now so you can talk to each
other
so thank you for the uh the question sir
and I what I can say is uh I don't want
to come across as saying hey I'm an
expert on that that was an incredibly
large document uh what I can say is I'm
familiar with the notion that there were
interoperability uh issues with that and
it's something we struggle with uh and
there's there's no doubt that that's a
real concern I don't want to uh Fufu
that and uh come across to the committee
that I don't think that inner
communication or inter-department
communication isn't an issue I'm just
saying from my perspective and from the
division of State Police perspective uh
a a competing harm is that uh giving up
the position of law enforcement uh is
also a of Paramount concern
one more time
uh tax channels you have multiple tax
channels is it possible to have one
channel for a bad situation and regular
channels for your regular day operation
I I so yes uh thank you for that
question sir
do I think that's possible yes uh I
think that's uh cost prohibitive uh
there's there's no doubt about it that
that would be difficult for many
agencies throughout the state I think
it's probably something better for the
the Chiefs to speak on than necessarily
me
um do I have uh could we have that
capability yes we actually have we do
have an encrypted channel that we could
go to
I just can't express you enough the
rapid nature of which a call changes
from
[Music]
um somewhat mundane to an emergency
situation and asking somebody to do
something in that moment of pure stress
uh like uh switch over on their portable
or switch over on their their car radio
I I believe is is asking too much of
that individual who's who really should
be concentrated on uh the danger that's
presented to them just one last question
uh is State Police presently on
narrowband
that unfortunately sir that is not a
question that I'm uh capable of uh
answering however if that is something
you're truly interested in I can get you
that answer
okay I believe that uh most State Police
are now on narrow ban in digital
frequency and that's very difficult to
scan with a scanner so these people that
just want to listen to what you're doing
or even a criminal is very difficult
unless they pay an expensive radio buy
an expensive radio like the ones you use
understood so it's hard to scan yeah
it's hard to listen to none of your
business
that's all I have thank you
representative Newman
thank you
I I just want to understand when you
talked about State Police having
encrypted channels and non-encrypted
channels could you just explain what you
use each one of those four currently so
I could just have understanding about
what what you all do
sure I
absolutely so the uh as I was getting
ready in prep for this uh hearing today
I wanted to know uh well I assumed the
first question that somebody might ask
me is what does the State Police operate
on an encrypted frequency what we have
now is uh what was it presented to me is
less than ideal in terms of our primary
channel can be encrypted but it takes
several steps with which to encrypt that
communication and that's why I really
wanted to emphasize the notion that in a
scenario where you have seconds to deal
with something
um you're it's asking a tremendous
amount to ask at that moment that you
also manipulate your radio to an
encrypted fashion in terms of actual
channels there primarily encrypted that
I'm aware of we have one primarily
encrypted Channel and that is used by
our undercover narcotics unit
thank you
thank you for your testimony excellent
thank you very much
and this time we will now close the
public hearing on House Bill 1031.
it's a recommendation today
come come back she might exec that bill
at this time we will now open the public
hearing on House Bill 16
the room will come come to order thank
you very much at this time the chair
recognizes representative David Welch
and and before the before the
representative Begins for the members on
the committee I'm gonna excise my
discretion and limit each member to two
questions per Witness
representative you may begin
all right for the record on
representative David Welch I represent
Rockingham District 13.
to give you just a brief introduction to
the bill
uh I was asked by the speaker to sit on
a commission as prepared to Lee act
commission that was put together
earlier on House Bill 2 created this
Commission
and only to
excuse me
it was a commission to develop
recommendations for legislation to
establish a single neutral and
independent Statewide identity to
receive complaints alleging misconduct
regarding all sworn and elected law
enforcement officers
pursuant the recommendation number 16 in
the final report issued by the New
Hampshire Commission on law enforcement
accountability community and
transparency
the members of the commission are here
they know the details so I would rather
not
bore you with my interpretation of what
I did on that commission I basically sat
and listened
the only other elected member on that
commission was Senator Carson
and she elected so far as I know not to
file legislation so I filed it
and with that I have a uh the final
report which I'll turn into the clerk
and I would defer any questions to The
Experts behind me
thank you representative
this time the chair now recognizes Eddie
Edwards
it's all new
it's been a moment for me
so uh good morning chairman honorable
committee members if I could reserve my
testimony to after director John skipper
is the director of the police academy
we'll kind of walk you through the
entire piece of legislation that's fine
thank you
I'm going to try with the pronunciation
here
chair now recognizes Tony
if only one Tony in the room
skull and braini is my last thing
um
good morning chair my name is Anthony
skullenbriti I'm here on behalf of nhaj
I'm a lawyer I own my own firm with a
former prosecutor in Nashua at Gillen
scholombrini first of all I want to say
that NHA supports this bill
because we believe that everybody
deserves due process
the bill gives rise to a committee that
or a council that would
provide officers accused of Ron doing
due process and it would also give
victims of police misconduct recourse
finally and importantly if the bill is
made into law it would create a resource
that would Aid both plaintiffs and
defendants and cases involving
misconduct
helping to preclude frivolous lawsuits
and ensure that ligands are dealing with
what real well-vetted information
while 1983 claims are a small part of
what my firm does in 1983 is just this
federal statute that allows people
to sue in court for police uh misconduct
they are by far the most common intake
topic that we have most of the people
feel aggrieved by police misconduct and
strongly believe that something illegal
has happened
as it stands now researching prior
conduct of officers is limited to
unreliable sources lawsuits filed in
court but settled out of court the EES
or what's called Lori list and internet
sources when a person calls about the
case one of the first things that I do
is research about the officers involved
I've been a lawyer in New Hampshire for
almost 20 years and I've been mostly a
criminal defense lawyer so oftentimes I
know the police officers by name
uh but sometimes they don't and when it
comes to finding information out about
what happened it's very difficult a case
that I had recently proves this point
and why this Council would be helpful we
had a case involving an officer who was
arrested and the arrest was reported but
the conclusion of the case just sort of
disappeared Into The Ether and so the
police log was appeared on the internet
and we were able to find out that he was
arrested but nothing else and so I have
a duty to my client to use this
information to their advantage and the
other side had a duty to sort of
mitigate that information when we
presented it to the judge because there
was no well-vetted facts there was no
conclusion the judge had a hard time
figuring out what to do and if this com
this Council exists and the bill is made
into law
everyone would be playing with the same
information we'd all have the same cards
to go from when we're playing poker it
wouldn't be you know one person using a
regular deck of cards and somebody else
using an Uno deck and that's really what
it is right now we just don't have
well-vetted information about police
misconduct and we don't have
conclusions about what happens a lot of
the time and so that's important the one
thing that I would point out is that
there are two tweaks that we would like
to see the first involves the
transparency provisions and that
involves when the allegations are
disclosed to the public
under the law is currently written it
would not be disclosed until the time of
the hearing and we would like to see the
disclosure time push back to when the
charges are docketed we'd like to see
this for two reasons number one it
parallels the ethics rules that exist
for judges and lawyers and those claims
are docketed or made public when they're
docketed and second it allows the public
to be made aware of what's going on
in a criminal case the charges are made
public when they're docketed just like
with these two ethics bodies that
regulate lawyers and judges
and one of the benefits of that is
people that have information related to
the incident but may not know that an
official proceeding is started can come
forward and by pushing back the
disclosure date and making the process
more transparent it allows people that
have been aggrieved
notice and time to get involved
the second tweak that we would like to
see is we would like to change the
constituency of the panel as it is now
according to the bill there are 17
members of the uh 17 people on the
council of those 10 are explicitly
related to law enforcement either as
police or prosecutors
one of the reasons why this panel came
about is because of the liac commission
and the liac commission came about
because of an outcry in the public if we
want this commission this Council to be
successful its appearance of fair and
balanced approaches to problems is
necessary and as it stands now there's
no representative on the panel for for
example criminal defense lawyers or the
ACLU and so we'd asked to have the bill
tweak to allow one of those people
on the panel as a representative to give
it some sort of balance
basically it's 10 people who are law
enforcement
seven people who have no connection one
way or the other and no one who has
experience dealing with the law from the
perspective of a criminal defense lawyer
or a civil rights litigator and I think
that having one person on the panel that
does those things would give the public
confidence that this is not something
where the status stacked the deck in
favor of the police
I thank you for your time and I'm
willing to take any questions
representative Platt thank you thank you
for taking my question
what would prevent
a criminal defense attorney
filing charges against a police officer
just to dismourge the name going through
this process it's public information
meanwhile you've got another case going
on involving that officer I mean how
could it be abused I mean that's a
really good point you know the one that
the way that it's currently set up sort
of mimics the process for lawyer ethics
complaints and judge ethics complaints
and that there's a vetting process
before the item is docketed so if it's
truly a frivolous claim or a claim that
even if true wouldn't result in
misconduct there's a weed out provision
in the bill right now that would prevent
that from going forward and that that's
a good point and it's an important
important thing to have that weed out
provision
there's no other questions I'm gonna
pass my time to somebody else
you may be excused
foreign
at this time the chair recognizes Matt
Broadhead
good morning Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Matt Broadhead I'm
a senior Assistant Attorney General for
the State of New Hampshire I'm the
bureau chief of the transportation and
construction Bureau which represents the
state police I've had the fortunate
honor to help with the legislative
component of the liac commission the
governor's liac commission and also the
study commission that was formed to
establish this legislation um
so I'm pleased to testify here today on
behalf of Attorney General John from
Ella and the entire department of
justice we strongly support this bill
especially the important concept that it
embodies which is to establish three
things and balancing them with
important interests from law enforcement
so first it provides oversight and
accountability and investigations into
police misconduct it increases the
transparency for confirmed violation uh
violations of police misconduct and it
promotes consistency and uniformity
among police departments as to what
actually constitutes misconduct and it
balances these important interests while
maintaining the Privacy interests of
individual police officers who do have
frivolous complaints levied against them
and it allows local police Chiefs to
maintain local control over their
employees discipline
um and so we strongly urge you to pass
this as written by way of background I
think not to to go over what has already
been said but the concepts of this bill
were first envisioned by the liac
commission as was said
um but however last year the legislature
through hb2 created a study commission
and it met weekly during the fall
and tackled some really important and
and tough issues that were raised by
unions representatives from police
unions police Chiefs Association
director skippa and his organization the
police standards and training Council
the ACLU public defender's office and of
course the Department of Safety in our
office
this strikes a consensus balance from
all of these diverse
the stakeholders
and it was a unanimous report that was
filed
um and so that is the text of the bill
that is before you today is the work of
that commission which had a lot of hard
conversations
um
and uh
one of the biggest frustrations we heard
from local police officers and Chiefs is
the lack of uniformity specifically with
when to report
types of misconduct when to report
conduct to the Attorney General's office
when to report conduct to police
standards and training what even
constitutes a basis for discipline and
what um you know what the standards are
this bill also addresses that by
creating in-statute a definition of
misconduct that will apply uniformly to
all law enforcement officers it also
clarifies and corrects a gap in who is
subject to the police standards and
training Council uh purview for for the
purposes of defining the law enforcement
officer itself
um it creates technical changes that
allows more flexibility on the part of
police standards and training to not
just take a look at somebody's whether
to revoke or suspend uh an officer
certification but also to provide
additional training to give warnings to
do some more of the soft approach to
things that actually encourages officers
to improve not just to cut bait
um so it has a lot of Concepts it's
wide-ranging I'm happy to answer any
questions I do want to say just a couple
more things
that about what this bill does
it creates that Review Committee and
that Review Committee reviews complaints
and it can access invest internal
investigative files but all of that
process is under seal only when it rises
to an a uh there's a standard in there
that says you know if it meets a
sustained or appears to to meet a
sustained finding of misconduct then
they can make a referral to police
standards in training which now holds
its hearings in public so they'll public
can see the process but the vast
majority of the complaints I'm sure
would be remain sealed in those
complaints until there is actually a
founding a finding so if there's a fear
or concern that there'd be you know uh
just making an allegation out there
would result in in this publicly public
shaming and it's unsustained that still
protected under this stat under this
proposed statute and then again if it
does rise to the level of seriousness
then there is a public process then that
increases transparency and IT addresses
a gap in our system which is when law
enforcement agencies investigate their
own employees there's typically no
publicly available document that reports
what the results of that investigation
are and there's very good reasons for
that there's collective bargaining
agreements there's things like that
um and it may not be a major uh incident
of misconduct that rises to the level of
public disclosure however what this does
is it it's a system in a process that
once a complaint is filed there is uh
transparency when needed there's a
review when needed and then there can be
a subsequent investigation in limited
circumstances if if there is something
that just doesn't
seem right about the way that the
investigation was conducted
so this bill is two years in the making
um and uh I would it would put New
Hampshire on the map in terms of one of
the leading States in this area of
police reform and I urge its adoption
um and again I'm happy to take any
questions on this
representative Roy you were recognized
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question what is the Attorney
General's position on the suggestion by
the previous
witness who questioned the makeup of the
committee with regard towards a bias
towards police
um
so I think I'd defer much of that I will
answer the question I think director
skippa probably would have a more
nuanced answer to that because it is his
counsel
um we considered that in the commission
ex there was a proposal to expand it
um to more than what was proposed here
and that was rejected by the commission
who had done again adopted this
unanimously ultimately
um the original Lee act commission
envisioned an agency that would review
complaints of misconduct with a board
that was slightly weighted towards law
enforcement that was the that was the
original Vision that is embodied in the
conduct Review Committee it is it is
nearly 50 50 but it is 51 law
enforcement the police standards and
training Council it tied to their
certification I don't know if any
organization in the state of New
Hampshire that has a certification or a
license that doesn't that isn't a
majority staff with respect to
the people who are employed by that
profession attorneys oversee attorneys
doctors oversee a doctors and certainly
there's room here for improvement in
terms of the public but this was the
balance that the commission thought was
the right balance
thank you
representative true
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question could you point to me
where in the bill there's the uh the
vetting of frivolous claims to so
there's no
uh public you know thank you yep
it if the information's in the bill the
witness does not need to locate it's
it's um
there's a section on accessibility and
confidentiality it's on page nine and so
I'd commit uh section 106 L 22 to your
reading and it sets forth what records
are accessed
yep
thank you thank you for doing this is
excused
at this time the channel recognizes John
skippa
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
honorable members of this committee
my name is John skippa and I am the
director of New Hampshire police
standards and training
our organization uh just celebrated our
50th anniversary in service to our state
in uh 2021.
and uh
we celebrated that 50-year anniversary
as an independent executive branch state
agency
the mission of New Hampshire police
standards and training is to shape
sustain and strengthen the competency
and professionalism of New Hampshire law
enforcement and that is in service to
our state
we accomplished this through our dual
responsibilities of developing and
providing initial and ongoing police
training
and that's to all New Hampshire law
enforcement officers and also by
establishing and enforcing standards for
the hiring training and conduct of all
New Hampshire law enforcement officers
I appear uh
in front of all of you today to voice my
support
for the proposed legislation that you
consider today
the impetus of this bill was born during
the work of Governor sununu's liac
commission and that acronym stands for
the commission on law enforcement
accountability community and
transparency which was established and
worked through 2020.
and it reflects
the efforts of many people that were
part of that commission and then
ultimately part of this last committee
to work on this legislation
each person they are bringing a very
different perspective to that overall
cumulative effort
ultimately all of us acted in
furtherance of the liac recommendation
16 that provided really a vision of how
police misconduct should be addressed
going forward
and I think it's important to to uh you
know thank uh representative Welch and
Senator Carson uh the AG's office and
really attorney Matt Broadhead uh for
their stewardship uh as we worked
through uh some really tough uh
conversations uh as we built this uh
legislation as proposed
the bill as you see it today addresses
each of the recommendations that were
set forth by the liat commission on this
topic
specifically under recommendation 16.
this bill contemporizes the process for
New Hampshire law enforcement and New
Hampshire police standards and training
on how allegations of misconduct would
be investigated and presented for
hearings and disposition
this bill has written clearly defines
what police misconduct is
this bill has written provides a balance
between local control with regulatory
oversight and review
of allegations of police misconduct
it provides due process
provides for an open and transparent
process with regard to hearings and
dispositions
it increases the public participation in
the process
it provides clearly defined expectations
of what a valid investigation is
and it provides for a central repository
of sustained findings of misconduct
with public disclosure
I would ask for one minor amendment to
be made just to correct a just a very
minor defect it's a housekeeping uh
request
I would ask each of you to refer to page
10 line 29.
and on page 10 line 29 uh
I would ask that Roman numeral eight
I I be changed to Roman numeral
5V
and that they do duplicative verbiage
that follows that
quote relating to an officer's
trustworthiness or credibility be struck
so that the entire sentence would read
notwithstanding paragraph two any
grievance alleging misconduct under RSA
106 L2 Roman numeral five B may be filed
at any time
again this is just minor housekeeping it
cleans the language up it strikes the
duplicative language and it's and it uh
refers back to really what we wanted to
make sure we were addressing which was
uh if there is ever a time where a
police officer lies uh
commits any kind of misconduct with
regard to uh their official duties
whether that be uh evidence the handling
of evidence testimony the way they treat
um Witnesses and victims we want to make
sure that we can address that regardless
of of when uh those allegations come to
light and the investigation can be
conducted
I think it's important also to recognize
that some of the requests that were made
by the trial attorneys
please understand that as we worked
through this to build the this bill for
your consideration uh the two requests
that were made those were two uh
requests that were discussed very very
deeply during our work and ultimately as
a committee we we felt it was very
important for us to speak with one voice
and unanimously support what was brought
before you today
and so to that end please understand
that those requests that were made today
were part of the discussion and uh very
deeply uh discussed and ultimately uh
they were not accepted as part of our
unanimous uh position moving this bill
forward
again uh I would I would ask that uh
with the amendment that I've requested
and again that's just a housekeeping uh
request
I would ask that this bill be supported
and I stand ready for any questions that
anyone might have
representative Roy
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
over here oh thank you uh if you could
just answer the question I asked the
previous speaker regarding the the
concerns of the other witness that the
commission might appear to be biased
based on its makeup a little bit too
much towards police thank you so I think
that um it's a it's a terrific question
and it was something that uh candidly
was really a point of um some pretty uh
Lively debate as we as we put this
together
uh
it was felt across the the group
ultimately that to allow uh any one
organization to be representative
as part of the Review Committee uh or
part of police standards and training
would in essence exclude
other groups that that may want to also
have a seat at that Council whether it's
the Review Committee or the actual
Council and so to that end uh it was
felt from from an objective point of
view that we increased a number of uh
civilian positions
on the council
in the first instance and and not put
limitations on
those civilians with regard to whether
they have any membership in any uh
organization whether that be the ACLU or
any other group we just felt that it was
more objective and it allowed for
um
really it didn't close the door on any
group and that's the reason that we we
ultimately decided that we would leave
it kind of objective and open
yeah
so just for clarity a member of the
defense bar a member of the ACLU a
member of any other organization is able
to sit on this board if they're
appointed
that is correct sir okay
representative Pratt
hello good morning
um after an investigation is done by a
local police department has turned over
the law enforcement conduct Review
Committee uh how soon would the
investigation take place it looks like
you meet quarterly
I believe that we wanted to make sure
that the
conduct Review Committee met at least
quarterly but certainly
you know because this is something new
we just don't know uh what the what the
workflow will be and whether they would
need to meet more often than that so uh
you know depending on the the
information that's brought and uh
whether there's a need to to look into
something sooner than later would would
dictate how that goes okay one more
follow-up
so I can ask for follow-up would the
credentialing be suspended while the
investigation is ongoing yes part of uh
part of
what is written in this bill allows for
uh myself to act in very narrow
circumstances to suspend
upon arrest immediately do an
administrative suspension of that
certification until such time that the
officer can be brought before the the
council to be heard on the matter
otherwise the allegation would need to
be uh in essence sustained and then that
would again be brought to the council's
attention through hearing and then
that's where the action would would be
taken
so would they be would they be able to
work
and with uh suspended credentials could
they do some kind of work are they going
to be suspended from work no presently
as it stands now any any officer that
has their certification suspended in
fact has lost their license to work as a
police officer and they cannot act in
any capacity wear uniform or even you
know remotely
kind of put out the notion that they are
acting as a law enforcement officer okay
thank you you're welcome sir
okay
representative Newman
at one point in your testimony you
referred to local control which can
sometimes be a contentious issue what
that means
so could you clarify that because it
doesn't appear that the appointment's a
local control what what exactly were you
referring to when you said it has local
control for something
uh thank you sir uh for that question
as we were fashioning this uh what we
wanted to make sure was that if any
allegation of misconduct is made
against a police officer
the initial responsibility of
investigating that allegation would be
left to the chief law enforcement
officer of that agency
that chief law enforcement officer will
need to adhere to a valid investigation
and then subsequent to that valid
investigation it would be turned into
the Review Committee for review
if in fact the Review Committee felt
that the investigation did not meet a
valid investigation or that there was
defects in that investigation this
legislation would give power to the
Review Committee to direct
either a de novo investigation or to
augment the investigation and work
independently of that that local entity
that did the the initial investigation
so there's kind of a uh
an overview of or an oversight of how
these things will be conducted and then
kind of maintaining consistency across
the state as to how they're conducted in
the findings thereof
thank you you're welcome sir
representative Conley thank you and
thank you for taking the question it's
quite clear that a tremendous amount of
effort and foresight went into the
this bill and the makeup of the
committee uh my concern and I'm getting
to the question is about perception
public perception of the work of this
body and by waiting the membership in
the way that it is weighted such that
law enforcement is given those uh for
better 10 members versus seven with the
non-law enforcement connection are you
concerned at all that the findings of
this body would not be considered
legitimate by a good person a good
percentage of our state
uh it's an excellent question and uh and
it brings to light maybe
um
an opportunity for me to kind of explain
the two sides of the house in the first
instance uh this bill establishes a
conduct Review Committee which is
weighted about 51 percent to law
enforcement and in fact we would have a
prosecutor that oversees that committee
to make sure that the investigations are
done correctly
if that committee feels that there is a
sustained finding then they will uh that
attorney will bring it to police
standards and training Council
uh
I think I'm understanding you uh
representative Conley that um
the question is whether the council make
up
does not provide legitimacy because of
the the way it's weighted do I
understand the question correctly
you do and just the concern that
somebody would presume correctly or
incorrectly that a finding was made in a
certain way based on the makeup of that
board not based on the facts of a
certain incident
yeah we do we as we presently operate
um that
that does not appear to be a concern
um and and please understand that this
process that we're talking about now
really does happen it's not nearly as
contemporized as it happens or will
happen if this bill goes to law
um
the ultimately you know we have judges
we have the attorney general that sits
on this board we do have some some
civilians that sit on the board of
council
as it stands now uh we wanted to
increase the number of of uh citizens
and
um and we did uh within this bill but
that the council would act as the the
Arbiter in the
um in this case so the Review Committee
would bring the case for hearing in
front of the council and that's a that's
a public
event that's open to the public and with
very very minor exceptions uh
we cannot do things in in uh non-public
session any longer so I I just think
that it is you know objectively it is
arranged in a way that will certainly
allow everyone to see you know the
process understand the process hear the
deliberation as they uh you know try to
reach a resolution I don't think that
the Optics of it
um
are are something that would cause the
average citizen to be concerned about
thank you sir
and if the chair May inquire and thank
you for taking my question
your testimony may have covered some of
this but perhaps you could maybe explain
to the committee the procedure from the
beginning to the end what would occur if
a complaint or was made
thank you sir
the way we uh Envision this and the way
it's been written is that if there is an
allegation of misconduct as defined
within this bill
uh the if if the allegation is made at
the local level and that happens quite
often uh and it's important to know that
I've I've spent 35 years in law
enforcement and I was a chief of police
on the Seacoast for a number of years
when an allegation like that comes in
uh generally uh it is just handled at
that local level
and uh there's no
um
there's no consistency across the state
as to how that happens so the way we
envision it is if there's a local
complaint that comes in alleging
misconduct uh then that chief law
enforcement officer would let police
standards and training know that hey we
just received this complaint and we are
investigating it or
we have an outside agency investigating
it or we're not sure if we can do this
ourselves and we're asking for police
standards and training to come down and
investigate it
uh once the investigation is complete it
would be uh all of all the documents
would go to the conduct Review Committee
they would review that investigation to
ensure that it was done correctly that
there's no follow-up that needs to be
done and then ultimately they would
decide whether uh they could sustain a
finding or or move that forward in a
hearing in front of the council if they
felt that that was something that should
be brought before the council that it
sustained a finding of misconduct then
the staff attorney
acting as a prosecutor and in an
adversarial way would bring that
complaint forward to the council they
would prosecute the case the officer
would be entitled to defend the case if
they wanted to and then the police
standards and training Council in
essence would act as the judge and uh
reach a a verdict on on whether it was
proven Beyond a preponderance and then
what penalty would be uh imposed if any
thank you thank you sir
representative Marston
taking my question
does this piece of legislation
preclude
criminals courts set up where the the
officer would be criminally charged
does this eliminate that
that's an excellent question uh
representative and it does not and in
fact uh
within this bill it very clearly defines
uh that this bill would not in any way
get uh impede the local authority to
impose their own sanctions if if
necessary and it's certainly also allows
for
prosecution in criminal events again we
envision that if somebody makes an
allegation of misconduct and it reflects
unlawful or criminal activity that was
committed by a police officer while
they're on duty
that would go directly to the public
Integrity unit of the AG's office
because the criminal case certainly
would take precedence over the
misconduct case and so we would let them
work the criminal side first
thank you
thank you for your testimony Mr chairman
ladies and gentlemen thank you
this time that you're now recognizes
Eddie Edwards
I think I got the process now
good morning uh honorable chairman and
honorable committee members for the
record my name is Eddie Edwards I am the
assistant commissioner at the department
of safety my parents here today is in
support of this bill on the on behalf of
the Department of Safety we believe that
this bill provides the necessary
transparency and accountability and due
process necessarily whole police
officers accountable it as a original
member of the liac commission
I supported the process there I I don't
think we can lose sight of the fact that
this piece of legislation really does
put New Hampshire on a map of his own
very few states have taken this uh
process going from the liac commission
to a commission to study misconduct and
now producing a product like this I I've
traveled uh throughout the United States
training law enforcement officers in
probably 21 different states over the
course of my career and this is a pretty
robust piece of legislation that allows
us to hold people accountable in the
proper way
so uh I do want to point out because I
think um assistant AG Broadhead pointed
this out
on the issue of weighted the committee
being weighted towards law enforcement
we wanted to make sure that the this uh
Review Committee was set up and
structured like all other professional
licensed Professionals in the state
where they are weighted towards the
Professionals in that occupation this
was modeled after the attorney
disciplinary board
an employee attorney disciplinary board
this is the model they have for judges
prosecutors and other attorneys so we
want to make sure this was consistent
so thank you very much uh and I'm happy
to answer any questions
thank you for your testimony thank you
it's time to train our recognizes Joseph
laskaz and
you both make
testify together
thank you thank you very much my name is
Joseph lascaz I will be representing the
oh sorry there you go I will be
representing the American civil
liberties Union of New Hampshire in
support of HB 1682 I will also be
speaking
um as a commission member I did serve on
the original liak commission that came
up with this recommendation as well as
the study commission that worked on
drafting this language
one of the first things that I just want
to speak on is the fact that this bill
right here is um the work of many
different perspectives the community
perspective that I will be representing
uh
agrees and supports this bill this
created something where there was
nothing if if this existed we wouldn't
have had to write this legislation so in
in that sense that there is a new body
that will hopefully be coming to the
state that will address the concerns
that many community members have voiced
and and that's one of the first things
it does is it creates a uniform
definition of misconduct that was a
concern before that uh we had different
departments that would have different
definitions of misconduct it wasn't the
same and so having this Universal
definition is um is a benefit for the
state and for the for our community
members
one of the original Three uh reasons
that leak uh came up with this
recommendation was it for it to be a
investigatory body
it would also be neutral and independent
and it would have public members
and so uh
speaking on the investatory part uh I do
believe that some of that those Powers
have been shifted down from what the
original recommendation was being that
this body could just independently do an
investigation but that still now is in
this bill uh where you can where they
have this power after receiving a valid
complaint to investigate and review
um review invest the investigations and
reports that they have received
the public member access to this uh
Council and committee is extremely
important because it speaks to again uh
the validity that representative Conley
was speaking about and I believe that
representative um
has spoken to that
believing and making sure that this body
is acting in the interest of community
members and transparency is their
um we will be speaking more about
transparency uh Henry uh Mr clementonas
will be talking about that but again
this is
um this is a bill that will answer the
community concerns
um with at the same time balancing law
enforcement's concerns about uh due
process rights one of the things I do
want to just point out quickly because I
did speak to director skippa was on page
four
um on page four when we're talking about
the public members
uh it it is saying that they're they're
that the public members could not be an
officer lawyer or judge and and I just
wanted to clear to clarify that which
which I spoke with uh uh attorney
general Broadhead and skippa that it
wasn't that a person couldn't be a
lawyer or judge that they on this it was
that you couldn't represent an
organization
um an advocacy or organization or
something of that nature so and that
comes from one of the potential
recommendations in this was that a
representative of law enforcement who
was at the rank of lieutenant and Below
representing a a union
um could could be on this and so to
balance that concern that you know that
it we need to be objective that was
where it was that there wouldn't be an
advocacy organization attached but that
didn't mean that a person couldn't be a
lawyer a judge so I would just be that
is one thing I would just want to flag
about the language that that that needed
to be corrected it wasn't the fact that
a person could be couldn't be a lawyer a
judge it was just that they weren't
representing an organization in an
official capacity
with that I am happy to take any
questions that you may have at the end
and I want to turn it over to um Mr
clementon's to talk about transparency I
saw a lot of some confused looks on the
committee are you
so under on page four with what you were
just referring to trade four line 17
lines 16 17 and 18. correct are you
suggesting that that is intended to read
that an attorney or a lawyer could serve
as a member of the public provided
they're not representing any
organization if they're yes they're not
they're not representing an official
organization yes
because I
that's in does that doesn't say that so
I guess my question is
was that the intent of the the committee
or the commission I met over the
summertime yes and that's what I was
that's what I was double checking this
morning
so I
it that's what I that's what I was
double choking with um
director skip
PA and Broadhead but yes that was the
original intent it wasn't that it that
they couldn't be those functions that
they wouldn't be doing it in an official
capacity
thank you
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee my name is Henry clementowicz
I'm also I'm a senior staff attorney at
the ACLU of New Hampshire I wanted to
talk a little bit about the transparency
Provisions in uh this legislation ACLU
of New Hampshire is generally supportive
of the language as drafted however we
felt at the end of the study commission
that there wasn't quite enough time to
fully reach complete agreement on the
transparency and so we reserved our
rights to propose further language
changes so in our written testimony we
submitted a proposed amendment that
would secure our full support around the
transparency process and I just want to
briefly
um make those points if I may
there's just a couple changes I think
that they're pretty modest
um for example on page 9 lines 25
through 28.
um the the language as written
provides that
um
I'm sorry yes uh
on page 10 I'm sorry lines two through
nine the language is currently written
provides that the records of the public
of the police standards and training
Council will be made public at the time
of the hearing our view is that that
should be changed
um to just make clear that once the
complaint screening committee determines
that there's sufficient evidence to move
forward the evidence shall be made
public and so it's really just a timing
issue it wouldn't create a new category
of cases that would be made public it's
just designed to one sort of the formal
charges are brought and as
representative Platt had suggested the
the
um frivolous or legally insufficient
charges have been weeded out by the
complaint screening committee at that
point things could be made public and
you wouldn't have to wait between the
docketing of that of that finding and
the hearing itself so that's really just
a timing change that we suggest
the second change just
um is a change to the purpose section
which is
um which is on page nine lines 25
through 28 that says it's the perfect of
the purpose of the section both to
protect the reputation of law
enforcement officers from public
disclosure of unwarranted complaints
against them and to fulfill the public
right to know of any action taken
against a law enforcement officer when
that action is based on a sustained
finding misconduct our view is that that
purpose section is unnecessary and may
have the unintended I think effect of
changing the current status quo of right
to no laws against local departments uh
right to no actions against local
departments or other agencies when
um there's a an investigation of high
public interest but the there's an
unsustained finding against an officer
right now uh the ACLU of New Hampshire
on behalf of the Valley News has the
case pending before the New Hampshire
Supreme Court uh seeking records into an
investigation that ended up ultimately
clearing an officer of misconduct but
the argument that the trial court found
persuasive and that I'm hopeful the New
Hampshire Supreme Court will recognize
on appeal as courts and other states
have done is that there's also a public
interest in knowing that the
investigation is comprehensive
um and fair and thorough and I think
that that will happen it certainly is
our belief that that will happen under
the this proposal as passed we just
think that this change and removing the
statement of purpose and there's one
other change to that effect would would
remove the possibility of these
unintended con um
changes to the right to no law then
finally our last suggested change and
again these are all uh in your inbox and
writing is to just make clear that ptsc
t
ptsc should maintain a public website
that has the reports of sustained
findings of misconduct after the process
has concluded and that was
um a recommendation made by Lee act and
it's also consistent with the attorney
discipline office for example if you
were to go to NH
attreg.org that's the website of the
attorney discipline office you can look
up online and read all of the
disciplinary decisions that have been
sustained against any lawyer in the
state going back like I think like 15
years and so those are the three changes
that we would put to this committee to
ensure our full support for the bill as
I said we are already generally
supportive those are just some changes
that we think could really improve what
is a what is a really comprehensive
piece of legis isolation that we're
pleased and proud to support we also
want to thank the other members of the
commission who worked with us on this in
particular director skippa and Senior
Assistant Attorney General Matt
Broadhead
um who did just incredible amounts of
work to to try to reach consensus on
these hard issues
um so with that I'm happy to take any
questions
the chair May inquire and thank you for
taking my question you referenced page
nine lines 25 to 28. can you explain to
the committee how exactly that that
would have a negative impact on the
right to know laws sure so if I may I'm
just calling up my computer to get the
bill so it's
um it is that purpose section and it is
also uh the language
um
so our view is that that surplusage in
light of the language that says that the
hearing shall be conducted in accordance
with RSA 106 L 5 Roman 3 which generally
makes them public
and so the Surplus which I think could
just be read to
um
the direct answer to your question Mr
chairman is that public records requests
are generally interpreted consistent
with the preamble to the right to know
statute which provides that open
government is the foundation of
democracy and so the case law that has
evolved in those cases is that documents
in the possession of a public body are
presumed to be public in accordance with
that purpose and the burden rests on the
entity-resisting disclosure to prove
that a document is exempt from the right
to no law putting a different purpose
here could sort of change the the I
think the Court's potentially I don't
know if it would but it's possible and
that's why we're suggesting it be
removed could change the underpaid the
underpinnings of that presumption of
openness
representative testerman
um you've made several suggestions and
and I'm assuming most of them are fairly
good you're not the only one who's come
up to the stable who's made several
suggestions uh
I don't yeah I'll leave it up to the the
chair to write this decision but
we need these things to come back to us
as one document
you know that that you all agree to uh
rather than us try to represent them
Testament my okay my question is we
don't debate the witness we ask
questions okay my question is have you
got a single document of all these
changes
that's just yours not just ours no sir
um uh As I understood it there was a
change proposed from The Trial Lawyers
there was a small housekeeping change
proposed from
um commissioner skippa which I think has
been read into the record of then our
changes were emailed to you but but the
answer is no we don't have a single okay
but if I if I may I'm sorry
representative testerman
um I will say that a ton of work has
been reached into into
um working on this product and if you
had been at the commission meetings when
they started you would see how far apart
everyone has come and it's our belief
that
um that that
a ton of work and compromise has been
made to reach a final product and that
this is ready for prime time yeah my
question is I is it's not my job
try to undo those
and I and I'm asking you
to come forward
representative testman
it has to be a question and I think we
the committee all we all prefer bills
arrive here in perfect shape it makes
our makes our responsibility easier but
that doesn't always happen as we can
tell but we don't need to discuss that
anymore one question I I do do really
have
are all the suggestions you you've come
forward with for changes have they been
vetted with the rest of your committee I
think the answer to that is probably no
um we've shared them with the Attorney
General's office but they haven't been
signed off on
representative Byrd
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
uh coming today
on
it got shut off sorry uh
page four line 16 to 18 you spoke of
that they can't be in official capacity
foreign
is your mic on oh my mic had shut off I
apologize for that it should be on now
um I was not on the study commission Mr
lascaz was the representative from the
ACLU of New Hampshire but what I
understand him to be saying is that the
intent of
this language was to prohibit a
representative of like a group of
lawyers like there wouldn't be a
representative from the bar or the
criminal defense attorneys Association I
agree that the language as currently
written probably does prohibit any
lawyer from serving on the commission
and from Mr lascaze I understand that
that to be not in keeping with
um the what the recommendation intended
so perhaps there should be a change to
that I will leave it to to to
um
to director skippa and to assistant
senior Assistant Attorney General
Broadhead to confirm that that's their
understanding too yeah
follow well you know yeah I never got to
my question but so what the question is
I apologize
um
in Goffstown we have you cannot be a
policeman fireman to be a segment
but we do have a retired fireman
and so what my concern was is and I
think you've cleared it up and and so if
you can explain it again just briefly um
you know I wouldn't want that with this
if you're a retired lawyer
uh policeman a judge you know it's it
you have that blood for the rest of your
life so you're always going to side with
that
you know I don't think our retired
uh firemen should be on the select board
because he always votes for that so I'm
just curious if so you're telling me
that
currently the way this is written they
cannot serve
yes which I support so yes the answer to
answer your question yes the way this is
written they would not be able to
support but thank you so what this goes
back to addressing them on line 11 it
says a law enforcement officer of a town
or city employed at a rank below
Lieutenant originally
um that that language had stated that it
would be a representative of a specific
police Union and we had discussions on
that where they could see that because
of the intent of this overall agency is
to be independent and neutral and
objective
the public and the community wouldn't
see it as being objective or independent
if you have a representative that
sitting there that is that represents an
organization or an advocacy group that's
what it was it wasn't the fact that we
that there should be a police officer on
this Council right that can rep that can
bring that perspective of
of a police officer that's not that's
not that doesn't have rank that can go
back to other police officers to be like
hey this is what's coming down the line
this is what happened but he's not
representing a police Union representing
a police Union on the council is
different than having a police officer
there and so it was with that same
mindset that it was like you can have an
individual who's a lawyer or a judge but
they're not there representing
um a specific community group where that
is what they advocate for yeah but Mr
chairman if I may yes yeah uh thank you
but but the way this is written they
cannot if they are a lawyer policeman or
judge be part of that for in line 16
four of the public members correct okay
yep that's perfect that's what I want
thank you
representative Newman
just to follow up on representative
Bert's question
it says certified lawyer judge or does
that all does that also prohibit them
from being a retired
certified officer judge or
I I don't know the answer to that the
the New Hampshire Bar Association has
inactive members who are retired but I
suppose have their license held into
bands I don't know how that would be
interpreted I'm afraid
any further questions
every non-witnesses are excuse thank you
for your testimony
the chair recognizes Mark Morrison
good afternoon my name is Mark Morrison
and I am the past president of the New
Hampshire Police Association I'm also
one of the original liac members and I
served on this
study commission as well and I am here
to Simply offer our support for the bill
as written and with the
the clerical correction as noted by
director skippa
um
everybody is right this was a lot of
work that went into this you know
hundreds of hours of of everybody's time
and this does represent
you know a good collection of opinions
with some very thoughtful very
passionate very at length discussions in
these topics I would not support any of
the changes other than the clerical
correction that was made
and as far as that goes I'll leave it at
that and I'll be happy to take any of
your questions
seeing no questions thank you for your
testimony okay
and and the chair recognizes Chief
Dennis
good afternoon
Mr chair members of the criminal justice
committee I'm Charlie Dennis I'm the
police chief in Hanover
I represented the New Hampshire
Association of chiefs of police
on the liac commission and also on the
commission to provide recommendations
for this bill that has been brought
forward
all members of the commission that I
served on went through numerous meetings
discussions and what I call Healthy
debate to bring forth unanimous
recommendations for you to bring this
bill forward
the Chiefs Association is always looking
for ways to build and strengthen
relationships with the citizens we serve
here in New Hampshire
and we know that that Bedrock of those
relationships is built upon mutual
respect accountability transparency and
Trust
you've heard from the Attorney General's
office and director skippa from police
standards and training and others
supporting this bill
we believe that HB 1682 builds upon that
Bedrock that I just described respect
transparency trust and accountability
I don't want to be duplicative in my
remarks you've heard again from the
attorney general director skippa I'll
just say that the Chiefs Association
supports HB 1682 with the
recommendations and changes that
director Skipper brought forward to you
and that concludes my testimony be happy
to answer any questions
there'll be no questions thank you for
your testimony thank you
is anyone else who wishes to testify who
hasn't signed up
there being no one I will close the
public hearing on HP 1682 FN
the committee will be in recess until 1
30 PM oh
standby
well
yeah I'm hungry say we're in recess
we're not recess you didn't drop the
hammer right no just I closed the bill
drop the Hammers
the criminal justice Public Safety would
not be in recess till 1 30. well we are
we are going to be in recess for at
least five minutes
what are you gonna exactly
what'd you say you can't go back
I would like to
where is Marston
okay
you're also free to go to lunch and not
be here
advice that's awesome
we will be in recess till one o'clock
all right
we're on lunch break not only that you
got here this afternoon
I got to see my surgeon I gotta go see
myself
again
I brought it with me I'm thinking
I'm thinking probably yesterday
did you not see you did you not see your
surgeon yeah I did
five x-rays this morning
right right
it's better why are you now saying I got
to see my surge oh no no I saw him this
morning
that's why I was late yeah I know I knew
that you had said that the other day
that was just teasing y'all
I'll Bet Your Life
he's always doing it to me that's why
he wants to put me in the movies but he
can't spell movie I know
I know
did we hear any other bills after that
last one 18 at 1682.
excuse me John Burt point of order
until we say
no
well I came back
I could have enjoyed my soup
I hope it's all of me
John I don't understand why aren't we
doing something now
because he doesn't want to
he tried to play a game
by me bringing my lunch money
but an inconvenience the rest of you
well you're sharing I don't care if you
pass his lunch found
so
what is the justification for these two
pieces of paper
other than other than killing trees
those will be referred to
too
why didn't you put the bill number on it
no
before you just put them aside until
they mentioned in testimony
that has passed your lunch down please
I don't know about this
we don't know what's going on here
all right
all right good afternoon we will now
call call the order the criminal justice
Public Safety Committee
we now open the executive session
on House Bill 1475.
this time the chair will recognize
representative testerman to make a
motion of author pass and offer an
amendment
I'd like to make a motion uh
ought to pass on the amendment
2022.0006 for house bill 1475. is there
second I'll second that motion motioned
do I have to pass an offer an amendment
has been seconded
representative Greene
representative testman do you wish to
speak to your emotion
just very quickly uh it basically cleans
up uh some words and allows the the
ability of the liquor people to uh
cover the whole state
I don't have it
representative borne you recognize
thank you Mr chairman
I want to oppose the amendment I am not
in favor of it because it basically
gives Liquor Commission
Law Officers
the leeway to enforce all state laws
across all jurisdictions uh
and the original Bill limited uh
those abilities to only three conditions
and I
I like the idea of limiting those uh law
enforcement abilities
thank you
representative true
uh thank you Mr chair
I I uh specifically asked to ask
uh chief
I'm a Ganon gainian
and he said
they are it's that's already in the law
the the amendment or the bill
does not give
the liquor investigators
police Authority
they already have
police authorities just like a state
police
in the incumbent law
so so it's not I don't like that I'm
surprised that that exists
but
this this amendment is not giving them
that Authority they already have it if
if we kill both of these they still have
police Authority throughout the state
representative boarding May respond to
that thank you uh the bill as presented
to us does limit The Liquor Commission
uh enforcement
to uh certain authorities
if we adopt the amendment it goes back
to what it is today and regardless of
whether or not the liquor commissioner
says that the protocols are in place now
that will basically make them operate
like the event the bill as presented to
us
those Protocols are subject to change at
the willm of the Liquor Commission
so I would like to see in law uh
them have the authority that they are
say they're doing today
so I am going to oppose this amendment
thank you
so just to clarify there
under existing law there are some rules
that are in policies that the Liquor
Commission has for its invest its liquor
investigators it does limit the scope of
the authority but the underlying bill
would have done although yes through an
act of legislation we could supersede
those rules or
the problem is the way as written if
let's say there was an armed robbery
at a convenience store that didn't have
any liquor
well the liquor investigator
Would we not have the authority to
intervene
And when they see what is otherwise a
violent criminal act they could also
walk by a issue of the domestic violence
situation and have no
uh jurisdiction or authority to act so
the underlying Bill although well
intended to me perhaps narrow the
authority of the of a liquor
investigator it may went too far when
many of the rules are and procedures for
the liquor investigators already in
place so what this is doing
the primary purpose of what the
amendment is is just changing
the language that references Authority
similar to that of the county sheriff
because that's a constitutionally
elected position and just changing the
Statewide jurisdiction which is more of
a housekeeping matter
so I understand the point being made but
by going down that road we are would be
needing to
understand we are then narrowing what
they can do and at when acting in
emergency situations
representative borne
thank you Mr chair
and if you will look at the original
bill you see that liquor investigators
shall have limited powers and enforce
the following
these are actually three different cases
the first one being other statues of
criminal law only to extend or to stop
the immediate threat of bodily injury
our death if immediate action is not
taken so the example that you just
presented to us they now
under the the bill as it presented to us
they would have that Authority
but pointing if we go
defeat the bill or overrided with this
amendment
the liquor investigators would have the
authority to uh
stop people if they run a stop sign
red light
or even cross a yellow line
so I have to say I don't want my my
liquor investigators pursuing a general
crime I want them to concentrate on a
liquor issues
I believe that that example is against
the policy of the liquor
investigators
specifically making stops for civil
infractions
I understand that you are talking about
policy within the Liquor Commission but
policy within the Liquor Commission
are is changeable by The Liquor
Commission itself
this it would be statute driven and they
could only
exert that Authority if we gave them
additional Authority
so
I am going to still vote against the
amendment I'd like the bill as presented
to us
thank you
representative Newman
I have a couple of questions based just
to clarify maybe your explanation of The
Liquor Commission and what
representative
was just talking about
these it appears that one two and three
they in fact do limit the abilities of
the liquid commissioners
from what they are now is that would
that be correct or not
it it does the point that I was making
is is that there are several rules in
place for liquor investigators to follow
and I'm just
suggesting as to the committee that
perhaps reviewing all those rules in
detail before we start taking away
certain authorities it may already be
the case with involving the rules
because all I'm suggesting all right
this is the primary purpose
is from the sponsor of the bill was to
Simply clarify the language that was
really referencing the county sheriff
where it shouldn't have been I I
understand that also and I think he may
have in
misunderstood how limiting these are so
it appears like in section one
that on on if there enforces another
statute but only to stop immediate
threat of bodily injury or death is a
pretty severe limitation
and I I wouldn't agree with that kind of
limitation I just wanted to make sure
that it was a limitation as I understand
it
well I'll give you an example if
someone's breaking into a house or a
store that the store is closed there's
no real threat of bodily injury right
but a liquor investigator is driving by
sees it happening they would have no
authority to act
they are alarm there are otherwise a law
enforcement officer who went through
same training as a state trooper but
because we passed this bill as
originally filed they would have no
authority to act in that case because
there's no threat to any bodily injury
and they would have to get permission
from local offices which by the way in a
scenario like that they're likely going
to call it in in local offices would
also respond to it but
they would have to wait and get
permission first that's that's the
difference
and my concern is that they are officers
I assume they're armed I assume that
they're well that they've been well
trained in in dealing with those other
statues I I personally would not agree
with that limitation on enforcing
statutes
thank you
representative Catherine
well we were talking about the amendment
but it's very clear here that the liquor
investigators shall have statewide
jurisdiction with reference to
enforcement of all laws either in
cooperation with or independently of the
offices of any County or town that's
pretty heavy
and I so for me I would definitely be
against this amendment
and and if they want to be policemen
then they should
go to the academy for police they do go
to the academy they don't get the full
police they get a partial a portion of
it or based on alcohol
so I believe the representative from
representative true said this sorry I
forgot you tell him
the representative true said this that
they already have the Statewide
jurisdiction that's an existing law the
issue with the existing law is not what
the the bills actually addressing it's
it's housekeeping the language the
concern was was again the constitutional
appointed position of a sheriff is
elected so the reference in elected
official they didn't find was
appropriate in the changing the language
to say Statewide jurisdiction
by saying you have the jurisdiction of
every County Sheriff it's what I believe
the original intent was it just this
clarifies that
so whether
we want to discuss the the you know
jurisdiction of liquor enforcement
another day that's just not what this
bill is intended to do at least what the
amendment would do
representative Welch
yes uh the the amendment
changes none of their duties at all it
just changes where their Authority comes
from it doesn't come from the the
sheriff's
it comes from this law
and there's to me it's a simple
Amendment and I and I think the
amendment clarifies it
this time the matter will now be put to
question if you are in support of
adopting Amendment 2022-0006h
please say yay if you opposed please say
hey the clerk and I'll call the roll
representative Roy yeah
representative Welch yeah
representative Bert
representative
yes
representative Rhodes
representative Testament
of true yes
representative Pratt
representative Marston
uh
Kirk says nay
let me see
representative boardnet
representative Muse
oh sorry
representative Newman
yes
Corrections yes
I'm sorry
sorry Newman is a yes yes I am
Conley
yes
no
the chair votes yes and to remind the
clerk for any members who are not
present just please just read off their
name
oh
you want to hear that now
yes o'hern and Muse
that's it right
oh and golden
anybody else
that's it
sorry about that
o'hern
Muse panta lockers and
golden
all right absent
from this
oh oh wait a minute
I don't know
14-3 we're getting there
by a vote of 14
yes
in three Nays the amendment is adopted
and I just asked the community the
original clerk is not here today
representative Eric Abbott is
substituting so what's
bear with her
at this time representative Testament
you wish to make emotion motion of ought
to pass as amended
and representative green you wish to
second that most second that motion
so who was the first one
who was the first one I'm sorry green
was the second who did the first one
Larson again
Testament
representative Roy you're recognized
thank you um I just wanted to address a
um
representative gathright's question
about um I too had the concerns
regarding the um Statewide powers of all
laws and then I went back and I looked
at the actual statute as it exists now
and that's exactly what it says they
have power over all laws except for
they're listed as sheriffs versus
Statewide authorities so the only thing
liquid said would be changed
we're not giving them any more power
than they already have with this
the current statue says all laws
representative board name
sure
I agree that the bill as we now have
amended is an improvement over present
law
but I do and I will support it but I do
realize you have to realize that the
bill as it was presented to us did limit
the powers of the Liquor Commission
investigators and I thought that that
was a great idea that is what they say
today that they do
so I think that that bill is a
reflection of what is present in the Now
The Liquor Commission but those those
Protocols are subject to change by
whoever becomes the next liquor
commissioner
thank you
at this time the matter will now with
the question if you were in support of
the motion of ought to pass as amended
please say yay if you were opposed
please say nay the clerk will now call
the roll
um yes
yes
wrote
Testament
true
yes
correct
Marston yes
works as nay
Panther Marcus is out or Hearns oh
wardenay
uses out Newman
yes
um
Conley
by night
yes and Bradley yes
sorry for your
the chair vote Yes
by a vote of 16 years and one day the
motion of octopus has amended passes
does it does anyone anyone wish to move
for consent
so moved
Mr chair
representative true you recognize for
your point of order
we had a problem
with this situation about people being
absent in the past
I don't think we called the lull like we
normally call the role
we don't call the bowl
uh pandalacas Ahern uh Amanda bold
that's not how we
representative true I I your point of
order is well taken
uh is there I would say one
the role has already been called and the
vote's completed so the point of order
needs to be would have been need to be
made right away
and
understanding that the regular clerk is
not here today I just would ask if some
leeway with with representative Harry
Catherine who I asked her to fill in
in
I I'm thankful that you did that
I understand that uh I mean I made the
ruling on the point of order uh
and procedures of this committee
uh if you don't call the roll correctly
you redo it
that's our past practice and procedure
and what was incorrect about the role
the way the members were called
the point you you are making is well
taken if I'm going to rule that the way
the role was was called was was correct
and if you wish to challenge a ruling
the chair you may do so
much
I could have representative true fill in
for the clerk the rest of the day if
you'd like
a second
representative testman do you going to
make a majority report
will it be a Minority Report
yeah until noon time Nick come by
tomorrow
at this time we'll now
you start before you begin you are now
recognized for your point of order
please State your point of order
yes my point of order is I thought that
I heard in a unanimous consent request
for the consent calendar I maybe I may
be incorrect I'm just curious your point
of order is not a point of order uh
therefore you are it's out of wood
that's a parliament parliamentary
inquiry and just remember a point of
order is an objection that requires us
to stop the entire hearing because you
believe a rule is not being followed
please you didn't State a point of order
to just
asking a question so at this point I've
made my decision I've already ruled that
your point of water wasn't a point of
order and we're moving on
at this time we are now going to close
the executive session on House Bill
1475.
um
thank you
at this time we are opening
you may approach we're now opening the
public hearing on House Bill 1539
at this time the chair recognizes
representative
thank you Mr chairman
my name is representative will infantine
representing Hillsboro 13.
which is the east side of Manchester
and bring forward
House Bill 1539 today
at the request of a constituent
and I'd like to tell the story
behind the reasoning for the legislation
it's a young woman is a friend of our
families and was involved in an incident
approximately 18 months ago
she attended a
party a day-long party at her
boyfriend's home
and you know how those can go in the
summer toward the end of the evening
she was too intoxicated to drive
but still wanted to drive
her boyfriend thought better of that and
hid her keys and it would not let her go
she didn't like it and called the police
this was not uh
in the city of Manchester for the state
police were called and dispatched to the
situation the scene
unfortunately
when the police got there they did the
best they could
they were there for an hour and a half
trying to figure out what to do
and I don't fault the state police at
all they were doing their job
and the only thing that they knew what
to do was in the discussions uh
young woman
stated that she had knocked the glasses
off her boyfriend's head trying to get
away and they felt that was enough
grounds and she was arrested for
disorderly conduct
about a few weeks later and she got an
attorney and went and saw the prosecutor
and they determined that there was
nothing to see here folks uh and dropped
all the charges
the um however the situation
stays on the State Police blotter her
name and her infraction
so she would wanted to get that removed
now that the charges were dropped
she contacted the prosecutor she talked
contacted the state police
to which you know politely they said
sorry there's nothing we can do about it
talk to Google
um
I brought a letter
to the governor
he thought something should be done he
sent it to Attorney General's office
they said it's not our jurisdiction
so prosecutor couldn't do anything
Governor couldn't do anything uh
attorney general couldn't do anything
and the state police said I'm sorry we
you know
the public has the right to know
so I'd like just to read a statement
from the young lady if I could
I'm running to you this is the letter
she wrote to the governor I'm writing to
you for help with a personal issue
I feel my future is compromised
allow me to explain I was arrested for
misdemeanor September of 2020 and the
charges were eventually dropped
I'm now facing judgment and backlash
because my arrest is easily found in the
state New Hampshire blotter while
searching my name on the Internet
this is affecting my future work success
and livelihood my job search and my
start and then my startup business
it's also having an effect on my
personal relationship as I am single and
still dating all the above people are
likely to to perform a Google search by
name and it blotter is the first item
that comes up I've spent over a thousand
dollars trying to remove that to no
avail
this is a potential to ruin my
reputation as a human resource
professional a new business owner a
daughter an aunt and neighbor
I'm uh other than this case I've been an
outstanding citizen I would like your
help in getting this removed from the
blotter
so the original Bill written by
legislative Services put the onus on the
state police to review all cases that be
uh come dropped I didn't think that was
appropriate didn't want to put the onus
on them
I'm going to put the owners on the
individual who had been arrested to
contact the State Police if they fell if
their their charges were dropped if they
felt that they wanted this removed from
the blotter
um
again no malice toward the state police
they did their job they did it right
but there should be a mechanism in place
where an individual can have things
dropped now if representative Burt and I
were in a bar
and our we were defending our wives
honors and uh
some big thugs came after us and then an
altercation happened and later on
when it was all said and done and
figured out and they saw that looked at
the videotapes and saw that John and I
were defending ourselves
um I'd like that opportunity as I think
representative Burke and maybe others
here in this room would like
the end of my testimony I'd be happy to
take questions
representative Klein Knight you
recognized thank you chairman thank you
uh representative infantine for taking
my question can you define the word
request on line 10.
what that would mean to you as an
individual
should would you be open to an amendment
because I'm sorry for clarification I
don't know if that means a phone call in
writing an email what kind of request
should the individual be giving to the
police
thank you representative for the
question very well Point well taken it
should be something at least a written
request and I would be amenable
representative borne
Mr chairman thank
you so I I haven't heard testimony from
the state
but I'm
uh and they he I think your testimony
you indicated they
couldn't remove it because Google
wouldn't let them
is it possible that something that might
be in a minimal would be to add a note
to the blotter entry that indicated that
drop the charges were dropped would that
be satisfactory
well uh representative obviously getting
something is better than nothing
um however
um
based on the testimony of the the
individual I read
having something up there on a Google
search as we all know many of us either
like or dislike things that are said
about us on social media and such
um yeah I would rather it not be there
if the all the charges are dropped but I
would if the decision of this committee
would be
that we're either going to kill the bill
or go with that I would obviously take
the ladder I do just want a question
um
[Music]
correct something I think I just heard
you say the individual it was a state
police that said if you know we can't do
it maybe you should ask Google if he can
well they're not going to override the
State Police blotter understandably
um and um
so I just wanted to make sure that was
clear
um of what the scenario was
I think that is what I I try to
reiterate and that's what I heard okay
thank you
representative Roy
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
it's not the police blotter
a historical record of a public event
without question it is and what was
that's why I might just add to my answer
and what was stated by the state police
to the individual
or was that you know the the
citizens have the right to know and of
what happened
I I think my question comes down to the
police had a very difficult decision to
make
okay
um and they did the best they could
when it all said and done the prosecutor
felt that there wasn't something that
merited any charges
so the way I look at it is that
it's by removing it it may be correcting
the record by the record not being there
I mean if I'm accused of a heinous crime
by someone and I get arrested and comes
and finds out that
there's no merit to anything
then I do believe
um
there should be a way that that gets
expunged from the record especially if
it's
the original
opinion of the police officers was
proven to be that it really
may not have been accurate
thank you
representative Greene
thank you Mr chair
I thought I had it on uh the boyfriend
took her keys and he hit him
he probably may have saved her life and
maybe saved the fact that she may have
had had a head-on collision with someone
else and killed them
Representative no doubt and I have no
issue with what the the boyfriend did I
don't think that's the part I'm trying
to the point of of the legislation but
you were recognized for your point of
order
thank you chairman I I think um to put
uh assumptions aspersions on a person's
character without knowing the full story
is inappropriate
can you please reference a rule or
anything in Mason specifically to your
point of order
or any house rule
1352.
do you want to recite that rule sure
your point of war is well taken I will
say that the member that was not really
a question was more of a comment
so let's try to I'll remind everyone was
please
we asked what we phrase questions
and that's how that's how we're supposed
to do it
okay
you may respond you're in the middle of
a sense I'll allow you to continue thank
you representative Mr chairman uh I'm
not uh questioning what either was done
this is unfortunate tonight we wish it
all never happened uh and I don't
disagree with you the right thing was
done there it was as I said it was
complicated incident it has to come down
to the fact that once the charges were
dropped
I feel that an individual should have
the ability to have that
record on the police bought or bought or
removed under that circumstances where
the charges are dropped
if they requested
you recognize for a follow-up question
uh
if the state police showed up and she
was still intoxicated would she have
been arrested for DUI
you don't
you don't that's not question that not
appropriate for the witness to address I
I would ask you not to respond to that
representative Marston you recognized
thank you Mr chairman and thank you uh
representative infantine for taking my
question
let us suppose that your bill passes it
would still be on the Google
website and yet it might have now a
follow-up that it was expunged in the
state police records would that be
correct
based on what representative bordenet
had offered as a suggestion I think that
would be the case you have to understand
once things are on on the internet the
way it works anytime anyone opens that
back up it keeps coming back to the top
and so
it's out there
but it just wouldn't be on the police
border which will allow this person at
least to then have other accolades that
she has received from being an HR
professional that kind of brings it down
a little bit so it's not the first thing
that comes up when you see the young
lady's name
thank you
representative Bradley you recognize for
a question thank you chairman and thank
you for taking my question
um So currently are you saying that she
has no way to expunge her record
it would be hard for me to say no way
but a thousand dollars worth of those
companies it'll help you expunge those
things hasn't worked it will go down
three or four spaces it'll put up some
accolades and other achievements that
she's had in life and then as soon as
the it seems like as soon as the blotter
is opened by anyone at any time it comes
back up
so attempts have been made to no avail
thank you that's exactly what I was
getting at so
charges have been dropped but yet she
you're mostly okay all right thank you
representative Newman you recognize for
a question
I had a parliamentary inquiry I'll wait
until the appropriate time
representative Klein Knight
thank you chair
um
do you know uh if where it says online
11 and a line 23 the computer system for
the police department if that that's not
accessible to the public right that's a
back end private system for them
no when the when the police thank you
for the question I don't believe that is
accurate this is not their their
internal system this is their public
uh when they report their
I don't know the term blotter uh report
their activities
uh it is out there for anyone to see if
you go to the state police
website I believe you can go up and just
find where on the site
they can check
um
for their calls and incidences and that
would come up out of that date
thank you Mr chair thank you Mr
infantine for taking my question short
of expunging the record entirely that is
a historical record would it be possible
to uh
anonymize
that the record stays there but the name
is gone
the record of an arrest did take place
uh and uh it was and it it didn't get
pursued so that the record is still
there but the person's name is gone
anonymized
there could be a possibility
representative I just don't know
um
how the the state police would do that
uh the state that they went to so and so
uh residents at a so and so time and
arrested uh blank I don't know how that
would or arrested an individual but
I don't know representative
okay the chair May inquire with a
question
so if this were to pass that the records
may have come off the stapley's website
but would that the arrest records still
be public record
I believe it would yes
represent representative Welch
Quest and line 23 and line 10. and that
way it's stated signed and it's a
if anybody checks into it they'll know
why it happened
so I I would suggest that we amend that
thank you representative that's that was
as a suggestion of Representative Knight
representative Klein Knight you're
recognized thank you
thank you and we're confused with what
has updated computer system really mean
does the record still stay there and uh
we if it it's right to know law so the
record does need to stay there I think
we have some amending to do with your
permission to Define some of these
ambiguous terms so that we're
specifically requesting that the
information for our constituents is off
social media but the record is remains
with the police department and if
anybody were to request it they could
still have access to this information is
that correct yes that is I will
apologize um
you know this is the first time in 15
years as a legislator I've been down to
this committee and I I find it similar
issues we have in the labor committee
where people come and they think they're
doing something right but you get to see
you folks see a lot more
than I ever understand
about the criminal justice system so my
apologies
I uh thank you chair I apologize for all
these questions I really do like this
bill but I for clarity's sake I would
just like to clear some uh concerns up
was your constituents picture posted on
social media before a conviction
blotter it's blog that I have seen that
does not have a picture it is just a
written statement of the call the time
the place and that someone was arrested
for a a
infraction of crime
but there's no no picture
follow-up
doesn't that in some way keep her uh
privacy and we all share many names
around the country with many individuals
what would her picture not being up
there protect her
uh her her Point she has a um the way
she spells her name is uh you is
relatively unique and I think that's the
situation
I pulled the name up in of all the names
of the individual would have a similar
name I was surprised that was the first
one to come up
representative Newman
I have a parliamentary inquiry and I
don't know
please stay your parliamentary inquiry
my parliamentary inquiry is that I've
noticed that there's a typo in in one of
the line sentences in here and my in my
inquiry is is that handled
administratively or would it be
appropriate to point that out to the
sponsor so that he can have that
corrected
any member of the committee is free to
contact legis uh legislative services to
actually get an amendment
oh thank you just if there's a mistake
in the bill anything you want to change
at this point I assume every member of
the committee knows how to get an
amendment drafted
follow-up I might recognize you for
follow-ups thank you
representative Bert you're recognized
thank you Mr chairman and thank you uh
representative for bringing this
incredibly good bill
I think
we are way overthinking this so let me
understand what your intentions are so I
understand but
I mean this state as it's not directed
to represent from Goffstown we ask
questions
that's is ask State the question I'm
asking a question it's not just you it's
me going around since we all came back
ask the question of the witness that's
it if it's if the first sentence is not
a question I'm going to deem the member
out of order I'm going to move on next
all right my question
is
with this wonderful written bill
your intention is
I was accused of something that I never
did and I could prove I was over an ex
place but my name is on the State
website I want to get a job
with my name on the State website please
by removing that wouldn't that help me
get that job
and that's what this bill is about
is that true that is correct that is one
of the points I do not want to but I do
not want to expunge the record the
record is the record right this person
will always have to deal with this if
someone does a criminal background check
there's no doubt about that not trying
to do it it has to do with the the
blotter itself it is up there for a lot
of people to see and then when the
charges were no longer or the charges
were dropped that is because it does I
don't know what the system the state
police utilize but it gets picked up on
the world wide web
it is up here that is the only thing I'm
looking to have expunged not the record
not the charges not everything so you
will have to deal with that the active
or the consequences that you have
because of what went on
thank you
thank you for your testimony thank you
everyone
the chair now recognizes Victor muzzy
thank you chairman thank you members of
the committee my name is Victor muzzy I
am a lieutenant with the New Hampshire
State Police assigned to record
Information Services
um and I I can offer The Following on
the language and the proposal and the
proposed bill here I think there's been
a lot of discussion here this afternoon
that were of some of concern to the
state police
and while I appreciate the intent I
think the the language is a bit
Broad in a sense that
our position as the
that the arrest did occur
the extent by which uh what results from
that arrest whether the charges remain
or not that's obviously handled through
a different process
um I think our issue is the word State
Police
computer system implies that our
internal records things like that would
be affected by this request which in the
interest of safety and transparency
obviously we would not want to alter
that because the arrest did occur in
fact for a time and place however
with respect to what the representative
clearly articulated relative to the
website that's
far more easy for us to employ upon a
written request from a defendant where
that's the case we can certainly do that
I will only add my concern is
and I think it's been stated here in
some assemblies today that is that if
another media Outlet Google whomever
captures our blotter from our website
via a screenshot via something else we
immediately lose control of that and it
may very well be that it still comes
back on top of Google's search list or
something like that so while I agree
that certainly from our public-facing
website removing that charge or removing
that arrest at the request of the
defendant is something we could do we
can't prevent what might be that
negative publicity for that person if
that's captured by somebody else after
we've put it out
and what I can say relative to our
weekly blotter is as it stands currently
that blotter is a snapshot in time and
is sent out in a PDF format to our media
Outlets we don't
to my knowledge we may very well post it
on our website we probably do but there
again the format of that is a PDF it's
not a living breathing roll call if you
will of arrests that have been made and
therefore we could remove the blotter as
we've done in the past from our website
I think our concern is how far and how
deep has this spread beyond our control
with the intent of the language in the
bill and what is Our obligation and
responsibility to recall or withdraw
that is is our biggest concern
thank you for taking my comments and
I'll be happy to take any questions
representative Herrick gathright
correct so if that's true why are you
opposing the bill
I think because of the language in it
where it talks about computer system I
don't I don't know what the definition
of definition of computer system is
if that's really intended to be our
website then I think the language should
read public website versus
computer system in addition because that
insinuates in my
interpretation that it's
broader than just the website or some
public facing advertisement that we've
made
it's clarifying if the chairman inquire
with a question and thank you for taking
my question is it the
is it the concern that by having to
remove the arrest records from the
computer system that that would
basically be scrubbing
all the data that the Staples has of of
a prior arrest
from their system correct I think in the
interest of transparency in an event
having occurred if we're to alter our
record system our records management
system to reflect that this arrest never
occurred because the charges were no
profits or dismissed pursuant to the
language and the written request or
request was made by the defendant
that somehow it's it's a double-edged
sword because that did occur and we
should have a record of that because it
did occur but yet we now don't have a
record of that I think is is the concern
certainly the public facing portion of
that I understand and have no no
objection to that I think it's what is
the intent of this bill how deep does
this removal or alteration of the record
go and what does that really mean I
think is our concern
thank you for taking my question yes sir
representative boardney
thank you Mr chairman
there is uh sent out as a PDF yes sir
now is that uh PDF uh have
uh historical data on it or is it
updated ever so often or
so that original record as it's still in
the in the next PDF you send out
good question sir the the arrest blotter
is typically drafted for a week's time
period and we post that on a weekly
basis at the moment we're currently not
doing that as we're working with our new
vendor to build out that report that we
have historically sent out
so that's run on a weekly basis and post
it on a weekly basis and what has
happened with the data from the week
prior
on our website I don't have the answer
to that and obviously don't have any
control over what happens to it beyond
that but
I guess what I was trying to articulate
was that it's it's a snapshot in time
and that it's sent out in a fairly
finite format meaning it's it's a page
of paper essentially in a PDF format and
sent out on a weekly basis
um
I I didn't
inquire of our own website how long we
keep those if they're searchable by week
time frame or if it's a running list if
you will
I think what we would have to do is if
there was a request made to remove
someone's information pursuant to the
bill if it passes we would have to
re-run that blotter for that given time
frame and replace that on our website to
be reflective of that change
that makes any sense mechanically
speaking would have to change that out
I think I understand thank you very much
thank you
thank you Mr chairman and thank you sir
for taking the question
as this document is shared with the
media and with the public on a regular
basis
with any change to this document
necessitate resending the document as a
means of correcting quote unquote
correcting the record I could with
multiple different versions of a of a
blotter existing it
it's a scenario I don't think I've
encountered before
so if I understand you you're asking
that if this if a request was made
pursuant to this bill by an individual
would we then resend that blotter for
the period of time and question out to
the media to say here's the corrected
version of that
that is the question and I should say as
in a past life I was a news reporter and
I would get these all the time and um
these have uh
I'll stop it there but I guess would
there be any correction of the record uh
done by State Police other than
scrubbing it from the website
no
Unless somehow the bill changed it was
reflective of that that required that we
send it back out
again I think immediately upon hitting
send we have no control over it except
for and on our website
so if the union leader for example
captured that somehow or another or some
other news media Outlet captured that
for that given point in time we could
ask them to certainly repost the new
information that we've put out
but I we would have no control over it
and to to the representatives point it
would still be there on the on the world
wide web I guess is our concern so
I guess it goes into a broader question
of where do we post and how do we post
our arrests
um and where is that information stored
that that's probably a discussion for a
different day at this point but
representative Klein Knight
thank you chair
um when media requests arrest record
how frequently do they do that for for
their own websites
don't have a direct answer to that I
know that as a matter of regular
practice we send it out on a weekly
basis
follow-up chair
you're recognized for a follow-up so you
send it out on a weekly basis would it
not be a crazy idea to also send out
with that a list of those removed to the
social media outlets on this record
the way the system would capture that is
we we run on a rush report for events
that occurred between
date a and date B
and that happens on a weekly basis and
it's typically Friday to Thursday which
is which is our weekly time frame so
what happened last week doesn't get
reposted again currently this week for
example
that's not what I'm I asked of apologies
you may ask a follow-up question thank
you we do not debate the witness right
thank you
um
I'm gonna
try and clarify
not what they post on a week to week
basis what you give them on a
week-to-week basis could you also
include in that week if you had any
requests from a citizen to remove their
record could you also include that when
you give them the weekly report this is
what we receive these people have been
expunged
in what format I guess
as my assistant is the member asking uh
is this could the state police include
that the member of the public requested
that they be removed from the website
when they put their information out
there to the media sites is that what
you're asking
I I don't know the answer to that at the
moment
sounds reasonable I don't know how to
execute that
thank you
representative true you recognize for a
question
thank you Mr chair thank you lieutenant
for taking my question
could you please tell me if I'm
correctly stating restating your opinion
that you can the state police can remove
from the public internet website this
information
but there is a legal difficulty in
removing it from a computer system
because you can't arbitrarily expunge
historical data
correct thank you
thank you
thank you thank you for your testimony
representative did you have a question
you're excused thank you
if I could just inquire that I see the
bill sponsor still here if I can just
ask one question
uh
would there be it would you have any
concern with
if we just struck the term computer
system and
from both lines 11 and 23 of this this
bill in an amendment I would not it was
never my intent to expunge the record uh
the difference differential by naivete
for not knowing the difference between
LL how a legislative Services wrote the
computer system versus uh web web page
so no I would not have any problem I
would appreciate that Mr chairman
thank you
at this time we can now close the
executives
excuse me the public hearing on House
Bill 1539
at this time we are now opening the
public hearing on House Bill 1540
someone to introduce the bill
is your member
you may you may approach
thank you
let's see where are we now did we just
open something
before
representative Vault you were recognized
the record I'm representative Welch to
represent Rockingham District 13. I was
asked to put this bill in
and again I'm not going to board the
committee with my opinions
there are experts who suggested that
this bill
you put in and they will answer the
questions
thank you representative
at this time the chair recognizes
by sheer
thank you
oh
it's
it's my it's my understanding you
weren't ready to testify the clerk has
informed me that you wish to be called
later on
okay
you made me excuse I will recall you as
a witness
this time the chair recognizes Lori
Roberts
there you go there we go
thank you very much Mr chairman and
members of the committee my name is Lori
Roberts I am a state policy Advocate at
the national Innocence Project
uh we're an organization that works to
exonerate the wrongfully convicted and
we also work with our local Partners
including the New England Innocence
Project on policy reforms that prevent
wrongful convictions
we strongly support HB 1540 and we thank
representative Welch for his work on it
as well as representative Bert and wall
for their support
this legislation would require
electronic recording of custodial
interrogations in their entirety from
the reading of Miranda rights to the end
of the questioning this creates an
irrefutable account of what occurred
during the interrogation which benefits
the innocent law enforcement and
taxpayers that is why legal and law
enforcement organizations have endorsed
electronic recording as a safeguard
against false confessions including the
national uniform law commission the
International Association of chiefs of
police the American Bar Association the
American legislative exchange Council
and many others
um
also 30 States already require this
practice for at least the most severe
crimes including neighboring Maine
Vermont Massachusetts and Connecticut
and the federal federal law enforcement
agencies including the FBI and DEA
record interrogations for all crimes
it can be hard for people to believe
that someone would admit to a crime they
didn't commit but nationally false
confessions have played a role in nearly
a third of wrongful convictions later
overturned by DNA evidence and of those
cases the real perpetrator went on to
commit and be convicted of 48 additional
violent crimes including 14 rapes and 25
murders
so there is a very real Public Safety
implication to false confessions and to
wrongful convictions
as we advocate for these laws around the
country we typically hear three
questions what are the costs how can
small agencies implement this practice
and why should this be required
and in the interest of time I'll be
brief but I'm happy to go into any more
detail on any of those questions for the
committee
um
to better understand costs the Innocence
Project surveyed law enforcement
agencies in Wisconsin and Massachusetts
which have required the practice for
over a decade
we received responses from over 100
agencies 111 to be exact both large and
small and none reported any problems
with implementation
smaller agencies
reported using handheld digital video
cameras that retail for fifty to 100 and
several agencies also reported using
body cameras to record interrogations
most reported storing recordings on
existing computer servers or burning
them onto DVDs meaning that they didn't
have to buy additional storage
and in general what we found was that
recording interrogations actually saves
money by reducing lawsuits stemming from
frivolous allegations of misconduct
against police officers improving Court
efficiency by reducing motions to
suppress and increasing plea deals and
protecting taxpayers from multi-million
dollar civil payouts associated with
wrongful convictions
next how can small agencies with limited
resources Implement a recording of
interrogation's policy what we found in
our survey was that about 13 of agencies
that responded had 10 or fewer officers
and most of those agencies reported that
they used handheld digital recorders for
interrogations
small agencies that want to use more
high-tech recording systems can consider
equipment sharing agreements with larger
agencies 22 percent of our survey
respondents said they had equipment
sharing agreements with local state or
federal agencies
and then finally why should this be
required well
a number of agencies in New Hampshire
have already implemented this practice
based on Outreach conducted by former
U.S attorney Thomas Sullivan and the
Innocence Project these agencies include
Carol Concord Conway Enfield Keen
Laconia Lebanon Nashua Plymouth
Portsmouth Swansea and the state police
which is a great start but there needs
to be a uniform Statewide practice to
ensure the fair administration of
justice throughout New Hampshire
otherwise agencies could simply choose
not to record choose to record only in
certain cases or choose to start and
stop the tape when they want
a requirement would ensure a uniform
Statewide practice of recording
interrogations otherwise someone in
Derry may not have the same protections
as someone in Hanover and are on the
same side of the coin an officer falsely
accused of misconduct in Dairy would not
have the same protections as an officer
in Hanover
uh there also needs to be a remedy for
failure to comply HP 1540 follows the
model of States like Texas Utah Alaska
and Connecticut
by suppressing an unrecorded statement
but still allowing the state to overcome
this presumption if they show that the
statement was voluntary and reliable and
there was a reasonable justification for
why the statement was not recorded
so finally to help agencies with
implementation the Innocence Project has
created a law enforcement primer based
on our survey and other research and we
have model policies from the
International Association of chiefs of
police that would be we would be happy
to make available to every agency in the
state
electronic recording not only improves
justice but it improves efficiency and
Savings in the criminal justice system
and we would welcome the opportunity to
work with law enforcement to make
implementation as easy as possible
we really appreciate the committee
considering this bill and we strongly
hope you will vote in favor thank you
very much
representative Roy
thank you for taking my question
um looking at the definitions in the
bill under custodial interrogation is
have you is this definition matched by
the Supreme Court definition of
consortial interrogation
of the uh Miranda as you know that's
what triggers Miranda is custodial
interrogation so does this match that
um I believe it does but I
on that but in the bill the the
definition is that it's a reasonable
person would uh consider themselves to
be under uh interrogation
but I'm happy to get a positive answer
on that for you
thank you I I asked because it would if
the two conflict wouldn't you agree that
that would be a problem absolutely thank
you
thank you for your testimony thank you
thank you in respect of the prior
witness uh witness is there any did you
provide testimony electronically as well
if you'd like to maybe bring a copy up
that would be appreciated
at this time the chair recognizes Lynn
uh Cusack
thank you Mr chair I do have um I sent
stuff in electronically but I also have
a
um
may also hand them to the clerk thank
you
[Music]
good afternoon Michigan Mr chair members
of the committee my name is Lynn Marie
kuzak and I am a
attorney for the New Hampshire
Department of Corrections as well as the
Director of Professional Standards at
the department the department is neutral
on this bill although we do have a few
concerns
um and as honorable member already asked
the question about what it means to be a
con a custodial inner
custodial interrogation
the term custodial energy
interrogation is one that is really not
defined well in this bill
and I say that because it's unclear from
the Department of Corrections standpoint
what that really means an individual
that's already arrested already
sentenced and already in custody could
have an argument that any time they are
questioned by an officer one of my
investigators a corrections officer a
parole and probation officer that they
are subject to a custodial interrogation
that's not what I think the intent of
this bill is the intent of the bill I
believe is to make a recording of any
custodial arrest that occurs and if we
look at the definition of RSA 594 colon
1 that defines an arrest as The Taking
of a person into custody in order that
he may be forthcoming to answer for the
commission of a crime
again from our perspective at the
Department of Corrections
there if a new crime is committed we're
certainly going to
record that
any session that is
um
that takes place when that individual is
questioned but when it comes to a
disciplinary hearing when an individual
creates or has an infraction violates
one of our disciplinary rules then they
are potentially going to incriminate
themselves when they're asked a question
about that that's not I believe what the
intent of this bill is and that's where
our concern comes into play because it
does talk about in one of the sections
where these interrogations take place a
Corrections Facility
New Hampshire Department of Corrections
has three prisons has three halfway
houses and a transitional work center so
anytime an individual is questioned in
one of those locations we could expect
them to say we're now being interrogated
in a custodial setting
the other thing that we want to point
out is because it does talk about a
Corrections Facility as a place where a
custodial interrogation could occur
that this doesn't include right now
law enforcement
which would be paroled probation
officers or Corrections Officers so that
was the other unclear piece that the
Department of Corrections was concerned
about again
neutral on the bill but concerned at
specific language in the bill so we have
expressed some thoughts about changes
for the bill
um
and one of those changes not only is to
Define broadly more broadly what it
means to be a law enforcement officer
but change the custodial interrogation
definition and then thirdly to exempt
specifically and explicitly the any
probation parole officer questioning an
individual on a technical violation or
any individual that's already sentenced
in our custody for purposes of an
administrative disciplinary infraction
if the intent of the bill is not to do
those things then we would like that
clarified so that there's no argument in
the future that it a custodial
interrogation could apply in a doc
setting
thank you for your testimony
the witness is excused thank you
it is time that she recognizes by sheer
chair uh my name is sure I'm a police
commissioner in Portsmouth I'm a law
professor at UNH Law And as always uh my
opinion to express today are mine and
they are not those of either the
Portsmouth police commission or UNH law
or UNH proper
um I
to clear up one question that uh
representative Roy had the the
definition of custodial interrogation uh
in 594 a to Roman numeral one is
basically an exact quote from the U.S
Supreme Court case that uh identified
what custodial is so it is incomplete
Accord with uh with the U.S Supreme
Court and and also the New Hampshire
Supreme Court
um
I think uh this is I I testify in
support of uh HP uh 1540 ask uh the
committee members to vote ought to pass
I think for three reasons one uh this
bill uh for recording confessions saves
time and money for the criminal justice
system uh number two it protects police
and number three uh it is uh it is
suggested as a preferable practice by
the New Hampshire Supreme Court though
the New Hampshire Supreme Court has
found as a constitutional matter uh
recording of confessions is not required
uh but they they expressed uh positive
feelings about the the idea of recording
confessions so back to number one and
this will be the substance of my
testimony the major substance um in the
criminal justice system there's a a
creature known as the emotion to
suppress uh that frequently defense
lawyers file them uh and allege a
constitutional violation and seek to
have in this circumstance a confession
suppressed uh
the huge majority of those motions to
suppress a confession under the Fourth
Amendment or the Fifth Amendment or the
sixth amendment uh involved did the did
the police read the Miranda Rights
properly
to the defendant did the defendant
actually waive explicitly or implicitly
wave their Miranda rights uh did they at
any point assert their right to remain
silent did they at any point assert
their clear and unambiguously their
right to counsel by saying you know is
this is this the point where maybe I
should get a lawyer you know there's all
sorts of litigation as I those of you uh
on the committee who have been in law
enforcement you're very familiar with
the litigation about well he said you
know I probably should get a lawyer now
it's how to clear an unambiguous
assertion to write the council that's
those Miranda issues in particular are
litigated all the time
if the confessions
are recorded and the interrogation is
recorded including the Miranda warnings
the huge majority of those disappear
because it's on the record you know it
picks up uh what the words were what the
tone of voice was you know unfortunately
there is U.S Supreme Court case law that
that distinguishes between one saying in
terms of whether it's a clear and
unambiguous a search invocation of the
right to counsel
if you say
maybe I should get a lawyer question
mark at the end
versus maybe I should get a lawyer
statement no question mark
it's just a messy area of the law and
fraught with lots of litigation and if
you're recording confessions really
takes a lot of substance out of that
litigation because it's not a he said he
said circumstance uh and uh so I you
know I think that is a A major benefit
of doing this uh it also it also makes
it much more likely that a motion to
suppress for the uh involuntary
confession that the person was coerced
into confessing uh will ever will uh you
know it will be a lot clearer whether
that's the case or not given what
occurred and what is visually apparent
um number two you know as as uh Ms
Roberts has already described it
protects the police from frivolous
accusations of undue pressure or
inappropriate conduct I mean I think
that is a a good thing it also by the
way if you know if there's less emotions
to suppress files filed related to
confessions
there's a lot less time police officers
are going to have to spend in court
uh that saves their time it saves money
um if you know if there's really not a
contest uh there
uh number three I've already said that
you at the New Hampshire Supreme Court
has spoken favorably of recording of
confessions though it has as a
constitutional matter has not adopted
that practice uh finally you know as
news Roberts said many police uh
departments in New Hampshire
um already record confessions
um and almost all that have body cams
now which is an increasing number uh
they effectively record
um they effectively are recording
confessions
um it is I note in one of the fiscal
notes that uh
there's a suggestion that it would cost
twelve thousand dollars well I don't
think that that assessment takes into uh
into it's by the municipal Association I
think
um they it doesn't take into
consideration the fact that many
departments already do it
um it's not that hard to do if you have
a you know if you have a smartphone you
can do it if you're a solo Police
Department or two people in the police
department all you need is a smartphone
and the storage costs are minimal
um so
um
that's the substance of my testimony
more than willing to entertain questions
if the team may inquire with the
question and I I appreciate a lot of the
points about the judicial economy what
but is there any uh thought on
especially the video recording side of
it of those being dispersed throughout
the public
perhaps maybe just limiting the
requirement to audio is really what I
was asking well you know I I don't know
that if it's part of a police
investigation I don't know that at the
least until the investigation is over
and the case is over it's gonna be ex
it's gonna be required to be turned over
to the public it's not like uh it's a
separate issue when we're talking about
body cams generally I think that that's
you know many of the body cam encounters
uh do not involve criminal charges and
and and so those are on our right to
know basis more accessible but but I
don't think these recordings that are
part of a police investigation or a
criminal case until at the least the
case is over they're going to be
accessible
representative Roy
thank you Mr chairman thank you
um what is your opinion regarding the
comments from the Department of
Corrections regarding the um the
interrogation or questioning of inmates
who are in the state custody
um
there's there's a good bit of
U.S Supreme Court and uh other court
cases that say somebody who's already in
custody isn't in custody for police
purposes if they're being interrogated
by uh department personnel on the other
hand if somebody's in jail on bail and
the police go to interview them in the
jail that's going to count as custody
that's what the case law said that will
count as custody they they don't get and
that's what it is meant here they don't
get in uh they don't get under the uh so
any called so-called exception simply
because it's happening in the
correctional facility
the chairman Inquirer of a question and
thank you for taking my question on
on the first page of the bill lines 20
to 22
excuse me 17 to 19.
with the definition of law enforcement
officer it ends with ori's security
officer employed by an educational
Institution
is that referring to University police
officers or private security uh uh
University police officers uh
you know I
I hadn't thought about like at a school
like Dartmouth the security officers
there I don't know what powers they have
uh under uh in the state who act uh you
know to take somebody into custody
um so I I'm not sure if it's a security
officer at Dartmouth who doesn't have a
relationship with the police department
in Hanover they even have the power to
take somebody into the kind of custody
defined in Roman numeral one
but uh I can think about that some more
and and get back to the committee
thank you
and thank you for your testimony thank
you Witnesses is excused
you may approach thank you
good afternoon everybody I'm Paul
Halverson I'm the Merrimack County
attorney the County attorneys throughout
the state and myself have had several
conversations about this and as written
we don't think that this bill should
pass as written the handout that I just
passed around I'll comment on some of
that but that gives an indication of
some of the difficulties that we see
with this legislation
um by way of background there are ample
constitutional protections that
currently exist
when you look within the New Hampshire
stat statutes particularly a part one
article 15.
put on Article 15 addresses the rights
of an individual regarding questioning
that is the amount of footnotes that
part 1 Article 15 has regarding legis
legal challenges to anything having to
do apartment article 15.
the Constitutional protections
specifically regarding due process and
Miranda amount to about 40 pages of
individual footnotes
when I did a
a quick
electronic search for certain terms
there were 1072 cases having to do with
part one article 15. out of that several
hundred addressed Miranda statement
suppression and audio and video
recording
right now
um
I don't believe anyone can Define
custodial interrogation because
custodial interrogation by the case law
is determined on the facts specific
to that case
you cannot say to any specific set of
circumstances is custody without
analyzing the entire event
on the whole
we believe that's a uh that's a problem
um with this with this proposed
legislation
um there are certainly best practices
and every one of the County attorneys
that I know which is which is all of
them and the police Chiefs that I know
which is a good number here in Merrimack
County is we prospered for over 30
police departments uh and all the ones
I've worked with in other counties to
the north because I've worked in many
Superior Courts at least four different
counties and about maybe a dozen or so
uh about eight or so circuit courts uh
all the prosecutors I know agreed at the
best practice is to record a a a
interview in fact the
the uh the state supreme court has even
issued cases on that 2001 2007 and I
addressed those in the second page of
the uh of the uh handout that I had
indicating that recording is indeed a
best practice so there's no doubt that
that most police departments should be
doing it
um many are doing it and it's a best
practice but not all departments are
capable of of doing it because at a cost
Factor
um
there was a mention of body worn cameras
being able to uh to be used I would note
that the next bill schedule for uh
discussion would actually prohibit the
use of body worn cameras inside of a
facility to record a a interview under
uh on Miranda and in custody that's
House Bill 1600 I believe is scheduled
for your next hearing and uh that would
actually prohibit use of body worn
cameras under certain circumstances
um we also believe that there's a a
probable challenge to this under under
the unfunded mandate portion enumerated
within our state constitution that
addresses uh mandates by the legislature
unfunded with the uh with the lower
organizations and we believe that's a a
possible
challenge to just pending litigation
legislation also so I would urge uh for
a matter of for the sake of time I would
urge you reviewed a document that I
prepared for you uh see some of the
difficulties that we see as uh as uh
prosecutors and um and as written uh we
would ask that you're not pass this
legislation as presented I'll certainly
answer any questions that uh that the
committee members may may have on the
issue I would ask however when you ask
me a question
please speak up I'm one of those people
after 21 years in the military before I
went to law school
I have a very profound hearing loss so
if you could speak up before so I could
hear you I would appreciate it
representative Newman
describe what the references that you
made at the very beginning to the
references with the 40 pages what that
is certainly this is um for the recorded
record the New Hampshire revised
statutes annotated the first volume
contains the Constitutions both the
United States and uh for the State of
New Hampshire the state of New Hampshire
Constitution broken down within parts
Part One Article 15
is within that bound volume
and part one Article 15 as you read it
there are a series of um of footnotes
and case references the case references
that I'm referring to go from page in
the volume that I have and this is
without reference to the pocket part
that has additional references go from
page 228 to
200 and
38 and then there are due process issues
that address footnotes going from
page 255 to page 278 in the volume that
that I have and the volume that I have
was printed in 2017. there are certainly
supplemental materials that were
annotated within the pocket Parts but
that addresses all the Constitution uh
challenges worthy of note within the
bound volume there are certainly many
many more that aren't worth that aren't
mentioned within the uh within a
specific notes
representative Marston
are you a county attorney I am my name
is Paul Alverson I'm the Merrimack
County attorney
thank you
if the chair can inquire with a question
and thank you for taking my question yes
sir
how would your office handle a situation
where the suspect that was arrested
objected to being recorded whether video
or video and audio
that's Case by case and I I wouldn't
want to speculate on how we would handle
it because it would initially be a be
addressed by the arresting Department
how they would handle it so there would
be a lot of a lot of other additional
facts that would be present that that I
couldn't I wouldn't want to speculate on
and like I said it certainly it
certainly best practices to to do a uh a
recording
I'll rephrase the question I suppose if
once the person has been gone been
interrogated if the case were to then be
prosecuted in that circumstance they
would if the if the suspect objected to
being recorded or videotaped and
recorded
and in that case that the way this is
written it would be a presumption that
that interrogation not be admissible
I guess how would you approach a case
like that if you came across it there's
an argument to be made
to party States so we can't record
something if someone uh
uh generally speaking if someone objects
to the recording uh there are exceptions
to uh doing that
um so the argument can be made I believe
that if the individual objects to a
recording if a recording is made for
showing to the uh to the statute that
they could ask to keep that recording
out that's my understanding of uh of the
two-party consent within New Hampshire
thank you
representative true
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question yes sir you just you just
quote quoted the New Hampshire
Constitution part one Article 15 yes are
you saying
this bill is against goes against that
part of the Constitution certainly not
um the bill provides
statutory protections that I believe are
already contained within the
Constitutional protections Within part
one Article 15 as well as U.S
constitutional protections
um uh and I we believe those are
adequate as they are uh now certainly as
I mentioned that there could certainly
be additional best practices mandated by
the legislation or police standards and
training whoever administrative whatever
but uh we don't believe this statutory
provision as it's written is uh is
needed
representative Conley thank you
us understand what percentage of uh
I guess custodial interviews or
interrogations your office encounters
that are not recorded like what's the
breakdown as far as the percentage of
departments that follow what you
describe as best practices in the
department that don't follow those best
practices
you know I'd be reluctant to put a
number on it because
my experience has been I can tell you my
experience the vast majority of ones
that I've been involved in personally
where there was an interview at the
police station War recorded
um I'm speaking mainly for the city of
Concord they do a very good job of uh of
recording our interviews
um
but I'd be reluctant to put a number on
it and I I don't mean to be wishy-washy
about it but I it's just something that
that I just never kept kept kept tabs
about
but I will say that the majority of ones
that I've had were probably recorded
the exceptions might be
um
roadside post arrest
post arrest discussions roadside they
might not be re recorded items such as
that
but generally speaking I would note the
majority of those were that I remember
were reinforced by a recorded statement
later and there's also under the
Constitutional protections if a if a
initial
statement by an individual is suppressed
for some reason that's suppressed
statement if later recorded and there's
a a relief to the pressure that was
placed on the individual to begin with
um that statement could later be
admitted
um
if those uh
first encounter
circumstances are not present that
circles right back to what I mentioned
earlier about about the the
admissibility of a statement is very
circumstantial
representative Roy
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um
so some police tactics uh my
understanding is in order to
um
not necessarily a void but not to set
off alarm is to Avo interview suspects
in places that they would not deem to be
in custody such as at a coffee shop or
something
if this law were in place in all
interrogations that took place within
the police station would that not have a
a chilling effect on the on the
interrogations of that place outside of
custodial interrogation where the court
might take a dim view on those I guess
the I guess the bigger com conversation
the bigger analysis would would be would
that type of conversation be a custodial
interrogation
and there are many things going on when
you evaluate a custodial interrogation
was there a seizure and a seizure is not
the same as custody was there custody
and was there interrogation and as I
mentioned before those are all very
situational and I I wouldn't want to
speculate
on a general question what a court would
or would not do regarding that
thank you
but you know I would comment though on
your question it gives rise to the
rhetorical question of of since there's
so much well-settled constitutional law
on on the issue would this statute by
enacting it bring about statutory
challenges
that are separate and distinct from
constitutional challenges
and drive additional litigation that
generally were covered by a prior
constitutional challenges and um I I
think the answer that might be yes
thank you for your testimony thank you
the witness is excused
at this time that chair recognizes Dan
Conley
good afternoon chairman and committee
members thank you for having me
my name is Dan Conley I am a captain
with the Goffstown Police Department
and I'm the executive officer and
prosecuting attorney for our department
I'm here today on behalf of the New
Hampshire Association of chiefs of
police
and we opposed this bill as written we
certainly understand the desire to
record all custodial interrogations and
um as County attorney said it is a you
know in some places best practice
however there's uh
quite a few obstacles in this bill
um you know and first off is uh you know
the suspect's right to privacy you know
numerous times when we sit down to
interview someone in the police station
in Goffstown Police Department is
fortunate that we have two rooms that
are set up with um
audio and visual recording capabilities
they will ask us not to record this not
to not to record this in any way
um
if this bill is in place
a defendant's or suspect's right to to
ask us not to record him now there's a
presentable uh presumption that any
statements he's made to us because he
asked us not to record
um would be inadmissible
um and like I said while this is
available in two of our rooms
um not all police stations is state of
that fortunate
outside of that there are many different
places
that a custodial interrogation
um and and I do
um
want to say do we have to do have an
issue with the definition of custodial
interrogation as as written in this bill
um these these interviews take can take
place in many different places within
the police station in the sally port in
the booking room area the police station
Lobby
um
uh police officers personal office with
inside the police department
we do have two rooms that are audio and
visual recorded capabilities
to get to that room they need access to
the detectives Division and they need to
physically start and end that recording
if they don't have access to that
which that that division is locked if
there's no detective in there because of
the the files that are kept in there
that are sensitive that has to be locked
they're unable to activate that
um
much like the like I said it's an
independent digital auto recording um
the files from the interview must be
taken off the the networks uh hard drive
and transferred to our department server
we've worked um hard at funding that if
this is put into place
um you know as noted by the New
Hampshire Association of counties the
cost of approximately twelve thousand
eight hundred dollars per recording and
a four thousand two hundred fifty dollar
annual cost per device
um record retention audio retention that
that stuff costs a lot of money we deal
with it every year trying to find money
in the budget to find the uh the place
to put these
um
these uh these recordings and if this is
put into place this is an unfunded
mandate this is going to put a a big big
problem for us that that don't have
these capabilities
and the access even when even though we
have two rooms at the Goffstown Police
Department
if they're being used or they don't have
access to get in there and start the
auto recording devices
now that interview can't take take place
somewhere else in there
if State Police they knew they they are
um they make an arrest they use all
kinds of different police departments
and to book and process uh prisoners
if they they go to a police station that
doesn't have those capabilities what are
they going to do if they come to our our
Police Department that has those
capabilities but it's only in the
detectives room and they can't get to
those detectives rooms they're going to
run into a similar problem there
um but like I said as as this is written
for the for the obstacles this is going
to bring if mandated
um in the funding the funding aspect of
this um we oppose it as written
have any questions
representative Newman
I I just have a question on the uh on
the um
your statement about
the intimate the way it's written you
would have inadmissible evidence if you
did you would not be able to bring
evidence in and I'm wondering how if you
could tell me how
the section that I was able to find
because it was in the bill that I was
looking at
um overcoming the presumption of
inadmissibility how does that relate to
the concerns that you have expressed
like like I said if
there's a presumption of inadmissibility
even if there's just because a defendant
can say I don't want to be recorded not
as a presumption of inadmissibility
um
it just it really so
I I just don't I don't see how that
without anything more
just just because it's not recorded so
there's no
there's no trust there's no Candor
there's no um
you know there's no um unless words a
police officers report a police
officer's testimony you're telling me is
no good just because it's not recorded
is that that's the way it's written
um written and I'm reading it
thank you
representative true
Prospect has the right to refuse to be
recorded
they often well yeah I think every
suspect has a privacy right uh to some
degree and they often ask us when we we
are
conducting an interview we will tell
them is it okay if we Auto record this
we start out with that
um and it's a good amount of times they
say no
thank you
representative Conley
thank you and thank you for taking the
question
I'm surprised that in something as
serious as interrogating a suspect that
they would have a choice in that matter
with um
it was more of a comment and I apologize
for that
um
I'm curious I find it surprising that a
suspect
um and could you help me understand why
that's the case
are you asking me why they say no
forgive me
I am could you help me understand why a
suspect who is potentially accused of a
crime who's being interrogated police
would be given the choice in this matter
and why the police would not
dictate to them that the interview is
being recorded
we try to we try to respect them and uh
build a rapport with them and we're
honest with them we're gonna let them
know that you're being already recorded
We're Not Gonna if we'd sit there and
we'd dictate to them what they're going
to do it's pretty unlikely they're going
to have any rapport with us or talk to
us
representative Platt
uh representative Fred plett from goth
Style
fine thanks I'm surprised you have two
rooms in there this given this tiny
footprint you have for that police
station how do you diminish it
said a question
I'm going to ask a a question so
um we heard testimony that you know and
and we both know you can go to Walmart
and pick up a a video recorder for 50
bucks and you can burn those on the DVDs
so we heard testimony that it's not that
expensive so
um could you speak to that you said that
it would be cost prohibitive how so you
know maybe the the individual device
may not be expensive but to retain that
that file
um cloud cloud space Cloud retention and
to guarantee the the safe retention of
that and to guarantee the safe you know
authenticity of that recording you can't
be just you know recording this on a
personal cell phone
um where there's no you know your body
warm cameras for instance
um 105 D2
it it mandates
the retention period how it's done and
it's spelled just to go you know go grab
a cheap recorder and then what do we get
I mean yes it costs money so it is uh it
is a fund but the the greater
um
the greater budget item is the retention
of these files because we're not keeping
these for a week
um you know sometimes they're kept for
years most times they are especially in
the big cases they're kept for 10 10
plus years and and that that costs money
to keep that storage
thank you representative Marston
this is a general question not just for
your gosh down
do most police people interrogating or
interviewing a suspect ask them if they
want to be recorded and is if they say
no uh the recording stop in general
jurisdictions in the state of New
Hampshire
I I can't speak for other departments I
can speak for
um you know when when you get to those
situations where where they're asked to
be recorded they're usually being
brought in by a detective they go in the
detector and then it's awesome and we're
going to be audio video recording do you
have a problem with that and
when they do say no they do stop it
because they respect their wishes and
you know they're they're trying to build
a rapport and talk to this suspect so
like I said we're not gonna if they wish
to not be recorded we'll stop that
recording
thank you
representative Newman
um
they're in the bill itself it says that
if there's clear and convincing evidence
that that the statement was voluntary
and reliable
if you if someone signed a document that
said that they did not want to be
recorded and that was kept would there
be a big burden caused by keeping a
statement like that showed that
that the interrogation was taken
voluntarily and was not recorded if
would it be a burden to have them sign a
form that they don't want to be recorded
that the basically that's kind of what
I'm asking I don't think it would be a
big burden okay thank you
there'd be enough for the questions
Witnesses excuse thank you
I think so like Daryl just got up and
left me
is anyone else who hasn't filled out a
oh
come on pass it along
the chair recognizes Captain Ebert
foreign
thank you at the risk of drawing the ire
of everyone on a Friday afternoon I
thought uh I may be able to provide some
information so I uh again my name is Joe
Ebert it's Ebert I am a captain with the
state police overseeing our
Investigative Services Bureau uh two
things that I want to touch on the first
is uh representative Roy you would uh
asked a question about the recording of
a conversation one thing I wanted to
address is that the recording of the
conversation is often the least
expensive although it depends on what
mechanism and what you're you're
choosing to do that but it is the uh
what happens to that recording afterward
and the security that is placed on that
recording that is often uh cost uh
prohibitive so in other words could you
download it onto a disk yes not a best
case scenario because you want to have
that encrypted in some way so that if
that disk is left in some uh
public area by accident that it is not
accessible so there are again I'm not uh
going to
address the amount that was given in
terms of the fiscal note on this but uh
I would say that it is I think a little
bit more involved than just downloading
it uh there need to be specific uh there
should be specific protocols uh in how
you handle a recording once you have
obtained it the other thing I wanted to
address is just there has been a lot of
uh questions over what what happens if a
a defendant somebody you've arrested
says I don't want you to record me we
don't record them uh it would be my
understanding of it is it would be a
violation of the one party statute
oftentimes that's uh a point of
frustration for me I I would much rather
have the ability to speak to somebody be
able to look at them eye to eye not be
taking notes and and to make sure that
everything that is being said is being
accurately captured
um but that uh that is certainly their
right if they say I don't want you to
record me and oftentimes people will say
to us I will not speak to you unless
you're not recording me so in those
circumstances I think that this
particular bill would be problematic
though I understand the intent of it I
wanted to bring those things forward and
I'm happy to answer any questions that
anyone may have
um I'm going to take the first question
for myself what does the State Police do
currently what is your policy on
custodial interrogations yeah custodial
interrogations I heard some testimony
previously but uh that was uh that's
unknown to me if that is in fact the
case that we require it however it is a
best practice uh there is there's no
doubt about it if uh if you're having a
custodial interrogation and you have the
means with which to record that that is
absolutely the best practice and we
encourage that
what I would uh there was a great deal
of and I don't want to rehash what has
already been uh uh discussed but there
was a great deal of discussion over when
is somebody when is it a custodial
interrogation I will tell you that uh
over the eight years I spent in our
major crime unit uh I did a number of
interviews in uh places of uh the back
seat of a vehicle uh on the side of the
road in a rest area in a McDonald's uh
there are any number of areas that uh
you you may record somebody that are not
a clean dry environment like this where
a camera system may be employed uh so
yeah it uh it very much varies in terms
of where you are and and I think that
definition of a custodial interview is
is incredibly important
is it possible a custodial interrogation
could happen for example on an OU IRS on
the way back to the station
by my interpretation yes uh yeah
absolutely you certainly have them in
custody they're they're not free to
leave they're in the back seat of your
car not only are they uh presumably
they're in handcuffs as well as they're
in a vehicle that they can't get out of
so I would say that anything at that
point uh aside from an excited utterance
from the the back seat so to speak uh
would be a custodial interview thank you
representative Rhodes
thank you for taking my
question I've asked this
about because I was a little bit
embarrassed that I didn't know the
answer to this question
and I apologize because I very well may
be opening up a hunu can of worms is
there a certain age that a person has to
be recorded if they're being arrested as
in a minor up to a certain age
I'm not familiar with any statute that
requires uh although I'm I'm certain
that he will not be happy I says maybe
attorney Halverson could speak to that
more eloquently but I'm not aware of any
statute there is Benoit warnings that
are required when you're going to
interview a juvenile and you read that
uh the warnings to that Juvenile and
there are lots and lots of caveats that
go along with that but I'm not aware or
I don't recall any specific
legislative statute that says you have
to record
representative boardnet
this is just a curiosity what does your
department do with recordings
so it really depends on the uh because
we have
for the State of New Hampshire we are a
larger Department uh
we have strict protocols on how things
will be maintained
however they may be slightly different
based on whether or not you're assigned
to a unit that uh is at headquarters or
a unit that is at a local Barracks but
typically now with our new uh RMS system
that recording is attached within the
RMS system there is a separate
there is a separate mode or nodule to
that uh to that system that is going to
deal with evidence digital evidence that
has not been activated yet so what we
will typically require is we will
require that that recording be made and
be put on an encrypted thumb drive and
be transported via that encrypted thumb
drive you try to have a triple
redundancy so you have it on your
recorder you have it on the thumb drive
and then you have it on a hard drive
that is assigned to an individual
Trooper so you have those three
locations should anything happen to that
specific piece of evidence but I think
what's important to note is we
acknowledge just what I was speaking to
representative Royer to the committee
about previously which is a best case
scenario is that you uh you you have
that in a digital format behind lots and
lots of firewalls
thank you
representative Platt thank you Mr
chairman thank you thank you for taking
my question you used an ackerman's
acronym so I just want to make sure I
understand it rms's records management
system it is sir I apologize for that
see enough further questions thank you
for your testimony thank you
very briefly
we are we are more than willing on the
issue of somebody who doesn't want to be
recorded we are more than willing to
write up an exception for the committee
in that circumstance those are not
uncommon exceptions around the country
in states that require recordings of
confessions and we're more than willing
to do that
thank you for that we'll take that into
consideration
that being the last witness I'm going to
go ahead and close the public hearing on
the Bell
we're going to go ahead and open the
public hearing on HP 1600
relative to the use of body cameras
and the chair recognizes representative
infantine
thank you Mr chairman
my name is Will infantine and I
represent Hillsboro 13 Ward 6 in
Manchester
um I'm here I'm sending out two handouts
I need to tell a story about how this
came to be this this are you submitting
this bill
this has to do with
the right to know and body cameras
there's a situation in the city of
Manchester or an individual
um
had a
an interaction
someone please silence their ice cream
truck
thank you
let's continue individual had an
interaction with the city employee
and that individual went to the
Manchester Police Department
and had an interview in a police report
was submitted and there were a number of
inaccuracies to the individual
statements
we only know this because of video
um
was obtained that showed some of the
items that were presented to the police
and state it occurred did not occur
so the individual was accused of doing
this requested a copy of the interview
from the city of Manchester Police
Department
they said the interview was done by Body
camera
so it is not
um open to the
right to know law
so I immediately read the law
and then got in the phone with the
honorable Neil Kirk
former uh representative and said is
this what you intended this to be
did you intend that that interviews
through body cameras
be not subject to 91a
so when I submitted the piece of
legislation again we all know what it
was like last year we had a week to put
bills together
and the initial bill
um
is presented in front of you here 1600.
the the point
at the time
was
as I find it
the point was to um
make it so if you did not have
you well okay I need to back up I
apologize so when another individual
questioned the chief of police in the
city of Manchester who I have great
respect for and who I I personally like
why did you utilize body cameras when
you have interrogation rooms with audio
and video
well that's upstairs and sometimes on
smaller type cases we don't bring people
upstairs we have them downstairs and
there's no audio or video downstairs so
we utilized the body cameras and so it
just so happens we utilize the body
cameras and the law says we don't have
to give it to you so
the question here is
the bill in front of you talks about
um that they can body cameras cannot be
used for interviews unless they uh don't
have any other facilities and I've said
I've given to you two parts of the RSA
chapter uh 105 D which outlines
um
where this bill says this should go it
adds another
letter right now it's a through H it
would add an i
stating that they cannot use body
cameras or interrogations unless they
don't have any other facility but the
more I think about this the more I think
this really needs to be revised under
section 9185
item 10.
which is the one piece of paper that
I've sent to you which outlines
um
that audio and video recordings
body cameras really can not be utilized
or accessed under 91a except for some
conditions a b and c
that's really where I believe this
belongs as the chief of police stated I
believe in this
committee last year transparency
transparency transparency those were his
quotes
um and I agree with that
and whether this was a simple
honest
situation where the law is what it is or
whether this was done on purpose
to keep that that interview
not subject to review I don't know
I don't care
I don't care to go back and rehash
issues the question is
whether or not
interviews done with body cameras are
subject to 91a or not and whether this
committee feels they should be or
shouldn't be
obviously when I spoke to representative
in Kirk about this you know the goal of
of the law was to make it so someone who
may be being the periphery
police are out on the scene there's all
kinds of stuff going on uh certain
things
um
if you and I happen to be
in the same area do we really want our
likeness and presented to the public of
maybe we were in a place where we didn't
want people to know we were in a certain
place
and I think that's what the point was
but I'm not sure the point was to allow
for interviews
to be utilized to utilize body cams and
then you could say sorry
not subject to naughty one day and I'm
not sure that is the intended it's sure
it's something I don't believe it should
be the intent so while my bill talks
about
eliminating the ability to utilize body
cameras for interviews
I would like the ability to amend my
legislation to really make it um
to place it under the 91a
91 A5 under the exemptions 10 and adding
another
um area another
there's a b and c adding d
to allow for this to be covered under
the 91a if the body cams are used
for interior for interviews and
interrogations
that's all Mr chairman
thank you
the witness is excused
all right
this time the chair recognizes Captain
Joseph Ebert
good afternoon everyone
again for the purpose of the record my
name is Joe Ebert e-b-e-r-t and I am a
captain with the state police overseeing
the Investigative Services Bureau
uh
we are opposed to this bill uh for a
couple of different reasons the first is
as you may remember from some testimony
that I gave a couple minutes ago the
state police has the occasion to be
throughout the entirety of the State uh
we are oftentimes in small police
departments and in very rural areas that
don't have recording mechanisms our
thought was that we would utilize that
uh that body camera to do just what we
uh what I discussed previously but I
would say again for the purpose of the
record in this bill which is uh in a
best case scenario you record both the
audio and the video of that interview
and what I would suggest to you is we
are outfitting each one of our Troopers
with a body camera and we were looking
at that as being a feasible means with
which to record uh interviews and
interrogations so on its base we would
say uh
we would like to utilize the body camera
the body worn camera for for that
purpose
um I I also wanted to just address uh I
understand exactly what the uh the
representative who put the bill forward
what his issue uh was
um but I at least put forward for the
consumption of the committee the notion
that uh it seems as though a discovery
request in a criminal proceeding would
supersede the uh the 91a exemption so in
other words uh if you were
um you know if you had obtained this
this body worn footage and you have this
but it uh somebody is challenging the
validity of an arrest you would uh
under rules of Discovery you would need
to provide that recording regardless of
uh the exclusion under the 91a statute
again that's that's my interpretation of
that but I for the purpose of this
committee I at least wanted to put that
out for consumption
having said that those are all my
statements I'm happy to answer any
questions
thank you the witness is excused thank
you
this time mature recognizes Dan Conley
good afternoon representative and the
committee members and thank you for
having me here Dan Conley captain of the
Goffstown Police Department
and I'm here today on behalf of the New
Hampshire Association and Chiefs of
police
uh we oppose this house bill 1600
um you know in every other occurrence
including the most severe use of deadly
force RSA 105 D2 is a trusted means to
record police encounters with citizens
um this bill would say that that is not
um a good enough record of a custody
interview
I would agree that the body won't camera
is a more secure means the data
retention as there is and has been
strict rules and permissions relative to
the deletion of any record recording
if an officer using a digital audio
recorder
there are no
if without the Bible Code there are no
automatic retention rules to protect
that file prior to it being stored on a
department-owned server
arguably a file could be manipulated
prior to its submission as evidence it
could be damaged and there there's no
safeguards in the case of the body won't
camera
there's no ability by the officer to
edit the audio or video recording in any
way prior to its saving
retention times are mandated by RSA 105
D2 based on the type of call for
services recorded when an officer
records a video they tag that video with
a category such as an arrest a traffic
stop or a non-crime
um call for service
when that goes into the Bodywork camera
software how long that video is it
determines how long that video is kept
according to the
um retention schedule before it is
automatically deleted but it is
safeguarded until those um until that
schedule is met
those durations are set and maintained
by administrator administrator access is
held in our department with the rank of
Sergeant or above
any changes to a particular video or
setting within the software are recorded
to show who made the change and when
basic access is given to every officer
and they have they are not able to make
any edits or changes to the videos
I would argue that body One camera is
more secure and more guaranteed method
of recording and retention
and as Captain Ebert said
it's handy it's on us
when I was talking
um earlier about where these interviews
take place you know in the police Lobby
sally port roadside the body worn camera
in our Department's always with our
officers
I've not I have nothing further
thank you for your testimony
and for the last witness we have Paul
and
both myself in the court were having
difficulty reading the writing today
probably my writing
I'm right there with you
good afternoon my name is Paul Halverson
I'm the Merrimack County attorney and
um I spoke with several County attorneys
about House Bill 1600 as it's introduced
and we do not uh support this bill as
it's introduced
some of the things that we're concerned
about with this is that
body warrant camera statute
105 D2 talks about use of body-worn
cameras
and the intent of the overall intent 105
D2 is to have a record of interactions
between the police officers and
individuals and to exempt the use of
body war on camera if the prior bill is
is passed frankly it doesn't make any
sense a recording is a recording no
matter what the methodology is whether
it's a body-worn camera or or otherwise
and to prohibit the use of a body
warrant camera would uh would would be
in opposition of the intent of the prior
stat of the prior
introduced
a proposed stat statute a couple things
that I would comment about
in relationship between this and the
prior the prior issue that that the
committee is is considering
it's interesting within the body worn
camera statute that the statute
addresses to be used only while on while
in uniform that's contained within
paragraph Roman 4 within the body worn
camera stat statute
there's an argument to be made that a
plain clothes officer is in uniform for
a department
however a a body more on camera used by
a plain clothes officer in recording a
statement
if it was allowed within a police
department
would if a court said a uniform is a
uniform and not plain clothes
would have to be destroyed by by Statute
even if it contained exculpatory
information
I would refer you to
105 D2 Roman
Romans 18 if you don't comply with the
statute you have to to destroy the video
even if it's exculpatory and frankly we
we see that as a as a weak point in 105
d d D2
overall though uh the uh you the
prohibition of using a body camera to
record a a Miranda custodian
interrogation makes sense and frankly
it's more cost effective than trying to
install cameras throughout throughout
buildings
other than that I'll defer to your
questions
thank you for your testimony thank you
the witness is excused
you may be recognizing representative
Infante
if it excuse me infantine
from
the
attorney County attorney who just spoke
would like to replace my bill entirely
with what he just said to resolve it I'd
be amenable to that
to resolve the issue he just outlined
thank you
at this time we will now close the
public hearing on House Bill 1660.
representative Marston you leaving the
room
oh excuse me 1600.
questions
at this time we are now opening the
executive session on
house bill 1682.
1682 it's establishing the law
enforcement conduct Review Committee and
the New Hampshire police standards and
training Council and making an
appropriation there therefore
representative Welsh do you wish to be
right
representative Welch who wish to be
recognized to make a motion of off the
pass as amended and offer an amendment
is there a second
that is second by representative board
name
do the members present all have a copy
of the amendment
representative Wells for the record can
you please State the amendment number
uh
we pass Amendment
2022-0112h
[Music]
and do you wish to speak to your
Amendment
correct a typographical error ill
and unfortunately the first amendment
that I had drafted was also wrong so
this is a second attempt this time we
got it right
but it does
it corrects
line
first line 29 on page 10.
and it replaces Roman numeral eight
with Roman numeral five on four on line
four of the amendment
and I did pass it by the uh the
attorneys that were here to testify on
the bill so I now I know it is
correct
thank you
considering the amendment is simply
fixing a typographical error
I will strongly
I will be supporting this amendment
I think we're almost ready to move the
question
I would advise the members to return to
the seats if you're not on the seat when
the questions move you cannot so let's
you support adopting amendment number
want to read the number David
zero one one two h
m in support of adopting an amendment
please say yay if you were opposed
please say nay the clerk will now call
the roll
it was seconded by representative Borden
the clerk will knock all the roll
yes
representative Roy
representative Welch
representative Burke
representative pleck yes
yes
representative testerman yes
representative true yes representative
Pratt yes
representative Marston
Kirk says yes pantovaccus
o'hern
e
news
no man
yes
golden Conley
quite night
Bradley
cheer the chair votes yes
18 to nothing the amendment has been
adopted
16 excuse me
we have more information we have five
minutes I mean no we don't we have three
out
should I redo it last term when there's
a difference no wait a minute
you check off green and you did say yes
correct I apologize 17. didn't check you
out
hey
Seventeen to zero the amendment is
adopted thank you representative you
wish to make a motion of
ought to pass as amended
that has been seconded by representative
Harry Catherine
I have a question
it was her Amendment before us uh
supported by uh uh uh uh
excuse me I'm looking for it here but
some point John Skipper regarding uh
duplicative language uh there's been to
be struck
it's my understanding that this
amendment addressed the exact issue that
was raised by uh officer skipper
coming into the committee I'm I'm just
coming up to speed
it's a problem
at this time that the matter now we put
the question if you can support the
motion of ought to pass as amended
please say yay if you were opposed
please say nay
yes representative
representative Platt yes
representative Greene
green representative Rhodes yes
yes true yes
Marston
yeah sure
yeah
Santa Lucas oh her what name
yes
Conley
fine night yes Bradley
I think 17-0 what about
chairman
the chair votes yes
by a vote of 17-0 the motion about to
pass those amended passes representative
wish to move for consent
and you'll be you'll be preparing a
majority report
this time we will now close the
executive session on House Bill
1682.
okay
at this time we're not going to open the
executive session on House Bill
10 31. we're giving law enforcement from
encrypting public frequencies
representative Wells do you wish to be
recognized to make a motion of index
being to legislate
I move we find House Bill 1031 and
experiential legislative
that's seconded by representative
boardnine
representative Welsh wish to speak to
the motion
representative wish to speak to the
speak
to them just briefly I think
I think Bill is
premature
mature I think that encryption adds
complexity to Communications in an area
that serves more than one
municipality including fire and Eminence
and police
and in situations where you are uh have
to make Split Second decisions being
able to go back and forth between two
different channels it adds even more
complexity I don't think we're ready for
this yet
thank you
representative Platt I I have comments
but they're encrypted
representative Burt you were recognized
thank you Mr chairman
I will be vote voting against the itl
I think there's issues with this bill
but there is a possibility of making it
work
so I will be not supporting the itl
representative Harry gath right
um
bring it closer can you hear me now
I think in testimony I heard that there
was a problem between the two two
different
groups of law and the federal government
when you have this encryption and
furthermore they hear that some towns
don't have it at all and some have
partial
but then there are at least one town
where it's completely encrypted I do
have a problem with that
I don't think it's necessary
I would just point out that the bill is
drafted as presented to the committee
there is absolutely no consequence
whether it's complied with or not and
the bill is just not ready for prime
time I think that the subject the
subject is worthy but I think with that
being said and we have a public hearing
that's supposed to start soon I think we
can
although representative Eric to respond
to that my comment
able to change the motion to um to a
study committee
you didn't make the motion did you
always do everything he says
perhaps we'll explore the idea of a
study committee after we move the
question on and experience allegedly
at this time the matter will now be put
the question if you in support of the
motion of index being to legislate
please say yay if you're opposed police
say nay the clerk will not call the roll
ER
representative Welch yes
representative
oh
representative Platt yes
yes
true yes
Marston
work best wrote snow
Panthers
one day yes
Newman no
vote in no
way yes
Bradley
I miss one you missed the the
representative from Raymond
representative Pratt all right
a problem
no
and
then let me fix him yeah
and chair
the chair of votes yes
one two three
I I also want to
by vote of 12 years and five Nays the
motion passes
representative you'll be preparing a
majority report
I guess oh
will it be a Minority Report
yes there will be
thank you representative Bert
at this time we'll now close the
executive session on House Bill
1031.
I just want to stand again I want to
thank representative Harry Catherine for
stepping it stepping up to be the clerk
today while representative walls could
not be with us today
uh Mr chairman
if I can have a question
verb statement point something I don't
know what I want you just want to talk
yeah I just want to talk we have a
public hearing that's supposed to start
but well before we go somewhere else um
I will know later if I'm going to write
the idea uh the uh minority blurb but in
case one of the other five or four
members want to write it
you know I may not write one I will
leave that up to the five of you to work
out amongst yourselves all right well
the public is not watching us figure
that out if it's not accepted by noon
time tomorrow we'll discuss it after
this hearing yes
yes this time we now will open the
public hearing on House Bill 1483
relative to the use of physical Force by
a law enforcement officer
representative true you are recognized
to introduce the bill
thank you Mr chair
members of the committee
for the record I am representative Chris
true Rockingham District 4. comprising
the towns of Auburn Justa and Sandown
Mr chair thank you for this opportunity
to introduce House Bill 1483 relative to
the use of physical Force by a law
enforcement officer
perhaps some members of this committee
will have a slight feeling of deja vu
upon hearing my testimony
Hospital 1483
is concerned with the criminal code
the general rule of Isa 627 colon 1
States
conduct which is justifiable under this
chapter
constitutes a defense to any offense
the fact that such conduct is Justified
shall constitute a complete defense
to any civil action based on such
conduct
House Bill 1483 amends Isa 627 colon 5.
Roman numeral 2.
by removing the justification by using
deadly force to affect an arrest
in other words
if House Bill 1483 becomes law
in a situation where a law enforcement
officer told the person who was running
out of Walmart with an arm full of
clothes to halt
and the person did not stop
in order to affect the arrest the law
enforcement officer shot and killed the
fleeing suspect
in that situation with House Bill 1483
becoming law
that use of deadly force would not be
justified
what house bill 1483 does not change
does not change at all is the legal
right of a law enforcement officer to
defend themselves
to defend others from the criminal use
of deadly force
House Bill 1483 does not affect at all
at all the legal right of a law
enforcement officer to prevent The
Escape of a person who has committed or
is committing a felony involving the use
of force or violence or deadly weapon
I have spoken to a number of law
enforcement officers and they have all
stated that they feel House Bill 1483
would interfere or prevent them from
effectively doing their job
and I asked them would you ever use
deadly force to stop a person fleeing
from Walmart with some stolen clothes
and they all said no they would not
shoot somebody because they were
stealing some clothes from Walmart
I then asked the question for which I
never got a reply that being the case
how does how would House Bill 1483
interfere with you doing your job
my position is that the removal of the
justification of the use of deadly force
to affect an arrest
which the police have told me they would
never use anyway
does not hinder or prevent law
enforcement offices from performing
their job in an effective and proper
manner
House Bill 1483 also amends The
Sovereign by removing the justification
for the use of deadly force based upon
what the law officer believes is
reasonable
if there is a question
whether the actions of a law enforcement
officer's use of deadly force most
reasonable or not
that math question must not be decided
by the officer
that question must be decided by others
such as Review Committee the Attorney
General
for the court system they are the ones
who decide whether somebody's actions
are reasonable or not
the law officer
Mr chair members of the committee thank
you for your time and your consideration
representative true if I can just ask
one question
under the existing law
what is the justification of not having
not permitting Force to prevent the
Escape but not
we're allowing a certain level of force
be used to prevent an escape and not
allow that same Force when affecting the
rest
um
the current law this is talked about to
prevent the escape from custody of a
person who has committed or is
committing a felony with the use of
force violence or deadly weapon
that's not being taken away from the
authority of the law officer
I'll rephrase my understanding is if
this bill were to pass
that
using that deadly force that you just
described would not be permitted when
affecting an arrest but it could still
be used to prevent a suspect from
escaping I'm asking what is the
justification of reasoning for having
permitting force a use of deadly force
to prevent some from escaping but not
allowing that same use of force when
trying to arrest the suspect in the
first place
if somebody is trying to escape custody
briefly with a deadly weapon
that doesn't change at all
I understand that but if they were
trying to uh when if they were using
that same
deadly weapon in attempting to escape
while they were trying to affect the
arrest basically fleeing that would not
permit it is the way I would read this
no
a law officer was justified in using
deadly force only when
so
if an unarmed person
not threatening anyone with any Force
or violence
is running away
that person under this law
may not be shot
there's no reason to shoot that person
if that person is carrying a weapon if
that person has a knife and is
threatening another person
and the officer may act as he must act
to protect others
um
all this all this change is
basically saying is
the state of New Hampshire is going to
erase what is now in law in law we give
the law officer the right
to shoot somebody if they are fleeing
from Walmart
with some clothes made out of from China
and they don't stop
right now the police officer has the
right the legal right
to shoot that person
and if
and and without any repercussions
because we've already said
that the uh
conduct which is Justified and it is
Justified under this chapter constitutes
a defense to any offense
so there's nothing can be said to that
officer now
for shooting somebody fleeing with
stolen clothes
if that person is fleeing
with stolen clothes and an armed weapon
that doesn't apply
represent representative Roy you were
recognized
thank you thank you for taking my
question
um
I see you've stricken out he reasonably
believes such force and replaced it with
reasonably necessary
where would a law enforcement officer go
to look and see what's reasonable
uh to the courts
to a
through a View Board
um
you're recognized for a follow-up
question
those are all after the fact but in the
instant for if I may give you an example
an officer pulls over someone the person
exits the vehicle it's dark the officer
says show me your hands and the person
reaches into the car is the officer
justified in firing his firearm or not
that would be in a court case that would
be decided in the court case it wouldn't
be decided then
it would be decided in court
continue to follow
you recognize for a follow-up question
and I'm trying to understand your
reasoning I agreed that they would all
be reviewed afterward in the court but
on the side of that road at 3 A.M what
does the officer rely on to to decide
whether or not he can discharge his
firearm when he sees someone reaching
into a car after he's ordered him to
show him his hands where does the
officer where does he how does he make
that decision whether or not to to
discharge his firearm he makes that
professional decision at the time based
on all all facts you know and what what
he can see and what he's surrounded with
um keep in mind
the reason why I removed that yeah
um
is
conduct which is justifiable under this
chapter constitutes a defense to any
offense
I thought I was being reasonable
well that's in the law as it stands now
if he felt he was being reasonable there
is his defense I am saying it's not up
to the office officer makes his best
choice best decisions they're not always
correct
um it's not up to the opposite of the
side whether it's correct or wrong
it would be up to his police chief the
board that reviews the situation or if
it's going to a court case
thank you
representative Platt
thank you thank you for taking my
question your bill would allow the
officer to use a Taser or other physical
means to stop somebody from fleeing I'll
pick on target rather than Walmart
um
yeah this only deals with deadly force
otherwise why keep Why Stop keep running
I think my general feeling is
the value
of some stolen clothes
is not worth
somebody being shot or losing their life
over
representative true cheer me inquired so
I understand the example you're using
someone's at a department store and
they're fleeing with with clothes
where under RSA 627 colon 5 does it say
that you can shoot an unarmed person in
the back running away with stolen
merchandise
the law officer is Justified and used in
deadly force
to affect and arrest
stop you're under arrest
stop
therefore the way the law reads now
he's trying to affect an arrest
and he's authorized to shoot
a law officer is Justified in using
deadly force only when
he reasonably believes such force is
reasonably necessary
to affect an arrest
and my point being
thank you that deadly force
is not worth somebody somebody's life
representative Rhodes
chairman representative are you familiar
with the terminology anything can be a
weapon with a proper imagination
no
would you agree that somebody could kill
somebody with a pen
thank you
but this deals with deadly force
thank you representative
representative green my apologies you're
recognized
thank you Mr chair
uh
there's an incident where a person
instead of running away with clothing
uh grabbed a lady's pocketbook and
forced her to the ground and her head
was bleeding
excessively and he's running away with
her pocketbook
wouldn't the police officer have the
right to shoot
um
has committed a felony
uh committing a felony involving use of
force or violence
using a deadly weather and attempting to
escape or otherwise indicates that
person is likely to seriously endanger
human life or inflict serious bodily yes
that's that's still in the law thank you
that's not taken away
thank you representative
this time the chair recognizes
Derek catalato
is it working now
um I'll try to make this brief I know
it's a Friday afternoon
so the first thing I'd like to address
is the representative was talking about
the the example of someone fleeing
Walmart
um
what he was describing is just not it's
it's not the case if you look at the law
um under Section B subsection one there
are some other standards that need to be
met before someone can shoot somebody in
the back as he said that person needs to
be committing a felony involving the use
of force of balance using a deadly
weapon and attempting to escape or
otherwise indicated that he's
endangering human life or will inflict
serious bottom injury so that scenario
that the representative
was describing is just not accurate
um
so that aside I'm going to be addressing
what we feel
is the most
um
kind of urgent part of this bill that
would cause serious issues for the law
enforcement community and that is the
removal of the reasonably believes
language from the statute
so my current assignment is the training
director for the Department I sit on our
use of force Committee in my written
testimony I put all my my credentials uh
I have 14 years experience I hold
instructor certification on basically
every tool a law enforcement officer has
and that reasonably believes language is
essential for a law enforcement officer
doing their job that
comes from the U.S Supreme Court case
Grand recliner which I'm sure everyone
is is familiar with
which gives law enforcement officers the
objective objective objective reasonable
standard
when applying Force so I'm just going to
read directly from chief chief justice
rehnquist majority opinion in that case
and that just outlines that standard and
why the reasonably believed language is
so necessary for us better than I could
kind of put it so I'll make it as quick
as I can he wrote the reasonableness of
a particular use of force must be judged
from the perspective of a reasonable
officer on scene rather than with 2020
vision of hindsight
you're going to say the calculus of
reasonableness must embody allowance for
the fact police officers are often
forced to make split sex and judgment
and circumstances that are tense
uncertain and rapidly evolving about the
amount of force that is necessary in a
particular situation
in my 14-year career I've been president
for three separate officer-involved
shooting incidents one of which my
fellow officers actions saved my life in
my opinion
each one of those situations were
extremely fast developing stressful
and required the officers to make those
split-second decisions only with the
information they had at the time
so those officers and any officers in
such an incident can only act with the
information they have that's kind of the
essence of the reasonably believes
language in that in the RSA
um our training in New Hampshire has
come a long way uh at the MPD we are now
given our officers 40 hours annually
training uh every year they get a
minimum of 40 hours which is a massive
increase from historically what New
Hampshire officers have gotten
much of that is
dedicated to de-escalation less lethal
and scenario training and this all the
training we give and all the training we
ever could give can only expect our
officers to respond with the information
they have at the time which is
basically what that reasonably believes
language is based in
um
so I think the most basic example of
this that can kind of illustrate it is
one that happens quite often you've seen
we all see in the news throughout the
country unfortunately is when a person
uses a toy or replica firearm in
confrontations with police officers
so if a person points a replica firearm
on an officer or a third party the
officer on scene reasonably believes
that deadly force is about to be used
against them or someone else
so they will be justified in firing
their weapon
now if you remove that reasonable belief
language and replace it with the
reasonably necessary
looking after the fact
it was not reasonably necessary to use
that Force because in reality that toy
gun
was not going to hurt anyone
okay so that is what that will do if you
take away reasonably believes it holds
officers to a standard that is basically
impossible for them to prepare for a
train for
um
furthermore as far as I in my you know
brief research every single state
in the United States has some form of
the reasonable belief language in their
deadly four statutes I cite a couple uh
in my written testimony
I could not find any state that has
anything other than that I think like I
said that all goes back to Graham V
Conor and that objectable reasonable in
the standard
um
so and I don't point that out to say New
Hampshire it needs to be like everyone
else because we are not we're a very
unique State and and
a lot of you know in a lot of good ways
in my opinion but for this specific
case it's a standard Across the Nation
and a standard and U.S Supreme Court
case law for a reason because of you you
cannot do your job as a police officer
in any other way all we can like I said
again all we can train for and all we
can prepare officers for
is to encounter and make decisions they
can for what they reasonably believe
uh at the time
so and
closing I was an honor to submit my
testimony today this is my first time I
apologize if I apologize if I was a bit
nervous or didn't make sense
um but
I appreciate it it was an honor and
please find this bill in an expedient to
legislate thank you
representative Marston
thank you Mr chairman
and thank you for your testimony thank
you sir
in your years of experience
and fellow officers that you associate
with
have you ever heard of an officer doing
something that the
representative brought up in his
demonstration of somebody shooting an
officer shooting somebody leaving a
store with clothes in their hands
no I haven't
um the closest thing I can think of
which would I cannot think of the name
of it
um
but I believe it was South Carolina
where the met with the officer it was on
video
shot the man in the back as he was
running and then dropped the taser on
him and that officer was correctly
charged with homicide and is now in
prison if you do that in this state or
any other state shoot a shoplifter in
the back with a handful of clothes
you will be arrested and charged as a
police officer I thank you
representative
did I just hear you say in so many words
that this bill is totally unnecessary
because you can't shoot somebody into
running anyway
existing law
yes sir in my opinion it is
um I'm going to ask a question myself
could you please tell the committee
under what circumstances you can fire at
a fleeing felon
so if for instance I'll give an example
of say an active shooter type call where
you arrive you have several people that
are injured you see a Suspect with a
weapon who is fleeing from you
that would be a case we could do it
where you reasonably believe that person
is going to continue to attack and
injure uh innocent civilians that you
can shoot a fleeing felon that's kind of
the most clear example I could give you
sir
under uh one more question and in your
experience in law enforcement
um how many times have you heard of
um any officers in New Hampshire firing
at a fleeing felon
I've heard I think there was a case in I
believe it was where
um
some years back where officers fired at
a vehicle that was driving away from
them I'm not sure the exact
circumstances but that's really the only
one that can come to mind
so it would be fair to say it's a rare
very rare occurrence extremely rare yes
sir thank you
see enough further questions thank you
for your testimony thank you very much
the chair recognizes Roger lamarche
a little bit wider than sergeant
catalato
good afternoon chairman Roy and members
of the committee I'm Roger lamarsh I
serve as a lieutenant for the Hudson
Police Department I've been with the
agency since December of 2004. and part
of my assignment as a lieutenant with
the police department I'm a usual Force
instructor from my agency
I also serve as a user Force instructor
for the Southern New Hampshire Special
Operations unit and I've also performed
functions as an instructor at the New
Hampshire tactical offices Association
SWAT school so I'm pretty well versed in
use of force training especially deadly
force
as invested stakeholders
police officers
we look in the mirror when we feel like
there are problems with law enforcement
because if there are problems with our
job we want to be a part of the solution
I'm not sure of any problems that we're
having in the state right now with with
people being shot
with without good reason
um it's just it's just not there you
would ask Sergeant Cataldo
and it's a very rare occasion if if at
all I can't think of any instances
um
when we train our police officers in the
state deadly force is a last resort
I can assure you every time an officer
is strapping on his boots
putting on her belt
the last thing they want to do is have
to discharge their firearm and the
execution of their duties
I don't have any issues modifying the
statute I I see some language in there
that makes the statute more gender
neutral obviously as police officers we
don't want to carry any bias or perform
our job with prejudice and if if there
are if there is language that's going to
make the statue apply to everyone more
effectively I'm all about that I don't
take issue with the language that makes
it more gender-neutral the concern I
have is is changing that statute like
Sergeant Cataldo spoke about is that
standard of objective reasonableness
we hold our officers to that standard
because these deadly force situations
are rapidly evolving
their their situations that are
obviously it's a it's a life or death
scenario
and there are three things that are
going to happen an office is going to
freeze they're going to fight or they're
going to run
and depending on what their action is if
they're they're presented with a deadly
force
concern they have to address that
appropriately not just to protect
themselves but our job is to protect and
serve the communities
and if we're not able to do that
effectively
and use deadly force when appropriate to
protect other people we're not doing our
job
um two thousand feet per second that's
just that's the average velocity of a
firearm round that's the time we're
talking about here officers are always
behind the eight ball we are reactive
the law as it stands right now levels
the playing field it allows us to do the
best job we can to weigh the
circumstance and take appropriate action
if the language change happens we don't
know who decides what that
reasonableness is and that's very
concerning when it comes to talking
about fleeing felons the U.S Supreme
Court has already addressed that with
Tennessee V Garner that's the fleeing
felon rule we go over Granby Connor
Tennessee V Garner Tennessee V Garner
I'm not going to get into that with too
much uh substance but it essentially
rules are out on using deadly force to
stop a fleeing felon unless those other
circumstances are present there has to
be deadly force and that's where we meet
it with deadly force so
um
you know
the concern to to change the statute is
going to cause our officers to have more
delay more hesitation
and then essentially cause possibly cost
lives
so I do have printed testimony it's a
heartfelt letter you'll be able to read
that
um
but
if there is a problem that we have in
the state with officers using
unreasonable Force the best way to do
that is not to legislate change it's
going to be to give us more training
and not just mandate the more training
but it is it's going to cost
we're going to need those resources to
give the officers the more training we
can provide unfortunately that does take
time and and everything else so
that's that's the testimony I want to
give it I get a little more depth with
that in my testimony and if you have any
questions I'll be more than happy to
answer
representative Newman
which
tell me another question is how the
removal of that particular
justification for the use of deadly
force
affects
the section section two Roman numeral
two where it says reasonably believes
that that is a lawful arrest so he's met
all the requirements of Roman numeral
two
then how does this relate to that and in
your opinion is that a problem or not it
is a problem Robert Newman I appreciate
that question uh you kind of triggered
my memory something I wanted to mention
is
deadly force the use of deadly force is
just a form of an arrest obviously if an
officer discharges a firearm at somebody
the end result could be death it could
be that's the reality if we're using
Firearms but our job when we use deadly
force is just to stop someone
immediately
it's just to infect an arrest that's
essentially what deadly force is so when
we use deadly force and we're trying to
stop someone from either hurting killing
someone else or just to affect an arrest
that's all the deadly forces for it's to
stop someone so if we remove the
language
relating deadly force to an arrest
it are we're handcuffed literally it's
we don't have many parameters that guide
us to decide when we can effectively
protect people and each other
thank you so just to clarify do you
believe that Roman numeral eight should
be removed or should not be removed
I don't believe that Roman numeral eight
should be repealed thank you say right
where it is
representative Burke you're recognized
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
your testimony
um the last speaker brought up the wear
incident and I represent Goffstown where
and Darren
if this bill passed
several years ago when the where
incident happened
would it have a different outcome
you know where the AG couldn't find
either way
or you know the taxpayers didn't have to
pay 350 000 excuse me before the witness
responds you're asking a police officer
to answer on behalf of the Attorney
General's office
I
didn't ask a question from the AG or
toward the AG I'm just asking him if
this bill of what happened in that
situation so I'm laying the the
story out I mean I think he understands
what happened there I I do apologize I'm
not familiar with the rare incident no
I'm sorry all right well I was just
wondering if there would be a difference
any difference is just
not allowing us to make the decisions we
need to make in those stressful
situations and that we don't always get
it right because we're human
but we do the best we can when we train
our officers to use the force
appropriately and I can tell you that
would be an absolutely terrible incident
if we have officers shooting people
fleeing Walmart just with merchandise
that that wouldn't happen in Hudson and
I can't see that happening anywhere in
this Granite State
I I can't speak more about the awareness
I'm just not that familiar with it all
right thank you you're welcome
thank you the win is excused thank you
at this time we'll now close the public
hearing
on
house bill 1483.
at this time we will now open the
executive session on House Bill 1483.
representative green you wish to be
recognized to make a motion
a motion to inexperienced legislate
representative Marston
representative Marsh and you have
seconded the motion uh to inexped into
legislate
do you wish to speak to your motion
representative Greene
no not at the moment
representative Rhodes
thank you Mr chairman
what really stands out to me is when the
officer spoke to the terminology being
removed where he reasonably believes
such force is necessary
to the example if the perpetrator has a
toy gun
um that is really what's resonating with
me that
this this whole bill I think has to go
away but you know removing that language
especially is is what really what this
whole bill is
representative Roy
um I'll be supporting the motion to itl
um
having having done this this job
particularly uh for a few years I had a
few occasions myself where I had to draw
my firearm and I can tell you no law
enforcement officer wants to to draw
their firearm no one's excited about it
no one's happy about it if you have to
discharge your firearm you know right
away
um regardless if you're right or wrong
you're done working for a while
um you're going to be subject to
unbelievable scrutiny both by the media
and the courts every second that that
went by will will be stretched out for
hours as people examine it where you
only had a second and it has an extreme
psychological effect on an officer just
having to draw their firearm I could
personally recall once
um for weeks I had I had nightmares
about whether or not I'd be able to
squeeze the trigger as much as I wanted
to in my dream I just couldn't couldn't
make my finger work it's a very
traumatic event it's not taken lightly
officers trained for unbelievable amount
of hours they the the technology they
use now and the shoot don't shoot
scenarios where they use video and and
it's just it's not something taken
lightly no one's out there anxious to
shoot anybody and it's it's just not
happening in the state this this
reasonable officers standard reuse is
the same standard use across the country
free and I don't think we need to
deviate it based on hypothetical
scenarios that have never happened here
representative true you recognized
thank you Mr chair
um
I have I've heard officers say that in
New Hampshire
you can't shoot somebody to affect an
arrest
they don't do it
and you can't do it
and it doesn't happen
and if we take away
the right
of an officer to do something they never
do
that's somehow going to affect
the Judgment down the road
if officers are never going to shoot
somebody simply to make an arrest
to remove the authority to shoot
should not be an issue
and I believe I'm going to have to
oppose the itl
thank you
representative Harry Catherine
I actually agree with my colleague on
the other side
um
the way I feel about that is that it
shouldn't this we're not just talking
about an arrest we're talking about
serious arrests we're talking about
um
what we talked yeah deadly force that's
what we're talking about here today
and so I have to agree that if if that
was taken away or this was this bill
became law that nothing would really
change from what the officer said here
today
so for me
I don't agree to the Ito
representative Bert you were recognized
thank you Mr chairman
not sure where I am on this
I'm back and forth but what I look at
is the wear case
you know that young stupid kid that
wanted to sell some drugs to a policeman
the member will suspend for a moment all
right
for what
it's an issue I'm you would suspend
you're referring to someone as stupid
and that is highly inappropriate given
the situation that you were talking
about and referencing you are correct it
is also
inappropriate
from a matter of that sensitive to just
refer to use that type of rhetoric
all right please please be careful with
the corner so I ask you are correct I
didn't mean the kid was stupid this
situation was so I do apologize if
anybody took that that kid was stupid um
so I do apologize for that I could see
how you could say that you know that I
would you know lean in toward that all
right the kid that went to where to sell
drugs to an undercover policeman
and he stopped
from what I understand the policeman
came up to him
um the kid just didn't like the
situation he says you know what I'm out
of here and he drove off
well he's dead
so I don't know if this law would help
that case
I know the taxpayers paid 350 000 to the
father
um the union leader pounded on the AG to
have a resolution to what's going on
with this case and where and the AG
finally said look we can't decide either
way so yeah I don't know either way
either because you know I wasn't there
but I just wondered if this law would
make a difference in that case and
that's all I'm looking at
um you know I don't think the police are
going to shoot anybody walking out of
Walmart you know and I hope people
aren't going to run to Walmart tonight
and steal
um you know and hope that's the case but
you know I I don't know it's just you
know we got to do something and what I
look at is I introduced a bill for
police reform a couple terms ago or last
term
um I can't remember who the guy that you
know the policeman stood on his neck
there or kneeled on his neck and died I
can't remember his name but
in that case everybody said John what
are you doing that Bill's going to die
well the bill is law now you know
because of that one incident so you know
I also look at that I say okay if we
pass this
in the representative that introduced it
you know could he stop one you know Bad
Apple from acting out and and causing
that I don't know
so I guess I'm just not sure where I'm
going to vote on this uh you know I
think it can go either way you know I
can see both sides thank you
clarify
for anyone listening anyone on the
committee it's already against the law
if you are do the fleeing felon Doctrine
was decided by the Supreme Court and I
believe in those sometime in the late
70s out of the case out of Tennessee
if this mere fact that a suspect is
fleeing and that alone does not give
a police officer the right to shoot that
person in the back what we have now RSA
625 colon 5. this law was adopted in
response to that Supreme Court case
if this example about someone fleeing a
department store getting shot in the
back under the existing law would be
illegal it would be an unlawful use of
force because it is this I'm going to
read them out loud right off the piece
of paper
you can defend themselves or a third
person
against the use of deadly force that's
one then you go to Roman numeral
it's Roman numeral to B1 committed or is
committing a felony using force or
violence so we're dealing with some type
of violent felony this is not when
affecting an arrest so the officer is
trying to arrest someone they are
encountering encountering violent
uh violent force in return when they're
trying to affect the arrest
using a deadly weapon and attempting to
escape so now an officer is trying to
arrest someone in the suspect is not
using a deadly weapon to escape or evade
that arrest
third case a situation or no fourth
excuse me
the person is likely to seriously
endanger human life or inflict seriously
body injury unless apprehended without
delay that is what the current law
in New Hampshire is on the books so if
someone is in a department store and
they steals clothes or whatever they're
doing and they try to run
a police officer is not permitted to
just simply shoot that person that is
not the law in the state
that's not what the laws on the books
today that is an incorrect application
of this interpretation I'm just
clarifying that it doesn't mean that
that may not persuade you to go one or
another just the application if that
were to happen
that is that is a crime that officer
would that would be investigated I can
imagine that officer would be arrested
and also they would I can imagine there
being a federal civil rights claim as
well
does anyone wish to speak who has not
spoken already
representative Newman
but uh can I make a question of the
chair just to clarify what you were just
reading that is the section of the law
it has it starts off with a a
requirement that has a colon and then it
has three sub paragraphs under
underneath that
does he have to meet
um all three of those or just one of
those and if it's just one I I'm re how
how do how do you read uh section two
the one that says he has made himself
known to be an officer
that's is that the only requirement that
needs to be met
so under Roman numeral
B1 it lists three circumstances that's
correct and you only need it it's any
one of those three circumstances you
don't need to encounter all three at
once so do you have an opinion about
section two it just seems as though he
just has to make it make known that he's
a police officer
it's then after that's under after Roman
numeral two B1 is followed by the word
and so then they got to satisfy next
section okay yes
so so one and two go together thank you
I missed the word in
this time the matter would not be put
will now move the question if you're in
support of the most of inix being to
legislate please say yay if you were
opposed please say nay the clerk will
now call the roll
he
apologize
representative Roy yes
yes
representative Platt yes
green yes
yes
representative Testament
yes representative true no
representative Pratt
I didn't hear him
representative Marston
clerk says no
representative pantalaka's
representative o'hern
representative bordenay
representative Muse representative
Newman yes
representative Bolton
yes
Conley yes representative
Bradley yes
you have to call my name Abbas
the chair votes yes
by about a fourteen to three the motion
of inexplained allegedly passes
with the majority report
there'll be a Minority Report and you
object to consent
foreign
report
you know what I'll write it
at this time we will now close the
executive session on house bill 1483.
we we could do one more executive
session if we go quick and we have a lot
of bills let's keep let's keep rolling
so we don't have to
I it should be one
representative true you know we'll talk
about this after let's get one let's get
one more exec in and then we'll
at this time we will now open the
executive session on House Bill
the chair will recognize
for 15 39.
all right no I understand but before we
I'm just going to explain if you're
going to offer if any member wants to
offer an amendment they probably should
because I already
the chair is a discretion to recognize
someone for a motion and that wasn't
really discussed with me or I haven't
reviewed it
and I was going to recognize
the representative representative Burke
who make a motion of ought to pass and
offer an amendment so
I don't
representative bird do you wish to be
recognized to make a motion of ought to
pass and offer an amendment yes I would
Mr chairman I would like to
offer an amendment with the ought to
pass motion
in is there a second
that has been seconded by representative
Marston
and represent
yes and Matt
I would love to speak on it Mr chairman
do you have an amendment to pass out the
side representative Byrne do you mind
reading your amendment number off yes I
would thank you uh it's
-0110h
someone was ordering them all
yeah I already passed
thank you
let me know
representative Byrne has been recognized
let him speak fearlessly of his great
Amendment and we'll go from there thank
you Mr chairman what my Amendment does
is if you look at law of the bill look
on the back page uh line 11 and 23
am I looking at the right bill
yes okay I am sorry
all it removes
yes it is I'm sorry it removes computer
system
in the word and that's it three words on
each of those lines that's all it
removes so that way it clears up what
the police are look you know the state
police gentleman said
you know that what do you mean by
computer system so basically what it'll
do is it'll remove
the name of what is public but not
deep down into their system
and you know when it comes to upon
request
you know I think it's just you know in
my eyes upon request is you know written
I don't think it has to state that
because I don't think in other
um
laws it states that it just says upon
your request so I think with the very
minor changes that I made
you know it will stay good with the law
thank you
representative Klein Knight
um
[Music]
on this amendment
you can see that upon request of the
person arrested is still not
um it's still
not described or defined if it's written
if it's verbal if it's online so I would
like you to please
um itl this amendment so I have made the
corrections on my Amendment if you
please take a look thank you so much
may I respond to that Mr chairman
we just we don't itl amendments we just
don't we just oppose them okay please
oppose this amendment so that a new uh
more comprehensive amendment can be made
Mr chairman
representative you may respond all right
thank you
in the past how I've seen this go
is you would support the amendment I put
forward and then if there was another
amendment brought forward and accepted
that would override my Amendment
but at least past mine and the reason is
you want to remove the computer system
in the word and out of there
so I don't know what's going to happen
if there is another amendment brought
forward but I also understand
when I looked into it upon request
you know it doesn't have to specify
written verbal or anything else because
if I was going to request anything of
course it would be in writing you know
it doesn't have to state that and and
the police are going to accept any
request
it's only smart to put it in right in
but it doesn't have to specify that so
please support my
you know six words being removed three
on each line of 11 and 23 and then if
there's another amendment we can talk
about that and if that's adopted
you know that's fine with me also once I
look at it thank you
you have to be recognized you don't need
to I know it's late and it's Friday and
representative Testament you're
recognized uh I have a problem
with an amendment if it tries to slip in
another subject altogether and the
second amendment that it was offered
talks about nobody there's been no
Second Amendment offered at this time
and and we can we're right now the
question is on
amendment number
2022-0110h that is the question
so the other Amendment may have some
good it may have some whatever we are
not that is not the question that is for
the committee right now
Mr chairman
Eric getting ready to vote on an
amendment one way or the other and you
know some of them are thinking
there's another amendment out there it
just makes a few tweaks and we need to
understand that it has been grossly
changed
we we can discuss that but the potential
of the other Amendment at the time this
question has been moved after this
question is moved so I can see my point
no I get the point that you're making
some you don't want people to vote
against one Amendment and hopes the
other I I to be honest and this
amendment has basically another bill we
had last year that didn't make it out of
it never made it to someone's desk for
Signature so I all I will tell you is
putting that onto this you may run into
some trouble somewhere else that's my
opinion that's all we're going to talk
about now so that's what we're going to
do representative Roy you are not
recognized thank you
um
I'm going to speak to the amendment but
it in in effect the overall bill because
it is the amendment I I think we it do
us well to do a little history
um quickly where do blood reports come
from this is a this is a civil rights
issue the police back in in in the day
people would go missing and they'd go
missing in the middle of the night and
nobody knew where they went and
sometimes they would be because the
police took them as a result of that we
made laws to make the police every
morning they would update who was
arrested and taken into custody
overnight this was to keep them honest
and so that we knew their activities
so
having that in mind
now we've come to the Future and now
well we don't really like that so much
because it's embarrassing for some
people and it's possibly it is but I
just want you to everyone understand
what we're what we're talking about
pulling back from was
um the fact that the police were able to
take someone and disappear them in the
middle of the night without any record
of where they went and who they are
so it this is a historical record this
person was arrested good bad and
different it happened they were arrested
it used to be not too long ago that it
would be in the newspaper it wasn't on
the internet because there was no
internet so every day if you recall once
most of us when there was a newspaper in
the morning you'd look at the blog and
see you got picked up last night
so now it's on the internet which unlike
a newspaper is forever so perhaps we do
need to look at the technological aspect
of this but we need to keep in mind why
we did this in the first place and why
this exists
thank you and I think the other concern
is just
is once it's on the Internet it's it's
on there and even if the state police
take it down or change your website it
may be
on other websites and and that this any
other third-party website that's not in
control of the state the state is not
under any won't be able to have any
obligation to do anything about that
representative Newman
must have a response to our question or
clarification for representative Roy's
comment
and it would seem to me that a person
who disappears in the middle of the
night has not been arrested so I'm I'm
not sure I can make the link
maybe they arrested him and did did
something nefarious with them but there
wouldn't be a record of his being
arrested at all I would I would think if
I could respond that's just the point
there would be no record they would they
would scoop somebody up well now they're
required to to make a record of everyone
they arrest and the public are able to
look at it and actually in some states
I'm not sure if it's this stapa if a
member of the public comes into the desk
of the police department says I'd like
to see the blotter they have to produce
it to anyone who comes and asks
representative Platt
I understand Representatives Roy's point
but nothing's changed and that there
will still be an arrest record it will
be permanent and the only thing that
will be changed after the fact upon
request is a public facing website but
the police still have the record and
it's going to it's going to appear in
the website at first and only be removed
later after request
representative Conley
thank you Mr chairman
um I have concerns about the underlying
Bill and won't support it as is but um
with the amendment and as I mentioned
earlier having dealt with this subject
very often back in the newspaper days
the best or perhaps a better way to
resolve this might be to do an addendum
that does not change the public record
um
but clarifies the result of the case but
further having again dealt with that on
a fairly regular basis when someone
would call out of the blue and make
start making demands of information
being removed in an identical situation
we would say Okay show us some proof of
this and there's nothing in this
amendment that requires that they
demonstrate this and of course this
information is available
but it's without that being clearly
specified it's going to create a whole
mess of problems for whoever has to take
these calls
oh
representative Klein Knight thanks
on uh you suggested that um it went
nowhere the other one I'd like to speak
to that if I may
um the what is in the other bill was
actually co-sponsored by representative
Troy and you introduced it to the Senate
and it unanimously passed this chamber
and it was on consent calendar I spoke
with the prime sponsor who agreed and
wanted me to do this for our city of
Manchester and the entire State and I
hope that you'll can you'll consider
that that this bipartisan effort of two
Representatives met and discussed how to
fix this bill and we had already agreed
on something similar before
so with all due respect chairman when
you say it went to somebody's desk and
didn't go anywhere was
I will clarify my comments it
that bill never passed in the other body
from what that I'm aware of
and then they're talking about the post
arrest photos which I went to the other
well I was on on a computer testifying
but I testified in front of the other
body in support of the bill that you
were the prime sponsor of Representative
Klein Knight I'm just what I was
cautioning was by taking the spirit of
that bill and putting it into this
amendment if that
if your other Bill did not make it out
of that body this whole if you support
the policy may not be wise to put them
together well it's just a suggestion can
I speak to that
Prime sponsor himself
noticed both of our intentions were
exactly the same because this is causing
a lot of public distress with pictures
and your name being up there and you're
innocent you can't get an apartment your
kids can't go to a certain school you
can't get the job I mean it's up there
forever and
we have the same intent for our people
in this bipartisan Manner and we need to
take this step and I I believe respect
for Prime sponsors wishes too and feel
free to reach out to representative
infantine about this but this is this is
at the request of the Prime sponsor
representative true
zero one one zero I think it's very
important that we removed the computer
system reference from the original bill
because it's the computer system that
holds the historical record that's where
the official record remains I also like
this bill because it doesn't start going
it just says upon request there's no
penalty of course if you have to call
the State Police twice or if you have to
send two letters I think just keep it as
simple as possible I don't see why the
state police would object to removing
something once they see that it's been
the case has been demised or wasn't
dismissed or wasn't processed at all so
I I support the the amendment uh zero
one one zero on the table
representative borne
um I agree with representative Conley
the underlying bill is has no purpose it
will not do anything
uh who was explained that the blotter is
a PDF that is sent out on a weekly basis
uh
that plot exists forever
an additional removal from the computer
database will make no change that PDF
that PDF is for one week the next a week
will have a different blotter that name
will not be on that blotter unless
they've done something else
I think that we are wasting time here I
think we are to forget about amendments
in ITF RTL this bill
representative Marston
incur with my learned appointed across
the aisle Mr bordenet
thank you
representative woodnay I concur
has anyone wish to speak was not spoken
already
all right
this time the matter will now be
put the question if you in support of
adopting
amendment number two zero two
two-0110h please say yay if you opposed
please say hey
the clerk will now call the roll
representative Roy
representative Welch no
representative Burt
representative Pratt
no
green
oh I'm sorry representative Rhodes no
representative Testament
representative true
yes
representative Pratt
representative Marston
representative oops can I go back
what was yours representative Pratt
yes okay that's my school I had trouble
hearing plant versus Pratt
representative Marston
okay thank you
uh
works
yes
representative Panter Marcus
representative representative Borden a
I said yes
representative Muse representative
Newman
representative Bowden
no
representative Conley
that way
cheer votes no
2013.
I had a vote of four years and 13
sorry yeah I'll let the clerk read the
results
just read the results we're still read
the results of the vote for the record
four years and 13 Nays
the motion the amendment motion to adopt
the amendment fails
I just don't understand 48 there aren't
that many people voting
I think it was four four yes votes 13 no
votes
representative Bert do you wish to
withdraw your motion of ought to pass
I will withdraw it and if somebody else
wants to make a motion that's fine
I'd like to make a motion
at this time the chair recognizes
representative
representative Borden to make a motion
of any speeding to legislate
I make a motion to
inexpensively is there a second
that has been second by representative
Marston
do you wish to speak to your motion of
index being to legislate yes I
understand the motivation of the sponsor
for this bill I don't think he
understood what it entailed uh and what
he wants to do is almost impossible so I
am going to recommend that we uh an
expedient to legislate this Bill thank
you
at this time the matter will now be put
the question if you support the motion
of inexp being to legislate please say
yay if you are opposed please say nay
the clerk will now call the roll
yes
representative Roy
yes representative Welch
yeah
representative Bert
representative Hopper from plant
yes
representative Rhodes yes
representative Testament
true no
representative Pratt
representative Marston
uh clerk says you know
had to representative pantalakis
representative o'hern
represent senator fordnet
representative Muse
representative Newman
representative Bolden no
yes
no
Bradley no
share the chair votes yes
and seven days
ten ten years and seven Nays
may I see may I see the role
will they be in my majority report reps
in the morning
anyone interested in a Minority Report
mm-hmm
whoever wants to do it I need to receive
it be nice tonight but tomorrow by noon
or it will be rejected
at this time we can now close the
executive session on House Bill
1539 and we will now adjourn